THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE
SELECT COMMITTEE PREPARING
CALIFORNIA'S FUTURE WORK FORCE-
I'M GONNA BE JOINED SHORTLY BY
WITH BY SENATOR STEVE GLAZER
I'M- GONNA TAKE AN EARLY
OPPORTUNITY THIS THANK HIM FOR
COMING. TO SACRAMENTO TO-
PARTICIPATE IN THIS HEARING AND
TO THINK ALL THE PRESENTERS
THAT ARE HERE TODAY- VERY
HONORED TO HAVE YOU- THIS THIS-
THIS WHOLE ISSUE OF WORKFORCE
PREPARATION IS CRITICALLY AND
IMPORTANT IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA WE'VE BEEN HALF
WE'VE HAD AN UNPRECEDENTED TEN
YEARS OF A BOOMING ECONOMY
WHICH IS MOVED US FROM THE
EIGHTH. EIGHTH GDP EIGHT NATION
IF WE WERE NATION IN THE WORLD
TO FIFTH AND- AND WHAT WE KNOW
IS THAT CALIFORNIA'S TENDS TO
SEE THESE EIGHT YEAR ECONOMIC
DOWNTURNS IN THE IN THE ECONOMY
AND SO WERE WERE ON PATH AT
SOME POINT TO HAVE A SLOWDOWN
IN THE ECONOMY BUT BUT DESPITE
THE FACT THAT WE'VE HAD THESE-
INCREDIBLE ECONOMIC GAINS THE
LOWEST UNEMPLOYMENT- A NUMBERS
IN- I WANNA SAY FOR DICK
DECADES. THERE ARE BEEN PARTS
OF THE STATE THAT HAVEN'T SEEN
THE SAME ECONOMIC UPTURN IN THE
ECONOMY AND SOME PARTS OF THE
STATE THAT CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
ECONOMICALLY AND- IT A LOT OF
THAT IS IT IS REFLECTED IN MY
DISTRICT WHICH IS THE TWELFTH
SENATE DISTRICT THE CENTRAL
VALLEY. THERE WERE FOUR ISSUES
OF GREATEST CONCERN- IT WHEN I
WAS WHEN I WAS HAVING MY HOUSE
MEETINGS AND THAT THE FOUR
ISSUES ARE INTRICATELY RELATED
TO EACH OTHER FIRST WAS WATER
SECOND WAS POVERTY AND CONCERN
THERE WAS WORKERS EARNING BELOW
THE POVERTY. LEVEL UP THE HIGH
COST OF HOUSING. RENTAL OWNER
FROM OWNERSHIP AND ECONOMIC
DEVELOPMENT AND JOB. REALLY
CONNECTED TO HOW YOU KNOW
WHAT'S THE WHAT'S THE MEDIAN
INCOME THAT PEOPLE EARNING AND
THE CENTRAL VALLEY AND WHAT CAN
YOUNG PEOPLE LOOK FOR TO IF
THEY STAY IN THE CENTRAL
VALLEY- IN TERMS OF A OF A
LIVABLE WAGER OR A WAGE THAT
THEY CAN AFFORD TO- TO BUY A
HOUSE OR TO REALLY RENT. A
HOUSE THEMSELVES WITHOUT HAVING
HAVE BY THEIR FAMILIES LIVING
WITH THEM WHAT WHAT I'VE SEEN
IN TERMS OF THE HOUSING MARKET
FOR MANY YEARS BUT IT'S BECOME
ACT EXACERBATED THE LAST- THE
UPTURN IN THE ECONOMY ACTUALLY
SINCE THE DOWNTURN IN THE- IN
THE ECONOMY WITH THE WITH THE
MORTGAGE MORTGAGE MELTDOWN IS
SIGNIFICANT OVERCROWDING. LONG
COMMUTES PEOPLE ARE MOVING
FURTHER AND FURTHER AWAY FROM
THEIR PLACE OF EMPLOYMENT LATCH
KEY KIDS THAT ARE LEFT FOR
HOURS BY THEMSELVES WELCOME
SENATOR DANGER I DO IN
ESSENTIAL FOR BEING HERE TODAY
APPRECIATE IT. VERY MUCH.
SOCIAL AND SECURITY THAT BEDS
CREATED WHEN FAMILIES OR ARE
FORCED TO LET AND ANNETTE.
RELATED FAMILIES ARE FORCED TO-
RENT TOGETHER IN ORDER TO
SURVIVE- SENIOR DISPLACEMENT
AND HOMELESSNESS ALL OF THESE
HAVE BEEN KIND OF FRONT AND
CENTER ON ON THE RADAR- ALL
OVER THE STATE IT DOESN'T
MATTER WHERE YOU WHERE YOU
LIVE. AND I'VE HAD THE
OPPORTUNITY RECENTLY TO DURING
THIS INTERIM TO DO TOURS AND
VISITS FOR A PROGRAMS IN THE
DISTRICT THAT PREPARE STUDENTS
TO ENTER THE WORKFORCE. AND
THAT THE PROPONENTS OF THOSE
PROGRAMS TALK ABOUT THE
DISCONNECT BETWEEN THE SKILLS-
DID THE STUDENTS HAVE IN THE
JOBS THAT ARE AVAILABLE OUT IN
THE COMMUNITY SO. THE CRITICAL
ISSUE IS GOING TO BE WHAT ARE
WHAT DO WE NEED TO DO TO BE
ABLE TO- INSURE THAT OUR
STUDENTS HAVE THE BEST
OPPORTUNITY- ANY WORKER IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA HAS THE
BEST OPPORTUNITY TO GET
TRAINING. THAT WILL PREPARE
THEM TO BE ABLE TO EARN EARN A
LOW WAGE WHERE THEY CAN.
ACTUALLY LIVE IN A IN A UNIT BY
THEMSELVES AND I HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH A COMMUNITY
COLLEGE- STAFF MEMBER-
ADMINISTRATOR AND THEIR
ANALYSIS IN MODESTO IS THAT. A
WORKER NEEDS TO EARN AT LEAST
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR IN
ORDER TO BE ABLE TO AFFORD TO
LIVE IN A COMMUNITY. AND OUT SO
ANYONE EARNING UNDER THAT WHICH
IS. BELOW THE POVERTY LEVEL IS
FORCED INTO THESE UNTENABLE
HOUSING SITUATIONS AND THAT
OBVIOUSLY IS NOT SOMETHING THAT
WE WANT TO KEEP PERPETUATING SO
THE GOAL OF THIS IN AN
INFORMATIONAL HEARING IS TO.
EXAMINE THE IMPACT OF THE LACK
OF SKILLED AND TRAINED
WORKFORCE. IT DID TO INQUIRE AS
TO WHETHER THERE IS A
DIFFERENCE BETWEEN URBANIZED
AREAS AND RURAL COMMUNITIES. TO
UNDERSTAND WHAT SOME OF THE
BEST PRACTICE MODELS ARE FOR
PREPARING THE WORK FORCE. AND
WHAT IS A STATE NEED TO DO TO
INCENTIVIZE A LONG TERM
COMMITMENT TO THOSE BEST
PRACTICES. AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT WERE PREPARING STUDENTS
FOR THE JOBS OF THE FUTURE TO
AND BUILD. BILL THE UNITS
NEEDED TO HOUSE OUR WORKFORCE
BECAUSE WE CAN'T DO THAT THEN-
WE'RE GONNA END UP IN A
SITUATION WHERE WE CONTINUE TO
SEE HOUSING BE ONE OF OUR
CRITICAL NUMBER ONE ISSUES AND
FRANKLY. PEOPLE CAN DISCOVER
PRETTY QUICKLY THAT- THAT THEY
MOVE WITH TEIR WITH THEIR FEET
INDEED THE GO TO OTHER
COMMUNITIES OTHER PLACES OTHER
STATES WHERE THEY CAN AFFORD.
TO EARN A LIVING THERE AND
AFFORD TO BE ABLE TO BUY THE
HOUSING UNITS THERE AS WELL SO
OBVIOUSLY NOT IN OUR INTEREST
TO DO THAT AND SO- THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND-
WITHOUT ANY FURTHER ADO WE'LL
GET INTO OUR HEARING BUT I WANT
TO. TURN THE MIKE OVER TO
SENATOR GLACIER FOR A FEW
COMMENTS. THANK YOU US CHAIR
IT'S GOOD TO BE HERE AND I
APPRECIATE YOURLEADERSHIP AND
CALLING THIS- HEARING AND
CONTINUING THIS CONVERSATION
THAT HAS GONE ON FOR DECADES IN
NEEDS TO CONTINUE TO GO ON FOR
DECADES BECAUSE A SKILLED WORK
FORCE IS SO CRITICAL- TO
CALIFORNIA TO OUR ECONOMIC
HEALTH TO THE WELL BEING OF OUR
OUR WORKFORCE AND OUR WORKERS
AND THEIR FAMILIES. SO I LOOK
FORWARD TO THE WITNESSES THAT
ARE COMING IN TODAY TO SHARE
THEIR EXPERTISE WITH US THANK
YOU FOR BEING HERE AND THANK
YOU THE CHAIR FOR. GIVING IN
THIS VERY IMPORTANT HEARING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH. SO WHAT
I'D LIKE TO DO IS INTRODUCE THE
FIRST A- PANEL AND IF YOU COULD
COME FORWARD- LOOKING HERE. I
THINK WE'VE GOT FOUR SEATS
THERE. ARE WELL IT WILL START
WHAT I DIDN'T SEE IF- PERFECT
TIMING- SAYS SAID VS IS- OUR
FIRST WITNESS. SAYS THAT THE SS
SERVED AS A LEGISLATIVE AND
POLITICAL DIRECTOR FOR THE
STATE BUILDING. AND
CONSTRUCTION TRADES COUNCIL OF
CALIFORNIA SINCE TWO THOUSAND
TEN. A PREVIOUSLY SERVED AS A
DEPUTY LEGISLATIVE DIRECTOR-
WELCOME- WE'RE HONORED TO HAVE
YOU HERE TODAY I'M GONNA
INTRODUCE THE REST OF THE
PANELISTS AND THEN. WE'LL LET
YOU GO- WILL START. AYE DAMON
CONKLIN DAMON IS THE DIRECTOR
OF GOVERNMENTAL AFFAIRS AT THE
SACRAMENTO REGIONAL BUILDERS
EXCHANGE A NON PROFIT
ASSOCIATION. THAT WORKS TO
IMPROVE THE HEALTH OF THE
CONSTRUCTION AND DESIGN
INDUSTRY. YES IF YOU COULD
PLEASE. HE SPECIALIZES IN
COMMERCIAL AND MULTI FAMILY
CONSTRUCTION IN CALIFORNIA. TIM
RAINY WAS APPOINTED BY GOVERNOR
BROWN TO THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD-
AND HAS INSISTED- IN THE
DEVELOPMENT OVERSIGHT AND
CONTINUOUS IMPROVEMENT
IMPROVEMENT OF CALIFORNIA'S
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT SYSTEM.
AND THEN MELISSA ROMERO MR
MERRILEES THE CALIFORNIA AT
LEAGUE OF CONSERVATION VOTERS
LEGISLATION LEGISLATIVE AFFAIRS
MANAGER AND IN THIS ROLE SHE
REPRESENTS THE ORGANIZATION IN
THE STATE'S CAPITAL LOBBYING
FOR STRONG ENVIRONMENTAL POLICY
AND WORKING WITH PARTNER
ORGANIZATIONS. THANK YOU ALL
FOR BEING HERE AND. SAYS THAT
WILL TURN THE MIKE OVER TO YOU
ALL THANK YOU SENATOR HOWARD
PAUL JOYCE- FOR MY TARDINESS.
NOW YOU WERE PERFECT IT WAS
PERFECTLY ON TIME- AND I
APPRECIATE THE YES WERE MISSED
MY WORDS OF WISDOM ALL YEAH
LARA. I'VE HEARD HIM BEFORE AND
I AGREE A 100% IT'S A GREAT
DANCER- THANK YOU CENTER GLAZER
FOR ALSO BEING HERE AND- FOR
GIVING ME THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DISCUSS THIS FROM BORDEN ISSUE
OUT THAT WE HAVE BEEN-
FOLLOWING FOR A LONG TIME AND
OF COURSE IS THERE DIRECTLY
CARLY DID WITH THE- ISSUE OF
LACK OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING OR
HOUSING IN GENERAL TO ADDRESS
THE- HOUSING NEEDS OF THE
CAMPUS A CALIFORNIA- WE DID.
ACTUALLY EARLY ON- COMMISSION A
STUDY OF TO LOOK AT THE ISSUES
IMPACTING THE INDUSTRY AND
WE'VE- FOUND SOME OF THE KEY
ISSUES RELATED TO THE ACTUAL
JOB QUALITY ASPECTS. OF WHY A
LOT OF WORKERS ARE CHOOSING TO
BE INTO THE RESIDENTIAL MARKET
NOW- BECAUSE OF SEVERAL FACTORS
RIGHT IN AND SO- WE WILL BE
RELEASING THAT STUDY- FAIRLY
SOON AND- THREE GET TO HEAR A
LITTLE BIT OF WHAT WE ACTUALLY.
COMPILED AND LEARN FROM THAT SO
OUR ULTIMATE THOSE OF TALKING
POINTS IN THE PRESENTATION TO
THE COMMITTEE AS WELL AND BE
GREAT OKAY SO. HERE'S WHAT WE
FOUND THE CALIFORNIA HOUSING
SUPPLY HAS LAGGED. A DEMAND DUE
TO DECLINING RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION PRODUCTIVITY. THE
COLLAPSE OF SINGLE FAMILY HOME
BUILDING AND THE X. URBAN
AREAS. BURGEONING INEQUALITY.
AND RESTRICTIVE LAMP POLICIES
FOR HIGH DEMAND LOCALITIES.
THESE FACTORS HAVE CONTRIBUTED
CONTRIBUTE TO A CRISIS
CHARACTERIZED BY LOW
HOMEOWNERSHIP HI RENTS AND SALE
PRICES. DISPLACEMENT AND
WORSENING HOMELESSNESS. STATE
OFFICIALS ESTIMATE THAT AT
LEAST ONE POINT EIGHT MILLION
NEW HOMES HOUSING UNITS ARE
NEEDED BETWEEN TWENTY FIFTEEN
AND TWENTY TWENTY FIVE TO KEEP
UP WITH THE POPULATION GROWTH.
THE GOVERNOR'S INDICATED THREE
POINT FIVE MILLION THAT'S A
HIGH NUMBER WHICH WE HAVEN'T
REACH SINCE THREE HUNT US SINCE
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX WILL REACH
THREE HUNDRED THOUSAND SO WORK.
WILL YOU HAVE TO RAMP UP TO GET
TO THAT NUMBER DEFINITELY WANT
TO BE PARTISAN DOING THAT. SO
WE NEED WE SEE THAT THE STATE
LEADERSHIP SUCH AS YOURSELVES
INTO ADDRESS OUR RELATED
FACTORS IMPACTING WHERE AND
WHAT TYPE OF HOUSING IS BUILT.
AND HOW IS IT HOW IS IT BRUCE.
THEY GET TO HAVE INCENTIVES FOR
SPRAWLING SINGLE FAMILY HOME
DEVELOPMENT AND IT INDUSTRIES
RELIANCE ON LOW WAGE. LOW SKILL
LABOR. ARE COLLIDING WITH
GROWING DEMAND FOR DENSER URBAN
LIFESTYLES. TODAY'S RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY SUFFERS
FROM A SHORTAGE OF
PRODUCTIVITY. WORKERS AND
CONTRACTORS READYTO BUILD
MULTI FAMILY HOUSING. AND FACES
LABOR MARKET COMPETITION FROM
ROCK NONRESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION EMPLOYERS OFFERING
BETTER WAGES AND WORKING
CONDITIONS. THE TRADITIONAL
MODEL USING UNSKILLED LABOR TO
BUILD SPRAWLING TRACK BOXES. ON
CHEAP SUBURBAN LAND HAS NOT
WORKED FOR CALIFORNIA. WHEN YOU
THINK BEG AND WE NEED TO THINK
OUTSIDE THE BOX. THIS WHY WE
SUPPORTED BILLS LIKE SENATE
BILL FIVE BECAUSE THEY DO HAVE
MORE OF A FOCUS ON THE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. AND IT ALSO
PROVIDES A COUNTER CYCLICAL
ECONOMIC STIMULUS FOR LOCAL
COMMUNITIES BY CREATING GOOD
QUALITY JOBS. THIS OUR BELIEF
THAT PUBLIC SECTOR CONSTRUCTION
ACTIVITY IS A PROVEN TOOL FOR
ECONOMIC GROWTH. IF WE CAN
BUILD DAMS BRIDGES AND POWER
PLANTS THERE'S NO REASON WHY WE
CANNOT BUILD MORE HOMES. THERE
ARE THREE TYPES OF PARTNERSHIPS
TO PROVIDE EXPERTISE AND
EXPERIENCE IN TO PROJECT
DELIVERY. BUILDING TRADES
UNIONS. TO PROVIDE THE BILL OF
THE SKILLED WORKFORCE AND A
PARTNERSHIP COMPORT
OPPORTUNITIES IN CONSTRUCTION.
AND PUBLIC AGENCIES WITH LAND
LEADERSHIP AND RESOURCES TO
MAKE LARGE SCALE PROJECTS
FEASIBLE. LEGISLATIVE EFFORTS
TO LOOSEN RESTRICTIONS ON
APARTMENT BUILDING AND OPEN
MORE ARE ALREADY DEVELOPED
AREAS PROMISED TO FIX THE WHAT
AND WHERE PART OF THE STATE'S
HOUSING PROBLEM. HOWEVER THIS
THEY MUST ALSO ADDRESSED THE
HOUSE OF PRODUCTION AND ENSURE
THE INDUSTRY HAS A STABLE
SUPPLY OF SKILLED WORKERS TO DO
THE BUILDING. SO FAR REPORTS
CALL THE HIGH. HOUSING HI ROAD
REPORT. AND WAS COMISSION
EARLY IN TWENTY NINETEEN THIS
IS WERE IT FIND SOME OF THOSE
NUMBERS CALIFORNIA WILL NEED
BETWEEN TWO HUNDRED FIFTY SEVEN
THOUSAND AND THREE HUNDRED AND
FORTY NINE THOUSAND RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS WORKERS.
IN ORDER TO MEET ITS AMBITIOUS
HOUSING PRODUCTION GOALS AND
BASICALLY DEPENDING ON WHAT
THOSE PRODUCTION GOALS ARE.
WITH ONLY A HUNDRED AND GIVE ME
TO SURE AGAIN IS AT NEW NEW
WORKERS THE WORKERS YES. WITH
ONLY AROUND A HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN THOUSAND RESIDENTIAL
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN. CALIFORNIA
NEEDS TO DOUBLE OR TRIPLE ITS
WORKFORCE EMPLOYED IN NEW
HOUSING CONSTRUCTION. THE LA
METRO AREA REQUIRES BOUGHT A
HUNDRED THOUSAND RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS AND SAN
FRANCISCO BAY AREA NEEDS ABOUT
FIFTY SIX THOUSAND WORKERS TO
MEET GOVERNOR NEWSOME'S HOUSING
PRODUCTION GOALS UNDER
HISTORICALLY HIGH WORKER
PRODUCTIVITY SCENARIO. LA WILL
NEED MORE THAN A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO THOUSAND RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS IN THE BAY
AREA WILL NEED NEARLY SEVENTY
SEVEN THOUSAND IF PRODUCTIVITY
REMAINS AT CURRENT LEVELS.
LINKING PREVAILING WAGE RATHER
FAIR WAGE STANDARDS WELL
ACTUALLY AN APPRENTICESHIP
PROVISIONS TO ANY LAND USE
RELATED REGULATORY CHANGES
WOULD HELP ACHIEVE THESE GOALS.
CONSTRUCTION WAGES AND BENEFITS
ARE TYPICALLY 15% OF TOTAL
MULTI FAMILY RESIDENTIAL
PROJECT COSTS. AND RECENT
RESEARCH SHOWS A MINIMAL COST
IMPACT FROM PREVAILING WAGE IN
SUBSIDIZED MULTI FAMILY
CONSTRUCTION. TO ACHIEVE ALL
THESE HIGH NUMBERS ON FOR A
LONG TIME WE HAVE BEEN WORKING
WITH CITY CALIFORNIA IN THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT AGENCY- TO ALIGN
THE WORK FOR SYSTEM AS IT
RELATES TO CONSTRUCTION. AND
ARE NOW AS IT STANDS THE CITY
CALIFORNIA LOOKS AT WHAT'S
CALLED THE MULTI CRAFT CORE
CURRICULUM MORE MC THREE. AS
THE APPRENTICESHIP THE PRE
APPRENTICESHIP CURRICULUM OF
THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA MEANING
THAT ALL LOCAL WHIPS USING MC
THREE MODEL AND ALSO WAS
INCORPORATED INTO THE SP ONE
THE ACTUAL OF ROAD ROAD
CONSTRUCTION AND MAINTENANCE.
OF FUNDS TO ATTRACT MORE PEOPLE
INTO THE TRADES- THERE ARE
CERTAIN CROPS THAT ARE GOING TO
BE WORKING ON ROAD MAINTENANCE
AND CONSTRUCTION BUT NOT ALL
THE CRAFTS WE REPRESENT-
FOURTEEN CROSS BUT THERE ARE
FIFTEEN IN THE BUILDING TRADES
ALL TOGETHER WHICH INCLUDE THE
CARPENTERS. MULTI CRAFT QUIRK
ALERT CAM OF INSURERS THAT.
WHOEVER IS INTERESTED IN
CONSTRUCTION HAS ACCESS TO ALL
OF THESE DIFFERENT- TRAITS AND
SO IF THEY'RE INTERESTED IN
THIS SPECIFIC TRADE AND IF
THERE'S AN OPPORTUNITY THERE'S
A HIGHER LIKELIHOOD THAT THAT
PERSON WILL CONTINUE THROUGH
THEIR- APPRENTICESHIP. AND
APPLY FOR SOMETHING WHERE
THERE'S ACTUAL NEED FOR THEIR
WORK. ON CERTAIN AREAS WILL BE
SATURATED WITH A LOT OF WORKERS
ALREADY SKILLED IN ROAD
MAINTENANCE AND SO FOR THAT
REASON THE MULTI CRAFT CORE
CURRICULUM WORKS FOR A LOT OF
THOSE LOCALITIES. SO LOOKING
OUT PRODUKTIVNOSTI NUMBER OF
HOMES BUILT BY THE SECTORS
WORKFORCE IS CURRENTLY LESSEN
SEVENTY FOUR PERCENT. OF ITS
NINETEEN NINETY TWO THOUSAND
FIVE AVERAGE. THE RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION WORK FORCES ALSO
GROWING OLDER YOUNG WORKERS ARE
EMPLOYED IN HOME BUILDING AT
LOWER RATES THAN OTHER SECTORS
OF THE CALIFORNIA ECONOMY.
SINCE NINETEEN NINETY THREE THE
SHARE OF HOUSING CONSTRUCTION
WORKERS BETWEEN THE AGES OF
EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY FOUR AND
TWENTY FIVE AND THIRTY FOUR IS
ONLY 68% OF ECONOMY NIGHT WIDE
AVERAGES. WORKERS OVER FORTY
FIVE HAVE BECOME OVER
REPRESENTED BY TWENTY EIGHT
PERCENT. IN THE HOUSING SECTOR.
HIRING RATES FOR HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION WORKERS BETWEEN
THE AGES EIGHTEEN AND TWENTY
FOUR AND TWENTY FIVE AND THIRTY
FOUR ARE JUST 73% AND 78%
RESPECTIVELY OF THEIR NINETEEN
NINETY THREE LEVELS.
CONSTRUCTION WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PRIMARILY A CURSE
YOU JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS FUNDED
BY EMPLOYER CONTRIBUTIONS FOR
EVERY HOUR WORKED THESE UNION
AFFILIATED PROGRAMS GRADUATE
OVER 90%OF THE STATE'S
CONSTRUCTION APPRENTICES.
CURRENTLY WE HAVE ABOUT SIXTY
FOUR THOUSAND APPEARANCES IN
THE STATE ANA APPROVE SYSTEM IN
CONSTRUCTION. ARE WE HAVE
ACTUALLY REACHED A GOAL THAT'S
SMALL IN COMPARISON TO WHERE WE
NEED TO BE BUT ITS HISTORICAL
IN THE SENSE THAT WE REACH NOW
FOR TWO THOUSAND WOMEN IN OUR
PARTNERSHIP. SIXTY TO SEVENTY
PERCENT- IS THE MINORITY
REPRESENTATION. OF THESE
APPRENTICES IN THESE PROGRAMS
AS WELL. ON THE RESIDENTIAL
HOMEBUILDING SECTOR IS ALMOST
UNIFORMLY NON UNION THOUGH AND
HAS NO SYSTEMATIC WAY TO
DEVELOP OR TRAIN ITS WORKFORCE.
AND I'LL JUST TRY TO FINISH UP
A LITTLE BIT SLOWER BUT MORE.
EXPANDING A PRODUCTIVE
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION
WORKFORCE AS RAPIDLY AS
REQUIRED WILL BE CHALLENGING
DUE TO COMPETITION FROM ROCK
NONRESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION. IS
BASICALLY EMPLOYERS OFFERING
HIGHER WAGES AND STRONGER JOB
SECURITY. ADDITIONALLY
INCREASED CONCENTRATION AND
CONTRACTION IN THE HOMEBUILDING
SECTOR HA THAT CALIFORNIA WITH
FEWER HOMEBUILDING CONTRACTORS
EMPLOYING FEWER PEOPLE PERFORM.
THE INFRASTRUCTURE AND NON
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION
SECTORS HAVE CONSISTENTLY PAID
HIGHER WAGES THAN RESIDENTIAL
BUILDERS SINCE NINETEEN NINETY.
THE WAGE GAP BETWEEN
HOMEBUILDING AND NON
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION SECTOR
EXCEEDS 40% GROWING PUBLIC
INVESTMENT WILL EXERT A STRONG
PULL ON CONSTRUCTION MARKETS
WITH TENS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS AUTHORIZED AN EXTENSIVE
INFRASTRUCTURE AND SUBSIDIZED
HOUSING INVESTMENT COMING
ONLINE IN MAJOR METROPOLITAN
AREAS PROPOSITIONS ONE AND TWO
AND OF COURSE OTHER BONTA
HAPPEN OUT THERE. SINCE TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX THE NUMBER OF
FIRMS AND MULTI FAMILY
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION IS
DOWN BY MORE THAN 33% STATE
WIDE WHY EMPLOYMENT IS DOWN BY
MORE THAN TWENTY SIX PERCENT.
THE AVERAGE FIRM NOW HAS 244%
FEWER WORKERS. SO AGAIN
CONCENTRATION AND CONTRACTION
AMONG HOME BUILDERS IS UNEVEN
THROUGHOUT THE STATE. WHILE BAY
AREA MULTI FAMILY GENERAL
CONTRACTORS HAVE MAINTAIN
STABLE NUMBERS AND INCREASE
EMPLOYMENT THE NUMBER OF MULTI
FAMILY GENERAL CONTRACTORS IN
LOS ANGELES SAN DIEGO AND
SACRAMENTO. ARE DOWN THIRTY
FOUR PERCENT. 51% AND 56%
RESPECTIVELY. WITH EVEN STEEPER
EMPLOYMENT THE CLIENTS AS
CALIFORNIA GRAPPLES WITH POLICY
CHOICES TO BUILD ITS WAY OUT OF
ITS HOUSING SHORTAGE THE
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION ENTRY
MUST PROVIDE DESIRABLE AND
STABLE JOBS TO ASSEMBLE A
WORKFORCE CAPABLE OF ADDRESSING
THE PROBLEM. THE RESIDENTIAL
SECTORS LABOR CHALLENGE
NECESSITATED HIGHROAD APPROACH
BILL AROUND LIVING WAGES AN
ONGOING INVESTMENT IN A
PARTNERSHIP TO CREATE A STABLE
SUPPLY OF SKILLED WORKERS WITH
THE FLEXIBILITY TO BUILD
HOUSING. AS WELL AS COMMERCIAL
AND INFRASTRUCTURE PROJECTS
THANK YOU. EACH PROCEDURE YOUR
TESTIMONY WILL WAIT IN AND ASK
QUESTIONS OF THE PANEL
AFTERWARDS. AFTERNOON THAT
MADAM CHAIR AND CENTER GLAZIER-
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR. CREATING
THIS OPPORTUNITY TO DRAW
GREATER PUBLIC ATTENTION TO-
WHAT WE BELIEVE IS ONE OF THE
SINGLE MOST CHALLENGES FACING
OUR INDUSTRY- THE SEGMENT
REGIONAL BUILDERS EXCHANGE IS
MADE UP OF- ELEVEN HUNDRED
MEMBER COMPANIES. THAT OPERATE
IS GENERAL CONTRACTOR SUBS
ARCHITECTS ENGINEERS AND THE
PROFESSIONAL ORGANIZATIONS THAT
SUPPORT THE INDUSTRY. OBVIOUSLY
WE RECOGNIZE A CALIFORNIA IS
EXPERIENCING HOUSING SHORTAGE
BUT EQUALLY WE'RE EXPERIENCING
A SKILLED WORKFORCE A SHORTAGE-
DURING THE LAST ECONOMIC
RECESSION WE LOST TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF JOBS- THAT DID
NOT. RETURN WIN THE- ECONOMY
RECOVERED. AND HAS CREATED A
VACUUM OF A RATIO OF FIVE TO
ONE SO FOR EVERY. AVERAGE
WORKER AROUND FORTY YEARS OF
AGE THAT IS SCHEDULED TO
RETIRE- OUT OF- THE
CONSTRUCTION THE TRADES WE HAVE
ONE IN THE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAM. TAKING LOOKING TO TAKE
THEIR PLACE AND- THE EFFECTS OF
A FLOODED INTO- THE HOUSING
MARKET WERE INVENTORY CRUNCH
HAS PRECIPITATED- BY THE
SKILLED WORK- SHORTAGE- HAS
CAUSED DELAYS IT IS BECAUSE-
PRICES TO RISE AND FOR MANY
CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES ARE
FORCED TO PASS UP ON
OPPORTUNITIES TO BID. WE'VE
SURVEY TO OUR MEMBER COMPANIES
AND- THE- THE- THE RESULTS- I
THINK- REFLECT BOTH STATEWIDE
AND NATIONWIDE OF 8083% OF OUR
MEMBERS SAYING THEIR TOP-
PRIORITY IS CLOSING THE SKILLED
WORKFORCE CAPPER DEFICIT. WE
HAVE- SEVERAL PROGRAMS THROUGH
OUR EDUCATIONAL FOUNDATION THAT
WE HAVE TO SCALE BRINGING OUT
TO SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA AND
ACROSS THE STATE SAYS A- STATE
TRADE TODAY- THAT WE JUST HELD
TWO WEEKS AGO AT THE-
EXPOSITION CALIFORNIA FAIR RED
DEAD NEARLY TWO THOUSAND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS- THAT- CAME IN-
AND- VIEWED US OVER SIXTY
VENDORS ARE OR MEMBER COMPANIES
THAT SHOWCASE THEIR PARTICULAR
TRADE WITH HANDS ON DISPLAYS-
AS A WAY TO. GET THE KIDS TO BE
EXCITED AND TO LEARN HOW YOU
CAN BUILD A SUCCESSFUL CAREER-
IN THE CONSTRUCTION WITHOUT THE
BURDEN OF STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
OBVIOUSLY THE STATE HAS MANY
CHALLENGES AHEAD THE GOVERNOR
HAS A VERY AMBITIOUS- GOAL THAT
HE HAS TASKED US WITH OF
BUILDING THREE POINT FIVE
MILLION AFFORDABLE HOMES BY THE
YEAR TWENTY TWENTY FIVE. AND
THE LEGISLATURE HAS
PRIORITIZED- IT PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE AND
TRANSPORTATION PROJECTS HIGHER
EDUCATION AND K. THROUGH
TWELVE- PRESUMABLY IF THE
VOTERS PASSED WITH YOUR YOUR-
MEASURE AS WELL- FIFTEEN
BILLION DOLLARS WORTH OF
EDUCATIONAL FACILITY
CONSTRUCTION PROJECTS- SB ONE
DOLLARS OF FIVE POINT TWO
BILLION- COURTHOUSES DETENTION
FACILITIES HOSPITALS. JUSTIN
SACRAMENTO ALONE WERE
FORECASTING SEVEN BILLION
DOLLARS IN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS
FOR PLANNED DEVELOPMENT. WE
CANNOT OUT SOURCE LABOR AND WE
CAN ONLY AUTOMATE SO FAR- AND
NOT TO SCALE- WE HAVE TO AS A
STATE PRIORITIZE CAREER TOWARD
A CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
WE'VE PARTNERED SUCCESSFULLY
WITH. STATE BUILDING TRADES IN
CALIFORNIA MANUFACTURERS AND
TECHNOLOGY ASSOCIATION- IN
TRYING TO. EXPAND THE STATE'S
INVESTMENT OF THE CITY GRANT
PROGRAM- IN ORDER TO. BRING
THAT TO SCALE AND TO MAKE SURE
THAT THOSE OPPORTUNITIES EXIST
TO GROW THE MIDDLE ECONOMY
AGAIN WITHOUT STUDENT LOAN DEBT.
WE REALLY MUST CHANGE THE
NARRATIVE FOR DECADES WE HAVE.
CHANNELED MOST YOUNG STUDENTS
TO HIGHER EDUCATION- MEANWHILE
THE COST OF TUITION FOR HIGHER
EDUCATION HAS OUTSTRIPPED- ANY
OTHER COMMODITY AND- SOMEHOW
THE NARRATIVE HAS BEEN LOST TO
THE DECADES THAT CONSTRUCTION
IS JUST LOW PAYING DIRTY JOBS
AND THAT IS COULD BE FURTHER
FROM TE TRUTH THEIR INNOVATIVE
THEY'RE EXCITING IN THERE WELL
PAYING JOBS- AND WE NEED TO.
GET KIDS TO BE EXCITED ABOUT
THEM. I HAVE WITH ME I'D LIKE
TO SHARE AT LEAST THE BALANCE
OF MY TIME- WITH- ONE OF OUR
MEMBER COMPANIES BROWN.
CONSTRUCTION THEIR CEO RON
BROWN. WHO'S BEEN BUILDING
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES IN
CALIFORNIA AS WELL AS
COMMERCIAL AND INDUSTRIAL
PROJECTS. FOR LAST- SEVERAL
DECADES HE'S THE PRESIDENT CEO
OF BROWN CONSTRUCTION. THANK
YOU I WILL BE BRIEF AS WE KNOW
THAT THE THERE SO I AM RON
BROWN PRESENT SEAL BROWN
CONSTRUCTION OR MULTI STATE
LICENSED CONTRACTOR. BASED HERE
IN- SACRAMENTO- WE BUILD
PRIMARILY OF AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND- APARTMENTS SENIOR HOUSING
SENIOR LIVING WE DO KNOW- A
SINGLE FAMILY HOMES. ANYMORE
WE'VE BEEN AROUND SINCE THE
NINETEEN SIXTY FOUR SO IF. WE
KNOW THE TURF A LITTLE BIT- WE
KNOW THE PROBLEMS THAT EXIST AS
WE'RE TALKING ABOUT OUR NUMBER
ONE PROBLEM TO DATE IS-
SHORTAGES OF LABOR- ACROSS THE
BOARD THAT ACCOUNTS FOR. THE
HIGHEST COSTS A TRIBUTE TO THE-PROJECTS TO DATE BECAUSE WHAT
IT'S DOING IS YOU CAN'T GET
LABOR SO THESE AT NIGHT. FOR
ALL TRADES AND IT IS INCREASING
IN THE PROJECT RATIONS ABOUT A
MONTH PER YEAR. SO OUR FEES
ALONEABOUT A HUNDRED AND
THIRTY TWO HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS A MONTH. SO
YOU CAN SEE WHERE THIS STARTS
INCREASING THAT- JOB BECAUSE
YOU KNOW JUST. IN UNDER MILLION
DOLLARS THESE PROJECTS ARE
ALREADY VERY DIFFICULT TO GET
FUNDING FOR. SO IT HAS BECOME A
BIG PROBLEM OBVIOUSLY AND
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE BUT. TO
MISTER DE IS- QUESTION IS IT OR
STATEMENT AS TO THE HOW HOW DO
WE DO THIS- I'M VERY INVOLVED
WITH- PROFESSOR ANDERSON
ISRAEL'S HERE LATER- DEALING
WITH THE STUDENT AT THE COLLEGE
LEVEL- BUT WE ARE FINDING WE
HAVE TO GO. WE GOT A PEEL BACK
MUCH LOWER WE GET IT AT THE
JUNIOR HIGH WE GOT TO GET THE
HIGH SCHOOL AND THERE ARE
PROGRAMS IN PLACE- TO HANDLE
THIS BUT WHAT HAS HAPPENED IS
WE KNOW. THAT THE TECH CLASSES
HAVE BEEN STRIPPED FROM FROM
SCHOOLS PARTICULAR CALIFORNIA'S
WHAT WE FOUND- SO THE
INTRODUCTION INTO TRADES OR
WELDING CARPENTRY THIS SIMPLE
TOOL USAGE HAS BEEN REMOVED
FROM A LOT OF THESE- POTENTIAL.
EMPLOYEES AND- AND THEY'VE BEEN
FORCED TO GO TO THE COLLEGE
DIRECTION I MEAN I RI SIX
CHILDREN I DID THE SAME THING
I'M A GUILTY PARTY I CAME UP
THROUGH THE TRADES AND ALSO
WENT TO COLLEGE AND I SAID. HEY
THEY CAN NEVER TAKE THE COLLEGE.
DEGREE AWAY FROM ME GET THE
COLORS AGREE AND MICHAEL. I'M
NOT GET DOESN'T ON THE COLLEGES
BUT- YOU KNOW I DID A
DISADVANTAGE TO SOME OF MY KIDS
NOT REALLY SPEND A LOT OF TIME
WITH THEM TO. BRING THEM UP
THROUGH THE TRAITS AND HAVE
THOSE CONVERSATIONS NOW I HAVE
BEEN ABLE TO RECRUIT ONE OF
FROM BACK IN BUT- THE OTHER
FIVERR OFF TO OTHER THINGS THAT
ARE MORE ATTRACTIVE IN THEIR
MIND. THE BE THE TRAITS IS AS
YOU AS YOU'VE HEARD. THERE IN
ONE AN INDIVIDUAL CAN MAKE
FIFTY EIGHT DOLLARS AN HOUR
THAT'S- PRETTY GOOD LIVING IN
MY ESTIMATION- AND ISSUE
COMMENTED THE TWENTY FIVE
DOLLARS THAT'S AN ACCURATE
STATEMENT TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS
AN HOUR. AND WE DO A LOT OF
WORK FRESNO AND THAT CLOVIS
THAT AREA FOR DOUBLE HOUSING
AND SENIOR SPECIFICALLY SENIOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT TO FIND
TRADESPEOPLE IN THOSE AREAS AND
SO ANYWAY I'M HERE TO PLEAD
FOR. ANYTHING AN OFFER ANYTHING
WE CAN DO. WERE POISED AND
READY TO DO IT AS I SAID WE'RE
VERY INVOLVED AT THE UNIVERSITY
LEVEL- BUT IT NEEDS TO GET
LOWER AND I WOULD REALLY LIKE
TO SEE IN FUNDING BEING PUSHED
INTO THE- AT LEAST THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL FOR. AND TRADE
SPEED. MORE COURAGE THAN TALK
ABOUT THE GREAT THANK YOU THANK
YOU THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE
TODAY HOW MUCH PLEASURE THANK
YOU FOR THE TIME. DURING I
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
CHAIR- CENTER GLAZER- FOR
SOFTBALL I WANT TO SAY THAT I'M
HONORED THAT YOU'RE ON THE
STATE WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT
BOARD THANK YOU- AND LOOK
FORWARD TO CONTINUING TO WORK
WITH YOU. ON THIS AND OTHER
OTHER SUBJECTS ARE WORKFORCE- I
WANTED TO START BY- ADDRESSING
THE FUTURE WORK QUESTION
BECAUSE THE INTRODUCTION TO THE
HEARING WAS SO WELL WRITTEN- I-
WITH A STAFF PERSON IF HE'S
HERE PETER BUT HE'S A REALLY
NICE JOB TRAILER. DOES FOR YOU
DO EVERYTHING RIGHT. OF ONE
IMPORTANT- I THINK LEVEL
SETTING I POINT MADE BY THE
FUTURE WORK COMMISSION IS OUT-
HAD THREE FULL DAYS OF
HEARINGS- IS THAT MARKETS ARE
GOVERNED BY NATURAL LAW-
THEY'RE ACTUALLY GOVERN MOSTLY
BY SOCIAL NORMS CHOICES MADE BY
KEY MARKET ACTORS BUSINESSES
LABOR COMMUNITIES WORKERS-
CONSUMERS ARE AND I WOULD GET
BACK TO THAT AT THE END BECAUSE
I THINK THERE'S AN IMPORTANT-
CONVERSATION IT HAS TO BE HAD
ABOUT HOW YOU HELPED TO SHAPE
OF THE WORK FORCE THE LABOR
MARKETING CONSTRUCTION NOT JUST
TODAY BUT FOR THE FUTURE- THEY
WERE INDEED A SHORTAGE OF
AFFORDABLE HOUSING CALIFORNIA-
EVERYBODY AGREES- BUT IT'S NOT
A SKILLS PROBLEM NECESSARILY OR
SUCH JUSTICE SKILLS PROBLEM SO
I DON'T THINK THE WORK FORCE.
ANSWER IS THE IS THE RIGHT ONE
BY ITSELF. YOU WERE WORKERS ARE
CHOOSING RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION- WE'VE HEARD THAT
MANY TIMES- IS FOR SEVERAL
REASONS ONE IS THAT. WE'RE A
FULL EMPLOYMENT ECONOMY I AND
JOB SEEKERS HAVE A LOT OF OTHER
OPTIONS NOW- I TALKED TO A
TWENTY FOUR YEAR OLDS RECENTLY.
WHO STARTED IN AS A RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION WORKER CARPENTER-
DOINGS OF FRAMING AND STACKING.
TWO YEARS AGO WHEN HIS TWENTY
TWO YEARS OLD AND WORKED HIS
WAY UP TO TWENTY DOLLARS AN
HOUR WENT TO THE CANNABIS JOB
FAIR. SPONSORED BY THE
EMPLOYMENT DEVELOPMENT
DEPARTMENT RECENTLY I GOT A
CALL BACK- IN IS NOW WORKING IN
IN A DISPENSARY IN SACRAMENTO
MAKING THIRTEEN DOLLARS AN
HOUR- BUT FOR HIM IT'S SAFER
IT'S INSIDE OF YOU DON'T GET
SPLINTERS THE SIZE OF TWO BY
FOURS- IN YOUR BODY- BUT IN
ADDITION TO THAT AFTER A
HUNDRED TWENTY DAYS A
PROBATION. HIS WAGES ARE GONNA
GO UP AND HE'S GOING TO BE A
CARD CARRYING MEMBER OF THE OF
YOUR C. W. LOCAL EIGHT NEWS
GONNA HAVE BENEFITS AND HE'S
GOING TO HAVE A RETIREMENT
PLAN. OF YOUNG PEOPLE ARE
MAKING THESE CHOICES ALL THE
TIME AND I THINK THIS IS REALLY
HAVE AN IMPACT ON THE
AVAILABILITY OF WORKERS IN IS
IDENTICAL CONSTRUCTION
SPECIFICALLY. I'M. I THINK
WE'VE TALKED ABOUT. HERE THE
SALES ARE POINTED OUT IN TERMS
OF THE QUALITY WORKING
RESIDENTS RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION. WORK IS VERY
VOLATILE SO IT'S DIFFICULT TO
GET HOURS- THAT NEEDS TO BE
ADDRESSED- THE OTHER WILL BUG
JOB QUALITY ISSUES IN
RESIDENTIAL. RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION NEED TO BE
ADDRESSED AS WELL- WAIT STAFF
TO STILL A BIG PROBLEM THERE-
IT IS STILL DANGEROUS WORK- SO
I WANNA TALK ABOUT
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND
WHAT WE'RE DOING THE STATE
LEVEL- THROUGH THE CALIFORNIA
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD. TO
ADDRESS. WHAT I THINK ADDRESS
RESIDENTIAL- CHALLENGE BUT WHAT
WE'RE DOING MOSTLY COMMERCIAL
PUBLIC WORKS. THERE IS NO
SHORTAGE OF INTEREST. IN A
PARTNERSHIP OF FOR STATE
APPROVED A PARTITION IN THE
BUILDING TRADES. I AS YOU KNOW
THE TRADES RUN ROBUST
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS IS THE
GOLD STANDARD IN TRAINING FOR
THE WORK FORCE THEM- WE WANT TO
GET PEOPLE INTO. A PATHWAY IT.
IT TO STATE APPROVED A
PARTNERSHIP PARTICULARLY THE
CONSTRUCTION TRADES BECAUSE
THEY OFFER LONG TERM KERR IS IT
PAY WELL AND BENEFITS. OF
PEOPLE RETIRE IN THOSE JOBS.
IT'S NOT THE SAME IN
RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION. I
BELIEVE AND I THINK THE DATA
BEARS THIS OUT IF JOB QUALITY
WAS IMPROVED A RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION. I THINK YOU
WOULDN'T HAVE AS BIG A PROBLEM
IN TERMS OF RECRUITING PEOPLE-
OUR CHALLENGE FROM A WORKFORCE
PERSPECTIVE. I IS ACCESS TO
STATE APPROVED APPRENTICESHIP
FOR WORKERS FROM DISADVANTAGED
COMMUNITIES. WE ARE AIM AT THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. TO DEVELOP
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMITTEE
BASED ORGANIZATION SCHOOLS A
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S
SO WE CAN GET A DIRECT PATHWAYS
IN THE STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP- THESE PROGRAMS
THAT TARGET THE POPULATIONS WE
WANT TO SEE- WE WANT TO MOVE
THE NEEDLE ON IN TERMS OF
EMPLOYMENT- THAT MEANS.
FORMALLY PEOPLE WHO ARE FORMING
COURSE RATED JUSTICE INVOLVED-
AS WELL AS WOMEN IN THE TRADES
BUT ALL KINDS OF BARRIERS TO
EMPLOYMENT. THE JOINT.
APPRENTICESHIP TRAINING
PROGRAMS IN THE TRADES. ARE IS
ONE. IT WILL THE TRACES WHERE
THAT THE TRAINING IS ACTUALLY
HAPPENING IN THE JOINT TRAINING
PROGRAMS I THINK SAYS ARE
POINTED THIS OUT OF THE SEVENTY
THOUSAND. APPRENTICES AND IN
CONSTRUCTION 93% OR IN JOINT
LABOR MANAGEMENT- PROGRAMS. SO
FROM POLICY PERSPECTIVE WE'RE
TRYING TO HELP MOVE PEOPLE OUT
OF POVERTY INTO INTO GOOD JOBS
WE ONE HITTER WAGON TO WITH THE
TRAINING IS WITHTHE JOB WHERE
THE JOB QUALITY IS. AND WHERE
THE GOLD STANDARD IS IN
TRAINING- WE ARE INVESTING THE
CALIFORNIA WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. IN REGIONAL
MULTI CRAFT PRE PARTNERSHIP
PARTNERSHIPS. ACROSS THE STATE
IT'S CALLED A HIGH ROAD
CONSTRUCTION CAREERS IT'S A NEW
INITIATIVE IT'S ABOUT NOT NEW
IT'S FOUR YEARS OLD- WE HAVE
TWELVE CURRENT PARTNERSHIPS.
THAT INCLUDE BUILDING TRADES
COUNCILS MULTIPLE CRASS. A
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT BOARD'S
CAN BASE ORGANIZATIONS COLLEGES
AND SCHOOLS. FUNDING FROM SB
ONE IS GONNA HELP EXPAND THAT-
THAT WORK AROUND THE STATE
KNOWS PARTNERSHIPS OF MORE
PEOPLE GET TRAINED. GREENHOUSE
GAS REDUCTION FUND DOLLARS-
WE'RE JUST TARGETED- TO THE
SAME PROGRAM TO EXPAND EVEN
MORE ACROSS THE STATE IS
LARGELY THOUGH GOING TO CONNECT
TO PUBLIC WORKS IN COMMERCIAL
CONSTRUCTION BECAUSE THAT'S
WHERE. MOST OF THE PEOPLE WHO
WERE IN STATE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS ARE GOING TO WORK- SO
BACK TO. SHAPING THE FUTURE
WORK. TO INCREASE THE SUPPLY OF
WORKERS IN RESIDENTIAL
CONSTRUCTION I THINK
CONTRACTORS WHO WERE SKILLED
STRAITS PEOPLE FRUSTRATED STATE
APPROVED APPRENTICESHIPS. THESE
PROGRAMS CAN RAMP UP TO MEET
DEMAND- THEY'VE SHOWN OVER AND
OVER AGAIN THEY CAN RAMP UP IN
THE COULD RAMP DOWN- WE CAN
TALK ABOUT THE MODEL OF YOU
PROBABLY KNOW- OF- TRAINING IN
THE TRADES IN THE DISPATCH
MODEL. THE DETACHED NATURE.
NEGOTIATED COMMITTEE WORKFORCE
AGREEMENTS BETWEEN CONTRACTORS
IN THE TRADES. CAN HAVE THE
ADDED SOCIAL. PULLING NEW
APPRENTICES. FROM THESE MULTI
CRAFT FREE PRINTER PROGRAMS
THAT TARGET DISADVANTAGED
POPULATIONS. SO MORE WORKERS
FROM DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES
WE GET. QUALITY OF HIGHWAYS
CRUISING CONSTRUCTION. INCREASE
A VIRTUOUS CYCLE IF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING IS BUILT. BY WORKERS
WHO LIVE IN THE COMMUNITIES
WHERE THEY CONSTRUCTION IS
HAPPENING- THOSE SAME WORKERS
CAN AFFORD TO LIVE IN THE NEW
HOUSING. THOSE HIGH WAGES FUEL
THE COMMUNITIES ECONOMICS NOT
JUST IN THE SHORT TERM BUT
POSSIBLY FOR GENERATIONS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU VERY MUCH I
WOULD JUST WANT TO MAKE SURE. I
UNDERSTOOD BECAUSE THIS IS THE
FIRST TIME THAT I'VE HEARD. THE
CONNECTION. QUITE SO STARKLY
BETWEEN THE STATE APPROVED
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS AND-
AND HOUSING BUT WHEN I HEARD
YOU SAY THAT NINETY 596% ARE
NOT. IN HOUSING THERE IN PLAAF.
PROJECTS WHAT NOT 93% OF ALL
APPRENTICES IN THE STATE ARE IN
JOINT LABOR MANAGEMENT TRAINING
PROGRAMS- AND THOSE
APPRENTICESHIPS THEIR STATE
APPROVED ARE DISPATCHING
WORKERS PRIMARILY TO PUBLIC
WORKS IN COMMERCIAL
CONSTRUCTION NOT RESIDENTIAL.
THAT'S THAT'S AND THAT'S
IMPORTANT TO KNOW NEW BECAUSE
THEN WHAT. AT AS THE FLIP SIDE
OF THAT IS THAT. THAT HOUSING
CONSTRUCTION IS NOT BENEFITING
THOSE PROGRAMS. AND IT'S
PROBABLY WHY YOU SEE THAT HI A
WAGE THEFT ISSUE AND SOME OF
THE UNDERGROUND ECONOMY ISSUES
THAT WE'VE HEARD ABOUT FOR
YEARS THAT'S CORRECT AND JUST
TO ADD ONE MORE POINT. STATE
REPRESSION PROGRAMS OFFER
REQUIRE RIGOROUS SAFETY
TRAINING- WHICH IS REALLY
IMPORTANT AND A SUB SECTOR OF
CONSTRUCTION THAT IS RELATIVELY
RELATIVELY DANGERS. RIGHT
THAT'S TRUE. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH FOR THAT KIND OF CASH
PATIENT. THANK YOU SO MUCH CARE
AND CENTER CENTER GLAZER- THANK
YOU SO MUCH FOR CONVENING THIS
THIS IS A REALLY IMPORTANT
ISSUE AND I REALLY APPRECIATED
HEARING ALL OF YOUR
PERSPECTIVES AND KNOWLEDGE ON
THIS SSUE. SO I WANT TO TALK
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITY AND THE
OPPORTUNITY OF INVESTING IN
GREEN INFRASTRUCTURE MEANING
ALSO INVESTING IN THAT WORK
FORCE AS NEEDED TO BUILD THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. THE TRANSITION
AWAY FROM A CARBON INTENSIVE
ECONOMY MEANS BUILDING
INFRASTRUCTURE THAT WILL
TRANSFORM COMMUNITIES AND THAT
INCLUDES INCREASING ACCESS TO
SAFE AFFORDABLE AND HEALTHY
HOUSING. AND ALSO SUPPORTING
THE INFRASTRUCTURE NEEDED TO
STRENGTHEN THE ENTIRE
COMMUNITIES TO BE MORE
RESILIENT TO THE EFFECTS OF
CLIMATE CHANGE THAT ARE BEING
FELT RIGHT NOW. ADAPTING TO NEW
NORMALS LIKE MORE FREQUENT
EXTREME WEATHER AND RESOURCE
SCARCITY BY MAKING BUILDINGS
AND INFRASTRUCTURE GENERALLY
MORE EFFICIENT AND RELIABLE.
AND MAINTAINING A HEALTHY A
SUSTAINABLE AND HEALTHY LIVING
ENVIRONMENT THAT PROTECTS AIR
AND WATER QUALITY AND ALSO
ACCESS TO NECESSITIES LIKE
HEALTHY FOOD. AND DIFFERENT
TYPES OF TRANSPORTATION THAT
WORKS FOR PEOPLE OF ALL AGES
AND ABILITIES. WATER AND ENERGY
EFFICIENT HOUSING SUPPORTS
COMFORTABLE AND HEALTHY LIVING
CONDITIONS AND SHOULD ALWAYS BE
A PRIORITY IN HOUSING PROJECTS
AND BEYOND THE HOME
OPPORTUNITIES FOR NEW OR
UPGRADED INFRASTRUCTURE
INCLUDING UTILITIES. SIDEWALKS
PASS ACCESS TO GREEN SPACE AND
PARKS AXIS NEARBY JOBS GROCERY
STORES EDUCATIONAL
OPPORTUNITIES. ALL OF THESE
THINGS THAT I JUST MENTIONED
REQUIRE A WORK FORCE TO BUILD
THIS HEALTHY AND SAFE AND
SUSTAINABLE FUTURE. PAIRING
UPGRADING EXISTING
INFRASTRUCTURE FOR MAXIMUM
EFFICIENCY SAFETY AND
AFFORDABILITY IS ALSO AN AREA
WHERE THERE IS A WORKFORCE NEED
IN ORDER TO MAKE THOSE CHANGES
HAPPEN. BUILDING MORE HOUSING
ALSO MEANS THAT WE NEED TO
ADDRESS THE LONGSTANDING
CHALLENGES OF UPGRADING AND
REHABILITATING INFRASTRUCTURE
THAT SUPPORTS HIGHER DENSITIES
DENSITY DEVELOPMENT. SO FOR
EXAMPLE GRAY INFRASTRUCTURE- SO
THESE TYPES OF THINGS HAVE HAVE
TO BE UPGRADED IN MANY REGIONS
OF THE STATE TO MEET DEMANDS OF
INCREASED CAPACITY BUT ALSO TO
INCREASE- OR TO MEET THE
INCREASING EXPECTATIONS OF
STORM WATER FLOW DO YOU TO SEE
LEVEL RISE OR- ABOVE AVERAGE
RAINFALL EVENTS THAT AFFECT
DIFFERENT AREAS OF THE STATE
MORE FREQUENTLY. GRAY WATER
INCLUDE THINGS LIKE PIPES TOM
SWISS REGIMENT PLANS BUT SHOULD
BE COMPLIMENTED WITH THAT GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE COMPONENT. SO DO
YOU KNOW TO IN ORDER TO REDUCE
THAT THE RUNOFF QUANTITY BUT
ALSO INCREASE WATER QUALITY. SO
THINGS LIKE GREEN ROOFS BIO
SWELLS PERMEABLE PAVEMENT
CONSTRUCTED A RESTORED WETLANDS
OF IN RIPARIAN HABITAT CETERA
ALL OF THESE THINGS CAN HELP TO
RELIEVE STRESS ON THE SYMPTOMS
ARE ON THE SYSTEMS. AND WILL
ALSO SUPPORT THAT ADDITIONAL
HOUSING AND CREATE THOSE
RESILIENT COMMUNITIES TO
SUPPORT A GOOD QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR THE WORKERS WHO LIVE N
THOSE COMMUNITIES- SKILLED
WORKERS ARE ALSO NEEDED TO
UPDATE OUR TRANSPORTATION I'M A
MILK MOBILITY INFRASTRUCTURE IN
ORDER TO SUPPORT- YOU KNOW SAFE
AND SUSTAINABLE TRANSPORTATION
OPTIONS. IN THOSE COMMUNITIES
WHERE- WE ARE WE ARE BUILDING
IT AND DIGITAL HOUSING UNITS
MAKING IT SAFER FOR KIDS TO
WALK TO SCHOOL. FOR PEOPLE TO
BIKE OR WALK TO WORK IF THEY'RE
ABLE. AND NOT TO MENTION SAVING
LIVES OF THOSE WHO ARE
TRAVELING ALONG THIS AND SAFE
ROADS THAT DO NOT CURRENTLY
HAVE THE INFRASTRUCTURE TO
SUPPORT ABILITY OTHER THAN
CARS. THE REASON I MENTION THIS
IS BECAUSE WHERE WE BUILD
HOUSING WE HAVE TO ALSO
CONSIDER THE NEED FOR BUILDING
THIS COMPLETE STREETS AND- BIKE
PATHS BEST RAN BY. PATHWAYS AND
ACCESS TO LOCAL PUBLIC TRANSIT-
WE A PARKING RIGHTS THINGS F
THAT NATURE. REPRESENTING AN
OPPORTUNITY FOR THAT WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT TO HELP US TO REACH
THOSE GOALS AND TO ALSO HELP
OUR WORKERS. GET TO WORK
SAFELY. THERE'S NO DOUBT THAT
THE APPROACH TO ADDRESSING EACH
OF THESE ISSUES I'VE MENTIONED
WILL VARY GREATLY THROUGHOUT
THE STATE. HOUSING IS NEEDED
ALMOST EVERY AREA OF THE STATE.
AND THE OPPORTUNITY TO BUILD
HOUSING THAT IS LOCALLY
APPROPRIATE. AND DOES NOT
CONTRIBUTE TO DISPLACEMENT AND
ALSO SUPPORTS THE HEALTHY AND
QUALITY OF WHAT A GOOD QUALITY
OF LIFE FOR THOSE WHO LIVE
THERE. ONE OF THE NEW NORMALS
THAT MANY COMMUNITIES IN
CALIFORNIA CONTINUE TO STRUGGLE
WITH IS THE NEED TO REBUILD
AFTER NATURAL DISASTERS. LIKE
THE WILD FIRES THAT HAVE TAKEN
THE LIVES AND HOMES OF OUR
FRIENDS FAMILY OR CO WORKERS.
CALIFORNIA'S LONG WILDFIRE.
SEASON THREATENS HOMES AND
COMMUNITIES EVEN TODAY AS WE.
SPEAK AND IN THOSE REGIONS OF
THE STATE- THAT ARE AFFECTED BY
THESE HAZARDS THAT ARE FUELED
BY THE CLIMATE CRISIS. BUILDERS
ARE BECOMING REBUILDERS. AND
WITH THESE MORE FREE GET
FREQUENT AND WIDESPREAD NATURAL
DISASTERS WE HAVE TO THINK
ABOUT REBUILDING WITH THE
SAFETY AND THE HEALTH OF THE
SURVIVORS IN MIND. AND THAT
MEANS TAKING INTO CONSIDERATION
FUTURE THREATS OF NATURAL
DISASTERS AND RESOURCE
SCARCITY. AND RELIABILITY WHEN
REBUILDING HOMES NEIGHBORHOODS
AND ENTIRE COMMUNITIES. THE
STATE CAN LEAD BY EXAMPLE
THROUGH PROCUREMENT BY
PRIORITIZING SUSTAINABILITY OF
PROCUREMENT THE GUIDES THE WAY
THE STATE PLANS BUILDS MANAGES
OPERATES AND MAINTAINS
BUILDINGS- UPDATING THE BILL
AND BUILDING NEW BUILDINGS IS A
MAJOR UP. OPPORTUNITY FOR
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT TO
SUPPORT THOSE PROJECTS AND- I
ALSO WANTED TO TALK ABOUT KIND
OF WHO IS PART OF THE GREEN
INFRASTRUCTURE WORK FORCE
BECAUSE I THINK. THAT WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT NEEDED TO MEET
THESE GOALS. SO THE SECTORS
THAT WILL DRIVE OUR TRANSITION
TO A CLEANER ECONOMY INCLUDE
FOR EXAMPLE CONSTRUCTION
LANDSCAPING URBAN FORESTRY
ECOLOGICAL RESTORATION. WASTE
WATER AND MORE AND SOME
EXAMPLES OF THE SKILLED WORKERS
NEEDED FOR THE SECTOR IS OUR
ENVIRONMENTAL ENGINEERING
TECHNICIANS FOREST AND
CONSERVATION TECHNICIANS.
CEMENT MASONS CONCRETE
FINISHERS CONSTRUCTION LABOR IS
OPERATING ENGINEERS AND
CONSTRUCTION EQUIPMENT
OPERATORS HI PLAYERS REFERS
CONSTRUCTING A BUILDING
INSPECTOR IS JUST TO NAME A FEW
SPECIFIC ONES BECAUSE I THINK
IT'S IMPORTANT. TO BE EXPLICIT
ABOUT THE TYPES OF JOBS THAT WE
NEED TO SUPPORT IN ORDER TO
MEET OUR CLEAN ECONOMY IN CLEAN
ENERGY GOALS. AND WE HAVE TO
WORK TOWARDS NORMALIZING AND
MAKING AVAILABLE THE OPTION FOR
PEOPLE TO PURSUE SKILLED A
SKILLED TRADE CAREER AS IS
MENTIONED A FEW TIMES. PROGRAMS
LIKE APPRENTICESHIPS THE LAB
PEOPLE TO WORK AND STUDY. FOR
YOU KNOW TO WORK TOWARDS A
SKILLED TRADE CAREER WHILE
HAVING THAT PREDICTABILITY OF
KNOWING THAT THEY'RE GOING TO
HAVE A JOB WHEN THEY COMPLETE
THAT PROGRAM. AND NOT JUST A
JOB AT A WELL PAID AND STABLE
JOB. SO JUST TO NAME A FEW
SOLUTIONS AND SORT OF IDEAS AND
HOW THE STATE CAN WORK TO
ACCOMPLISH THESE MAJOR
INFRASTRUCTURE OBJECTIVES THAT
WILL HELP US TO SHIFT AWAY FROM
A CARBON INTENSIVE ECONOMY-
THINGS LIKE SUPPORTING EXISTING
EFFORTS AND PROVIDING
ADDITIONAL RESOURCES. TRAINING
AND EDUCATION TO ALL PEOPLE
WITH A FOCUS ON FRONTLINE AND
VULNERABLE COMMUNITIES.
WRECKING INVESTMENTS TO SPUR
ECONOMIC DEVELOPMENT WILL ALSO
PRIORITIZING FOR HIGH QUALITY
JOB CREATION. POLICIES THAT
STRENGTHEN WORKERS ABILITIES TO
BUILD SUSTAINABLE CAREERS. AND
INVESTMENT IN JOB TRAINING JUST
TO NAME A FEW- THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR INVITING ME HERE TODAY
I VERY MUCH APPRECIATE BEING
PART OF THIS CONVERSATION.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH I YOU- YOU
MAKE GOOD POINTS IN TERMS OF
SOME OF THAT. THE JOB
CLASSIFICATIONS THAT I HADN'T
REALLY EVEN THOUGHT ABOUT IN
TERMS OF. IN THE CHANGING. THE
CHANGING INTEREST IN FOCUSING
ON ON- GREEN. AND KIND OF THE
TRANSITIONS FROM URBAN TO RURAL
AND- THE INTERESTING VERY GOOD
WELL THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR
YOUR TESTIMONY WILL SEE IF-
CENTER GLAZER HAS ANY QUESTIONS.
GO AHEAD. THANK YOU CHAIR I
CABALLERO OUT I APPRECIATE THE
EXPERTISE AROUND THE TABLE- AND
CERTAINLY YOU'VE DONE A GOOD
JOB OF EXPLAINING- THIS KOREAN
NOT THAT WE ARE LIVING WITH
THEM- AT HI WHO CAN ARGUE WITH
THE IMPORTANCE OF A SKILLED
WORKFORCE- THE ISSUE OF WAGES
LIVING WAGES HOUSING
AFFORDABILITY- AND CERTAINLY
GREEN CONSTRUCTION I MEAN ALL
THOSE THINGS IN A MATCH UP WITH
A NO THE VALUES THAT WE HAVE
FOR WHAT WE'D LIKE TO SEE AN
OUT GREAT STATE OF CALIFORNIA-
BUT THEY DO COME INTO CONFLICT-
BUT EVEN IN ADDITION TO THOSE
THINGS THAT YOU'VE IDENTIFIED
TODAY. YOU KNOW WE HAVE SUPPLY
COST PEOPLE HAVEN'T TALKED MUCH
ABOUT THAT WE HAVEN'T TALKED
ABOUT UTILITY COSTS WE HAVEN'T
TALKED ABOUT FEES. IT'S GOOD
THAT WE DIDN'T TALK ABOUT
ZONING BECAUSE WE HAVE ANOTHER
HEARING AND I THINK HE WANTED
TO GET INTO THAT TODAY NOT
TODAY. BUT THERE'S SO MANY
OTHER THINGS OF THAT HAVE HAVE
CREATED THIS NOT THAT WE LIVE
WITH AND TODAY AND- I DO THINK
THAT. AND I KNOW WHAT THE NEXT
FILES GOING TO FOCUS ON THIS A
LITTLE BIT SO I'M LOOKING
FORWARD TO HEARING THEIR
THOUGHTS BUT- THAT EDUCATION
TRAINING REALLY ARE THE KEY. AT
SOME LEVEL IT'S ALL ABOUT
ECONOMICS AND IT'S ABOUT SUPPLY
AND DEMAND. AND YOU KNOW I
HEARD I HEARD A FACT- ALLEGEDLY
A FAX WOULD LIKE TO GET GET
YOUR REACTIONS TO IT. IS IT
THAT. I WAS TOLD THAT THERE ARE.
FIVE HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND
APPROVED. HOUSING UNITS IN
CALIFORNIA TODAY. NO WAY OUT.
ZONING ISSUE NO SECRET ISSUE
THESE ARE APPROVED UNITS- AND
THEY'RE NOT BEING BUILT ON AND
I KNOW THAT IN MY DISTRICT. I
HAVE A NUMBER OF PARCELS THAT
HAVE BEEN APPROVED FOR
THOUSANDS OF UNITS AND THEY'RE
NOT GETTING BILLED. SO THEY
ACQUIRE ASIAN THAT THE THOSE
LANDOWNERS OUR DEVELOPERS ARE
FACING. THAT INVESTMENT THE
RISKS THE REWARDS JUST NOT
THERE FOR LOTS OF THE REASONS
IN WHICH YOU GUYS HAVE JUST
CRIED RIGHT. ALTHOUGH THERE
SOME OF THEM ARE IN CONFLICT
WOULD WE LIKE TO PAY MORE OF
COURSE. BUT THEN WHAT ABOUT THE
ISSUE AFFORDABILITY SO THAT
THAT'S THIS NOT THAT WE ARE
LIVING WITHIN WE'D LIKE TO HAVE
EVERYBODY ABSOLUTE REUSS OF
COURSE. NOW RAISING COSTS. SO
IT IS AN INTERESTING KIND OF
NOT THAT WE ARE LIVING IN TODAY
AND HOW WE GET OUT OF IT. AND
GET OUT OF THE BASIC ECONOMICS
WHICH IS THAT- IF WE DON'T HAVE
THAT. YEAH THE SUPPLY. IT'S
GOING TO AFFECT THE DEMAND. AND
VICE VERSA AND SO. I WOULD BE
INTERESTED IN ANY REACTION TO
THE IDEA THAT- IS THE FIVE
HUNDRED FIFTY THOUSAND APPROVE
UNITS JUST UNDERSCORE WHAT YOU
HAVE SAID. WE'RE NOT PAYING
ENOUGH. WE'RE NOT HAVING A
SKILLED ENOUGH- WE- THAT THAT
THAT REALLY ALL FEEDS IN THE
SAME PLACE. THAT'S THAT'S
REALLY THE- THE DILEMMA
QUESTION WHICH I KNOW YOU'RE
WRESTLING WITH TO. I THINK YOU
HIT THE NAIL ON THE HEAD AS FAR
AS- EXAMINING. THIS ISSUE OR
THIS DILEMMA IN A HOLISTIC
MANNER OBVIOUSLY. LUXURY AND
HIGHER AND HOMES ARE BEING
BUILT BECAUSE THERE'S A MARKET
FOR THEM AND- MORE AFFORDABLE
HOMES ARE UNFORTUNATELY GETTING
PASSED UP BECAUSE THEY DON'T
PENCIL OUT. THERE ARE. IN MANY
CIRCUMSTANCES. THERE ARE
PROJECTS- THAT MEMBER EARLIEST-
CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES- ARE
HAVING TO FOCUS ON ON ONE
SECTOR AND AT THE RISK OR AT
LEAST- JEOPARDIZING OTHERS.
OBVIOUSLY LABOR IS 2025% OF
CONSTRUCTION OF THE HOME AND
THAT'S A HUGE SEGMENT- THERE
ARE- ENTITLEMENT COSTS THERE
ARE NON UTILITY IMPACT FEES
WHICH CALIFORNIA. TWENTY TWO
TWENTY THREE THOUSAND WHICH IS
TWICE AS MUCH THE TO
NEIGHBORING STATES. ALL OF
THESE COSTS- ADD UP ON TOP OF
EACH OTHER AND EVERY MONTH WE
PROBABLY INCREASED BY ABOUT A
PERCENTAGE POINT- AND THEN YOU.
SNOWBALL THAT INTO TERRACE AND
EVERYTHING ELSE THAT ARE
UNCONTROLLABLE. FOR EVERY
THOUSAND DOLLARS YOU INCREASE
THE COST OF A HOME YOU'VE KEPT
THAT HOME OUT OF REACH FOR
FIFTEEN THOUSAND FAMILIES. AND
WELL THAT'S A PART OF IT. WE
NEED TO LOOK AT A BUILDING
HOMES AT ALL LEVELS AND ALL
SCALES AND. WHETHER THOSE THOSE
HOMES ARE. BELOW YOU KNOW 50%
AM I OR IF THEY'RE ABOVE YOU
KNOW THE YOU KNOW A OR FOR
INSTANCE HAS GOT A ONE POINT
THREE MILLION DOLLAR AVERAGE
AVERAGE LUXURY CONDO. YOU HAVE
THE STILL THE SAME PEOPLE SWING
IN THE HAMMERS AND OPERATING
THE HEAVY MACHINERY. UP AND IN
LESS WE LOOK AT THIS UPSTREAM
AND INVEST IN CHANGING THAT
NARRATIVE IN GETTING KIDS.
EXCITED ABOUT THE POSSIBILITIES
OF A CAREER IN CONSTRUCTION
AGAIN WITHOUT COLLEGE DEBT-
THEN THESE. PROJECTS ARE GONNA
CONTINUE TO GO. ON BUILT OR
DELAYED ATADDITIONAL COST- IN
AND THEY'LL JUST BE SITTING
IDLY- IN MEANWHILE WILL JUST
BE. WAITING AND HOPING SO I
JUST OFFER THAT. UNLIKE THE
ADELANTO WOOD MISTER CONKLIN-
THIS SAID ON THEE ARE MANY
FACTORS WERE WHILE OTHERS
PERHAPS FIVE HUNDRED THOUSAND
UNITS ARE APPROVED IN AND NOT
GETTING READY TO BUILD. UP COST
MAY BE A FACTOR WILL DEFINITELY
SEE THE POINT HAVING ACCESS TO-
A SKILLED LABOR FORCE TO
ACCOMPLISH THE PRODUCT PROJECT
WITH PRODUCTION EFFICIENCIES.
CAN ALSO RELATE TO THAT- BUT WE
MISSED ONE POINT AND WHAT YOU
SAID CENTER AND THAT'S PROFITS.
RIGHT WHOCONTROLS THE PROFITS
AND THE TIMING OF THE
CONSTRUCTION ONCE YOU RECEIVE
THE ENTITLEMENT. AND THAT IS A
KEY COMPONENT OF THIS AND SO WE.
CONTINUE TO STRESS THE FACT
THAT THIS IS A CONGRESS SAID
THERE IS A LUXURY CONSTRUCTION
A MARKET RATE SORT OF SPEAK
PRODUCTION. OUT THERE BUT
WHAT'S MISSING IS THAT.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THE OF THOSE
PROJECTS THAT CONTINUE TO BE IN
NEED OF SUBSIDIES. HAVING A
SORT OF A PUBLIC PRIVATE TYPE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THERE IS A
PUBLICLY SUBSIDIZED LIKE WHAT
WAS AN ARTY GAZE FOR EXAMPLE A
BILLION DOLLARS A YEAR FOR
AFFORDABLE HOUSING THAT HAD THE
WORKFORCE PROTECTIONS ADDRESS
THAT ISSUE IT DID PROVIDE A LOT
OF UNITS AND PERHAPS THE
INVENTORY TO. BE IN COMPETITION
SOME OF THOSE HOMES WITH PRICE
ABILITIES WERE ALSO THERE-
THAT'S SOMETHING I THINK THAT
OF LEGISLATORS ARE GRAPPLING
WITH HOW TO ADDRESS THAT SORT
OF NOT ONLY THE REGULATORY
REFORM SO YOU'RE LOOKING FOR
BUT ALSO TO STRIKE WHEN THERE
IS GONNA BE THE SOURCE%
SITUATION WHERE THE ECONOMY
DIPS. THINGS CONTRACT AND
DEVELOPERS ARE NOT GOING TO
BUILD BECAUSE THE PROFITS ARE
NOT THERE FOR THEM AND SO
THAT'S NOT SOMETHING THAT YOU
CAN CONTROL YOU CAN CONTROL IN
THE SENSE THAT YOU COULD
PROVIDE PUBLIC SUBSIDIES WITH
STRONG CONDITIONS TO BILL THE
TYPE OF HOUSING THAT A LOT OF
WORKERS NEED TODAY. I MEAN
WE'RE SEEING THE PRICES GO UP A
WE'RE ALSO NOT SEEING THE WAGES
GO UP THE ACTUALLY THE DRESS
THAT I TRY TO ACTUALLY GO ON
AND BE- ELIGIBLE TO BUY A HOME
IN TODAY'S ECONOMY AND SO IF
YOU'RE ABLE TO. SUBSIDIZE IT
CONDITION IT ADDRESS THE
WORKFORCE ISSUES I THINK YOU
CAN HAVE THAT COUNTER CYCLICAL
RESPONSE TO THAT. SO IF I HAVE
A AT MANAGER RESPONSE AYE AYE I
SUPPORTED THAT WAS CENTER BILLS
WELL WAS IT SB FIVE YEAH I
SUPPORTED THAT AND I'VE
SUPPORTED RDAS AND- I THINK
GOVERNOR BROWN ACTED NOT OUT OF
THAT LACK OF INTEREST IN.
AFFORDABLE HOUSING BUT OUT OF
THE BUDGET CRISIS HE WAS FACING
BUT. AND I AND I AND I AND IN
OUR BUDGET THIS YEAR WE'VE DONE
A LOT TO TRY TO SUBSIDIZE
AFFORDABLE HOUSING AND I'VE
BEEN SUPPORTER OF THAT AND THE
SENATE HAS BEEN SUPPORTIVE OF
THAT. BUT WE ALL KNOW THAT THAT
IS NOT GONNA BE THAT THAT'S A
SMALL PART OF HOW GETTING OUR
WAY THROUGH THE SUPPLY PROBLEM
THAT REALLY IS I MEAN. I'D LOVE
SOME ECONOMISTS TALK ABOUT THE
BIG PICTURE OF HAVE OVER THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND UNITS AND HOW
MANY. EVEN THE BILLIONS THAT
WE'RE SPENDING WITHIN
GOVERNMENT ARE GOING TO
CONTRIBUTE TO THAT THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND I THINK I'D BE
PRETTY SMALL BUT I'D LOOK FOR
THE EXPERTS TO GUIDE US ON
THAT. THAT'S THAT'S THE DILEMMA
THOUGH RIGHT I MEAN SO IT'S A
PEOPLE WE'RE ALL WE'RE DOING IS
DOING LITTLE THINGS NOT THAT
THERE AREN'T IMPORTANT DON'T
MISUNDERSTAND ME- BUT THEY ARE
SMALL IN TERMS OF THE PROBLEM
THAT WE'RE FACING- THERE WAS A
STORY TODAY- THESE TWO WAS
ONLINE. TODAY BY CAL MATTERS.
ABOUT A DIFFERENT FORM OF
CONSTRUCTION- MY THE MODULAR
UNITS IS THAT THE RIGHT FOR HOW
THEY REFER TO THEM FACTORY
BUILT WITH. AND I'M SURE
THERE'S SOME ISSUES ABOUT THE
WORK FORCE THERE AND WHAT
THEY'RE BEING PAID. WHICH IS A
LEGITIMATE QUESTION- BUT IN
REGARD TO BUILDING IT FASTER
AND CHEAPER WE HAVE TO CHANGE
THE DYNAMIC I GET THAT OFF. I
KNOW WHY THE LUXURY HOMES ARE
STILL HAPPENING. BUT THAT'S
REALLY ALMOST A SIDE ISSUE TO
WHAT WE HAD GOT WHAT CAN WE AND
GOVERNMENT DO. THE CHANGE THIS
EQUATION TO GET OUT OF THIS
COURTNEY AND LOT THAT NOT THAT
WE'RE FACING. NO REALLY AND WE
HAVE TO DO IT IN A BIG WAY IT'S
NOT A LITTLE WAY I MEAN THERE'S
A REASON. THE ASPIRATIONAL
GOALS OF THE GOVERNOR WHICH WE
ALL APPRECIATE AND ADMIRE.
LET'S BE CLEAR IT'S FALLING
FLAT BECAUSE BUT WHAT DO WE DO
THIS YEAR. TO ACTUALLY ADVANCE
THAT IN A SIGNIFICANT WAY AND
WHILE WE APPRECIATE THE BUDGET.
AUGMENTATIONS AND THE REST
WHICH ARE VALUABLE AND KNOCKS.
THAT'S NOT REALLY. CONFRONTING
THE QUESTIONS THAT YOU GUYS
TALKING ABOUT HERE WHETHER IT'S
ABOUT. THIS SKILLED WORKFORCE
THE WAGE TO THE AFFORDABILITY
SO REALLY HOW DO WE BREAK IT
DOWN IN A SIGNIFICANT WAY I
THINK IT'S GETTING EVERYBODY
OUT OF THEIR COMFORT ZONE AT
SOME LEVEL. BUT WE HAVE TO JUST
BE WE HAVE TO BE HONEST ABOUT
IT. IS THE BIG PROBLEM IS
SIMPLE EITHER BIG ACTIONS OR
SIGNIFICANT. ACTIONS OVER A
PERIOD OF TIME TO REALLY GET
OUT OF IT. THIS IS THE DILEMMA
WE. FIND I THINK I THINK THAT'S
ABSOLUTELY TRUE AND I AM. I'M
NOT EXACTLY SURE WHAT THE STEPS
ARE THAT WE NEED TO TAKE BUT
THE M. I'VE BEEN TALKING TO A
LOT OF PEOPLE OVER THIS OVER
THE INTERIM. AND. I THINK IT'S
GONNA TAKE RETHINKING HOW WE
HOW WE HOUSE PEOPLE AND PART OF
THAT IS UNDERSTANDING THAT.
FROM MY PERSPECTIVE IN IN MY
COMMUNITY- THE RENTS IN SALINAS
IN OUR THREE THOUSAND DOLLARS
FOR A THREE BEDROOM HOME THREE
BEDROOM TWO BATH HOME. AND WHEN
YOU'RE MEDIAN INCOME IS
SOMEWHERE AROUND FORTY FIVE
THOUSAND DOLLARS- YOU HAVE A
LOT OF PEOPLE THAT EARNING MUCH
LESS. AND. AND THAT THREE
BEDROOM HOUSE WILL BE RENTED BY
THREE FAMILIES THAT EACH SHARE
A BEDROOM AND THEN- AND
EVERYTHING ELSE WHICH MEANS ARE
PROBABLY FIVE OR SIX CARS. THAT
DON'T FIT IN THE DRIVEWAY
THEY'RE STARTING TO CLOG THE
NEIGHBORHOOD AND- AND IT'S A
SIGNIFICANT. SOCIAL ISSUE
BECAUSE YOU DON'T KNOW WHO'S
COMING AND WHO'S GOING WHO
REALLY LIVES THERE AND IF
YOU'VE GOT A COUPLE THE
NEIGHBORS THAT ARE DOING THAT
IN YOUR NEIGHBORHOOD BEFORE YOU
KNOW IT THAT. YOU CAN REALLY
TELL THEM IT'S INCREDIBLE
PRESSURE ON THE INFRASTRUCTURE
OF A COMMUNITY. AND SO THE
QUESTION THEN BECOMES DOES IT
MAKE SENSE. TO ME BUILDING
TWENTY EIGHT HUNDRED SQUARE
FOOT. FOUR BEDROOM HOUSES OR
WHETHER WE SHOULD BE BUILDING A
MUCH SMALLER UNITS AND BUILT
AND BE BUILDING I'M IN A WAY
THAT CREATES OPPORTUNITIES FOR
PEOPLE TO MOVE INTO SOMETHING
THAT SMALL. I BET THEY CAN
AFFORD TO BUY AND THEN CAN MOVE
UP ECONOMICALLY. BECAUSE. FROM
MY PERSPECTIVE. THAT THE
PRESSURES ON ALMOST THE IN THE
ENTIRE PART OF MY DISTRICT IS
IT IS REALLY EMBEDDED UP UP
AGAINST THE SILICON VALLEY SO
UP A LOT OF THEIR COMMUNITIES
ARE IMPACTED BY. A COMMUTERS
THAT ARE DRIVING AT LEAST TWO
HOURS TO GET TO WORK. ON AND-
AND IF WE START. IN A SUBJECT
FOR ANOTHER HEARING IF WE START
ON. PUTTING UP A FEE ON VEHICLE
MILES TRAVELED THOSE ARE THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE GONNA END UP
GETTING HURT OR THAT ARE THE
POOREST PEOPLE THAT CAN AFFORD
TO WORK. A IN THE WHERE THERE.
AND BE IT AND THIS IMPACT BUT
LET ME LET ME LET ME LET ME ASK
YOU IF THERE'S- IT. I OBVIOUSLY
WERE REPRESENT A RURAL-
COMMUNITY AND SO SOME OF THE
ISSUES THAT YOU SEE IN THE BIG
CITIES ARE ARE ARE. REFLECTED A
LITTLE BIT DIFFERENTLY IN RURAL
CALIFORNIA- IN PARTICULAR IN
THE LAST MAN IS IN THE- AND THE
PATTERSON AND NEWMAN AREA
THAT'S WHERE YOU GET A LOT OF
THERE ACTUALLY IS A LOT OF
HOMEBUILDING GOING ON. BECAUSE.
OF COMMUTERS. PRICING OUT THE
LOWER. AND I'M WONDERING IF- IF
THE- IF THE PRESSURE FROM. THE
THERE'S THIS PRESSURE IN THE
REGION FOR GOOD JOBS MY SENSE
IS THE PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING
IN THOSE JOBS ARE NOT FROM THE
REGION- PARTICULARLY GIVEN MY
CONVERSATIONS WITH SOME OF THE
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS AND SO
ARE PEOPLE COMING IN FROM OUT
OF STATE OR THEY COMING FROM
THE FROM THE BIGGER CITIES THAT
ARE. WHERE THEY'RE
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS ARE.
YOU HAVE A SENSE OF THAT. AND
IT IS IT RESIDENTIAL OR
RESIDENTIAL THIS RESIDENTIAL
AND COMMERCIAL AS WELL BUT IT'S
RESIDENTS. IT'S LIKELY THAT THE
WORKERS THAT ARE BUILDING THOSE
HOMES ARE NOT NECESSARILY
PRESIDENTS OF THOSE AREAS IS
MOST LIKELY THAT HAPPENS ON WE
HAD OF OUR PARTICULAR CASE THAT
WE TOOK ALL THE WAY TO THE
SUPREME COURT WHERE CHARTER
CITIES NOT PAYING THE
PREVAILING WAGE OR MUNICIPAL
WORK AND WITHIN THAT UP CASE WE
PROVIDED INFORMATION TO THE
SUPREME COURT WE ENDED UP
LOSING THIS CASE BUT- WE
PROVIDED INFORMATION THAT
TALKED ABOUT WHY IT'S SO
IMPORTANT TO PAY. THE
PREVAILING WAGE TO THESE
WORKERS BECAUSE WORKERS ARE
TRANSIT THEIR TEN STORY THEY
BELIEVE THEY TRAVEL TO WHERE
THE WORK AS AS TO OUR MEMBERS
IS NOT- STRANGE THEM ALSO
BASICALLY TO HAVE THE ABILITY
TO HAVE GET TO THE JOB SITE AND
THE TRAVEL OF TWO HUNDRED MILES
A DAY. IN A TO GET TO AND FROM
THE JOB SITE OF SOME
UNFORTUNATELY HAVE TO WORK
FARTHER BUT THAT'S JUST IF THE
THROUGHTHE WORK IN TERMS OF
BUILDING FOR EXAMPLE A WIND
FARM OR SOLAR. ENERGY FOR
SOMEWHERE IN THE MIDDLE OF THE
DESERT. BUT IT IS
INFRASTRUCTURE JACQUE REID AND
WHEN IT COMES TO THESE HOMES-
Là THESE WORKERS. THE
CONTRACTOR WILL PICK UP THE
WORK. THE COLIN THEIR WORKERS
THEY'LL ALL COMMUTE TOGETHER
AND THE ALL. YOU KNOW BASICALLY
SPEND THE DAY WORKING. ARM AND
THEY WON'T HAVE. THE SORT OF
QUALITY OF LIFE NOT ONLY YOU'LL
TAKE A THE CYPRESS EITHER THE
QUALITY OF THE JOB. BUT THE
ACTUAL QUALITY OF LIFE RIGHT
THAT THEY HAVE TO TRAVEL TO THE
JOB SITE PERHAPS BEEN ALL DAY
TRAVELING IN THE NEXT TO HAVE
TO DO IT ALL OVER AGAIN. AND SO
IT'S A- IT'S A VERY MENTALLY
DANGEROUS INDUSTRY BUT ALSO
IT'S A VERY OF PHYSICAL SERVICE
STRENUOUS SORT OF A WORK THAT
HAPPENS AND- IT TAKES A LOT.
OUT OF THE CONSTRUCTION WORKER
IN TERMS OF THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR A FOR HIS HER FAMILY TO
MATCH WOULD COME HOME AND SPEND
QUALITY TIME SO. THE LIKELIHOOD
OF A WORKER IN PATTERSON
STAYING WITHIN. THE FIFTY MILE
RADIUS IS PROBABLY VERY LOW. I
WOULD JUST ECHO. AND AN OFFER
MAYBE IT ALONE SLIGHTLY
DIFFERENT- PERSPECTIVE AS WELL.
OBVIOUSLY HIGH DENSELY
POPULATED AREAS ARE- MAGNETS
AND DRAW- INDIVIDUALS WITH YOU
NO PROSPECTS OF HIGHER INCOME
OPPORTUNITIES- RULE AREAS TEND
TO- JUST NOT HAVE THE- THE
LABOR POOL. A LOCAL LABOR POOL
TO MEET EITHER- THE STATE'S WAS
AS SKILLED WORKFORCE- I
REQUIREMENTS. AND SO YOU KNOW
OTHERS WILL NEED TO COME IN TO
HELP. OFFSET THOSE NUMBERS AND
IN ORDER FOR THE JOB TO BE-
COMPLIANT- AND SO THOSE RULE
AREAS STILL HAVE. PUBLIC
INFRASTRUCTURE PUBLIC PROP
PROJECTS. WHETHER IT'S THE
LOCAL JAIL. OR THE LOCAL SCHOOL
SO A LOT OF TIMES THOSE PARENTS
HER- OR THE YOU KNOW THE ONES
THAT ARE- IN THE CONSTRUCTION
AND HAVE THEIR KIDS. TO GO TO
SCHOOL. PRESUMABLY AT THAT
LOCATION THEY'RE NOT ABLE TO
WORK ON THAT BECAUSE- JUST NOT
ENOUGH WORKERS IN THAT
PARTICULAR AREA TO ME WHATEVER
THIS COMPLIANCE IS- AND SO.
THOSE FROM HIGHER DENSITY
POPULATED AREAS WILL COME IN-
METERS COMPLIANCE NUMBERS- AND
AS- SAYS EARLY TO YOU KNOW
THAT. USUALLY THE HOTELS AND
TOURISM- LOOK AT INDUSTRY BUT
IT'S FROM THAT- FROM STAYING
AWAY FROM THEIR FAMILY BUT IT.
IT IS IT'S A TAXING SITUATION
ON ALL THOSE AND TOOLS. SO HOW
ABOUT THE PRINTER PROGRAMS I
GUESS WHAT I'M WHAT I'M TRYING
TO GET TO IS. EIGHT THERE'S A
REAL NEED FOR GOOD JOBS IN
RURAL CALIFORNIA AS WELL. AND
IF THE JOBS AREN'T THERE
NECESSARILY ON A CONTINUOUS
BASIS THEN YOU'RE NOT GONNA SEE
THE SAME INTEREST IN IN THE JOB.
IN IN GETTING THE TRAINING IF
YOU WILL- THAT YOU WOULD IF
THERE ARE LOTS OF CONSTRUCTION
PROJECTS GOING ON AND RIGHT NOW
HIGH SPEED RAIL IS MADE A
TREMENDOUS DIFFERENCE IN THE
CENTRAL VALLEY. THAT'S BEEN A
GREAT. IT REALLY HAS BEEN A-
AT. ECONOMIC BOON FOR THE
CENTRAL VALLEY FOR PEOPLE WHO
HAD A HARD TIME FINDING A JOB
AND NOW WE'RE GETTING TRAINED.
AND ARE DOING. A REALLY GOOD
JOB. BUT UNLESS YOU HAVE ENOUGH
PROJECTS LIKE THAT THEN YOU
DON'T KEEP THE WORK FORCE THERE
THEY'LL MOVE SOMEWHERE ELSE
THAT'S RIGHT- IT'S AN
IMPORTANT. ASPECT OF IN AND
THEN RAIN MENTION I THINK-
MISTER COCHRAN ALSO OF.
COLLUDED TO IT. WHEN YOU HAVE
PROJECTS THAT REQUIRE CERTAIN
SKILLS THAT OR CONDITION LET'S
JUST SAY LOCAL HIRE. A PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENT- THE HIGH SPEED
RAIL OF. PROJECT HOUSING
COMMITTEE WORKFORCE SO PEOPLE
FROM THE LOCAL COMMUNITY. HAVE
TO BASICALLY WORK ON THIS
PROJECT. THEY'RE NOT ONLY
WORKING ON HIGH SPEED RAIL THE
RALLY CHRISTIANS THAT ARE ALSO
WORKING ON SOLAR FARMS AND SO
IBEW. AND THE AND WORKERS WILL
BOTH ARE WORKING ON HIGH RAIL
AS WELL. ARE ACTIVELY
RECRUITING IN THOSE AREAS. THE
TWO PEOPLE TO WORK ON SOLAR
FARMS AND THE WORKERS AND
TRANSITION FROM THEN THERE ARE
THIS IS. THE ONE ACTUALLY. HI
SPUR OF SYSTEM. NOW THERE LOCAL
WORKERS. THEY'RE GOING TO KEEP
THEIR WE JUST WITH THE LOCAL
ECONOMY THEY MAY ACTUALLY THEN.
PURCHASE A HOME SOME OF THOSE
THERE ARE TO BE BUILT AT OUR
SENSE OF. HAVING MULTIPLE
AGREEMENTS WITH IN AN ERROR BE
A PUBLIC AND PRIVATE. HELPS. US
BASICALLY BY MORE. ABOUT. AND
YOU HAVE MORE RESTAURANTS MORE
HOTELS MORE ENTERTAINMENT. YOU
KNOW JUST DIFFERENT THINGS ARE
ACTUALLY RECYCLE AND THEN YOU
HAVE MORE INVESTMENTS FROM
ACTUAL OTHER UNION CRAFT THAT
WERE LIKE TO PERHAPS BUILD
SATELLITE TYPE APPRENTICESHIP
PROGRAMS THERE. AND START
GROWING THEIR NUMBERS BECAUSE
THEY GO TO WHERE THE NEED IS.
EXAMPLE IS THE IMPERIAL VALLEY.
SO SAN DIEGO IS BASICALLY THE
ECONOMIC CENTER AND IN THAT
AREA. BUT WHEN THE DOWNTURN IN
THE ECONOMY HAPPENED IN TWO
THOUSAND AND EIGHT. THERE'S TWO
THINGS ARE HAPPENING THAT HELP
OUR MEMBERS OUT AND I WAS WE
WERE SEEN 40% 50% UNEMPLOYMENT
SOME LOCALS. WELL I B. W. WAS
BUILDING A NEW APPRENTICESHIP
CENTER IN THE IMPERIAL VALLEY.
THEY WERE DOING THAT BECAUSE
THE POLICY CREATED BY YOU HERE
IN THE LEGISLATURE TO ENSURE
THAT THERE WAS A RENEWABLE
PORTFOLIO STANDARD THAT WAS
HIGHER. WAS CREATING A LOT OF
JOB OPPORTUNITIES BASICALLY
BUILDING RENEWABLE ENERGY
CENTERS RIGHT THERE. AND SO
THEY WANTED TO THE ADDRESS THE
ISSUE OF HAVING LOCAL WORKERS
HAVE ACCESS AND TRAINING SO
THEY BILLS SATELLITE OFFICE.
LIKEWISE IN THE AGO THE PROJECT
LABOR AGREEMENT THERE. ENSURE
THAT WHILE THERE WAS OTHER
LOCALS AND OTHER PLACES IN THE
COMMERCIAL RESIDENTIAL WERE
DOWN. THE PUBLIC WORKS SECTOR
WAS ACTUALLY PICKING UP A LOT
OF OPPORTUNITIES FOR WORKERS
THERE AND THEY WERE ACTUALLY
GROWING AND FOR. US AS WELL. SO
THAT'S MY THOSE PROJECT. AS A
COMMUNITY. IT'S WORK BECAUSE
THEY THEY COUNTERACT A LOT OF
THOSE ISSUES IMPROVE THE
QUALITY NOT JUST IN THE
CONSTRUCTION BUT ALSO THE
QUALITY OF LIFE WORKERS. I JUST
REGISTERED TO THE- ON THAT A
LITTLE BIT. ON THE MESSAGE OR
SAID THAT HIGH SPEED RAIL IT IS
UNDER CAN YOU WORKFORCE
AGREEMENT- ONE OF OUR MULTI
CRAFT PRECONSTRUCTION TRAINING
PROGRAMS- SERVICES CENTRAL
VALLEY ITS BASE IN FRESNO- SO
IT'S BEEN WORKING WITH
COMMITTEE BASED ORGANIZATIONS
AND WORK AND THE WORK FORCE
BOARDS. INTHE CENTRAL VALLEY
TO HELP PEOPLE GET ACCESS TO.
JOBS ON HIGH SPEED RAIL- AND
JUST RECENTLY THREE WORKERS
DURING THE OUT SO THEY ARE
STARTED FOR FIVE YEARS AGO- ERR
NOW JOURNEY LEVEL WORKERS
BECAUSE OF A PRE CONSTRUCTION
TRAINING PROGRAM BY TARGETS
WOMEN OF PEOPLE OF COLOR LOW
INCOME COMMUNITIES. AND THE
DIVERSITY IN THESE COHORTS OF
TRAINEES ARE WILL TO CRACK UP
PARTNERSHIP PROGRAMS IS EXACTLY
THE WHAT YOU WANT THE TRADES-
DEMOGRAPHICS TO LOOK LIKE AND
IT'S MOVING IN THAT DIRECTION-
VERY DELIBERATELY. THAT'S GREAT
WELL I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY
TO. TO DO A TOUR A NUMBER OF
TIMES ON THE HIGH SPEED RAIL
PROJECT AND TO ALSO TALK TO
SOME OF THE WORKERS THAT ARE
OUT THERE DOING- THE WERE THE
ACTUAL WORK AND IT'S BEEN.
REALLY IMPRESSIVE AND SO THAT
MAKES A LOT OF SENSE WHAT YOU
SEEN TERMS OF THE VARIETY OF.
OF OPPORTUNITY SO THESE
APPRENTICES COULD MOVE FROM ONE
PROJECT TO ANOTHER STAY WITHIN
THEIR OWN REGION AND THEN-
EVENTUALLY WORK INTO THE
JOURNEY. YOUR NAME AND FACE
WHICH IS GREAT. WHILE THE ON.
ON ONE LAST FIGHT IS I SAW IT A
COMMUNITY THAT STARTED TO
TRYING TO CHANGE THE NARRATIVE
ABOUT- WORKING- AT THE INCOME
IN THE CONSTRUCTION TRADES AND
THEY HAD A SIGNING CEREMONY.
FOR THAT THE DAY THAT THEY WERE
SIGNING UP WITH THE TRADES VERY
MUCH LIKE THE SIGNING
CEREMONIES IT THEY DO FOR
SPORTS AND I THOUGHT THAT WAS
REALLY A UNIQUE- OPPORTUNITY TO
REALLY GET YOUNG PEOPLE EXCITED
ABOUT A NEW A NEW START. A NEW
CAREER- AND WE MIGHT WANT TO
THINK ABOUT DOING SOMETHING
LIKE THAT BECAUSE I DON'T THINK
WE GET THE WORD OUT ENOUGH
ABOUT THE OPPORTUNITIES AND-
AND- THIS IS THAT. THIS IS A
GUARDIAN NOT WE'RE GONNA HAVE
TO FIGURE OUT WHAT ARE THE
PIECES WE NEED TO PUT TOGETHER
TO GET OUT THERE BECAUSE- THAT
THE PUBLIC MONEY INVOLVED IT
WILL IS MENU IS COMPARED TO OUR
RDA- WHAT ARE USED TO PRODUCE
AND- AND IF THAT'S ONE OF THE-
ONE OF THE. FUEL FUNDING
OPPORTUNITIES IT'S WAY TOO
SMALL- MAKE THAT WE'RE GONNA
HAVE TO THINK BIGGER WOULD HAVE
TO BE A LITTLE BIT MORE
CREATIVE ABOUT HOW AND- IF YOU
HAVE SUGGESTIONS I THINK WE'RE
OPEN TO LOOKING AT ANYTHING
THAT GETS US. GETS IS TO START
REALLY MOVING ON THE NUMBER OF
UNITS SECOND BUILT EVERY YEAR
AT THAT THAT I'VE SEEN A HALF A
MILLION UNITS UNITS ARE READY
TO GO IN YET WHEN I TALK TO THE
CITY SAY SAY WE'VE GOT TO WE'VE
GOT PROPERTY. IT'S ALREADY-
PERMITTED AND WE CAN'T FIND
ANYBODY TO BUILD. AND THAT IS A
CONCERN OF MINE. WE'VE BEEN A
AT LEAST THE S. R. B. X. WE'VE
BEEN WORKING WITH A LOT OF OUR
INDUSTRY PARTNERS TO AGAIN LOOK
UPSTREAM AND TRADED MAKE- OR AT
LEAST CHANGE THAT NARRATIVE OF.
CONSTRUCTION BEING- AN
EXCITING- CAREER OPPORTUNITY-
IN ADDITION TO OUR TRADE STAY
THAT I ALLUDED TO EARLIER AT
CAL EXPO IN TWO THOUSAND HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS AND WAVES OF
THREE HUNDRED- COMING IN AND
LEARNING- DIFFERENT TRADES WE
ALSO HAVE A DESIGN BUILD
COMPETITION- WHERE WE- FOR
THREE DAYS WORK WITH STUDENTS-
WE HAVE MEMBER COMPANIES THAT.
DONATE THE REPLIES IN THEIR
TIME OF FOR WEEKS LEADING UP
TO- THE PROJECT AND THEN- WE
USED TO HAVE ACTUALLY ON THE
SOUTH STEPS OF THE CAPITOL.
WITH THE STATEWIDE COMPETITION.
ALL THE LOCAL JUNIOR COLLEGE IN
THE PARKING LOT AND THREE DAYS
THEY- CONSTRUCT TINY HOMES- AND
THEN- OR GO THROUGH DESIGN
REVIEW PROCESS. AND THEN
ULTIMATELY OR THOSE HOMES ARE
DONATED TO LOCAL CHURCHES FOR-
TEMPORARY STRUCTURES FOR
INDIVIDUALS THAT ARE IN
BETWEEN. HOUSING SITUATIONS-
THESE ARE ALL YOU KNOW
DIFFERENT ERAS IN THE QUIVER IF
YOU WILL- THAT WE COULD. BRING
OUT TO SCALE IN EVERY COMMUNITY
IS DIFFERENT EVERY COMMUNITIES
GOING TO RESPOND DIFFERENTLY-
BUT AGAIN CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION- HAS- IT HAS A HAS A-
A COMMITMENT FROM THE STATE
BUT- IN LESS WE INVEST MORE IT
JUST WON'T. HANDLE. THE OR AT
LEAST TO MEET THE DEMANDED THAT
WE HAVE PLACED ON IT WITH OUR
OUR POLICIES- UNFORTUNATELY WE
JUST HAVE- TOO MANY. OTHER
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE
LIEU PULLING IN LOWERING THESE
THESE STUDENTS AWAY I WITH
FIFTY THREES- OF VARIOUS
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS.
THE CONSTRUCTIONS REFERENCE 7%
AND SO WE JUST NEED TO
ENCOURAGE AND EDUCATE- PARENTS
TEACHERS GUIDANCE COUNSELORS
ACROSS ALL SPECTRUMS TO MAKE
THEM AWARE OF WONDERFUL
OPPORTUNITIES THAT EXIST IN
CONSTRUCTION. RATING THAT'S
PROBABLY A GOOD INTRODUCTION TO
THE NEXT. PERFECT TRANSITION I
WANT WANT TO THANK YOU ALL FOR
BEING HRE TODAY REALLY
APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY. I
LOOK FORWARD TO WORKING WORKING
WITH YOU. WE'RE GONNA INVITE
THE SECOND PANEL TO PLEASE COME
FORWARD JILL HERMAN WHO MANAGES
AN OVERSEAS THE CALIFORNIA
HOMEBUILDING FOUNDATION
BUILDING INDUSTRY TECHNOLOGY
ACADEMY. PROGRAM WHICH INCLUDES
EXPANDING THE CURRICULUM TO
CAMPUSES STATEWIDE. RECRUITING
IN THIS INDUSTRY SUPPORT AND
COORDINATING EVENTS RAISE
AWARENESS FOR THE FOR THE
PROGRAM. ALSO WON A- OUT
WELCOME AT PER DEEP. CORD CODE
CAM RIDE YOU THEY SAY THAT
RIGHT OKAY WHO RECENTLY JOINED
THE CALIFORNIA DEPARTMENT OF
EDUCATION HAVING PREVIOUSLY
SERVED AS THE CHIEF OF THE
BUREAU OF CAREER AND TECHNICAL
TECHNICAL EDUCATION DIVISION OF
COMMUNITY COLLEGES I AWAY
DEPARTMENT OF EDUCATION AS A
DEPUTY DIRECTOR OF THE NATIONAL
RESEARCH CENTER FOR CAREER AND
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AT THE
UNIVERSITY. OF LOUISVILLE.
PROFESSOR MACABRE L. ANDERSON.
WHO IS THE CHAIR OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT CALIFORNIA STATE
UNIVERSITY SACRAMENTO. AND
SIMEON GET WHO IS A GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS AND PUBLIC AFFAIRS
CONSULTANT AND THE FOUNDER AND
EXECUTIVE BOARD MEMBER OF GREEN
TECHNICAL TECHNICAL EDUCATION
AND EMPLOYMENT. A COMMUNITY
BASED NONPROFIT ORGANIZATION
TEACHING YOUTH AND YOUNG ADULTS
TWELVE TO TWENTY ONE ABOUT
CAREER OPPORTUNITIES AND CLEANENERGY. ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
SUSTAINABLE LIVING STRATEGIES
WELCOME. VERY MUCH FOR BEING
HERE. WE'LL START OFF WITH MISS
HERMAN. SO NOW THAT WE'VE HEARD
WITH THE PROBLEM IS I'M I'M
ASSUMING YOU GUYS HAVE ALL THE
SOLUTIONS RIGHT. OKAY. GOOD
GOOD WE'RE LOOKING FOR. OKAY I
THINK THIS IS ON AND HELLO
MADAM CHAIR AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU FOR THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO TALK TO YOU
TODAY ABOUT THE BUILDING
INDUSTRY TECHNOLOGY ACADEMY OR
AS WE LIKE TO CALL IT DATA. MY
NAME IS JILL HERMAN I WORK FOR
THE CALIFORNIA HOMEBUILDING
FOUNDATION AND I AM IN THE
PROGRAM DIRECTOR FOR BED AT THE
PREVIOUS PANEL REALLY TOUCHED
ON- THE LABOR SHORTAGE AND- YOU
KNOW THE FIVE AND ONE RATIO
AND- YOU KNOW. HAVE CONTRACTORS
ARE EXPECTING THIS LABOR
SHORTAGE TO CONTINUE SO HE
BASICALLY TOOK MY WHOLE INTRO.
BUT THAT'S OKAY. AND SO WE KNOW
THAT THERE'S ABOUT TWELVE
HUNDRED SKILLED TRADES THAT
TAKE IT TAKES TO. BUILD AND
SELL ONE HOME YOU KNOW FROM THE
SURVEYORS TO THE FRAMERS TO THE
PLUMBERS. AND THAT INCREASES AS
WE BUILD OUR SCHOOLS ROADS- AND
ONLY 20% OF THOSE REALLY I
REQUIRE A COLLEGE DEGREE. M.
THIRTY THIRTY MILLION JOBS IN
THE US THAT PAN AVERAGE OF
FIFTY FIVE THOUSAND DOLLARS PER
YEAR THAT DO NOT REQUIRE A
BACHELOR'S DEGREE. AND A
CALIFORNIA CONSTRUCTION WORKERS
ANNUAL WAGES AVERAGES ABOUT
SIXTY FOUR THOUSAND DOLLARS A
YEAR AND THAT INCREASES WITH
EXPERIENCE CONSTRUCTIONS ONE OF
THE FEW INDUSTRIES WHERE YOU
CAN WORK YOUR WAY FROM THE
BOTTOM TO THE TOP. AND WE HAVE
A LOT OF PEOPLE IN OUR INDUSTRY
THAT STARTED- YOU KNOW AS A
FRAMER ARE OF SOMEONE THAT WAS
DIGGING HOLES AND THEN. ALL THE
SUDDEN THERE THE OWNER OF THEIR
OWN COMPANY AND THEY WOULDN'T
HAVE IT ANY OTHER WAY BECAUSE-
THEY CAN REALLY RELATE TO EVERY
ASPECT OF THEIR BUSINESS. AND
THAT MAKES ME A BETTER
BUSINESSMEN IT MAKES THEM A
BETTER MANAGER AT AT A REALLY
GOOD JUST A REALLY GOOD
INDUSTRY. I'M SO ADDRESS LABOR
CHARGE. TOUCHED ON THIS IN THE
LAST PANEL BUT WE REALLY NEED
TO ADDRESS THE MISPERCEPTION
ABOUT THIS INDUSTRY. AND WE
NEED TO START WORKING WITH
INDUSTRY TO PROVIDE CURRICULUM
TRAINING EDUCATION. FOR THE
NEXT GENERATION AND THAT'S
REALLY WHERE MY PASSION EXISTS
AND WHY I DO WHAT I DO. SO MUCH
TALKED ABOUT THAT AT. A WIDE
SUCCESS WIDE SIX AND A GOOD
EDUCATION MODEL FOR BRIDGING
THE SKILLS GAP- WHY THE
INDUSTRY SHOULD BE ENGAGED WITH
THIS MODEL- AND FINALLY I'LL
LEAVE YOU WITH A FEW ACTION
ITEMS. AND SO BET AS A FOUR
YEAR CONSTRUCTION TRAINING
CURRICULUM THAT. AND IS
PROVIDED AT NO COST TO
CALIFORNIA HIGH SCHOOLS ON BY
THE CALIFORNIA HOMEBUILDING
FOUNDATION THIS CURRICULUM
SERVES AS A CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PATHWAYS PROGRAM OF.
C. T. E. WHICH WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT- AND IT'S- APPROVED BY
THE UNIVERSITY OF CALIFORNIA
UNDER THE G. ELECTIVE
REQUIREMENT WHICH MEANS THAT
SINCE THAT TAKE THIS CLASS. GET
THEIR ELECTIVE REQUIREMENTS NOT
ONLY TO GRADUATE FROM HIGH
SCHOOL BUT USUALLY THAT
TRANSLATES INTO- GETTING IN
THEIR REQUIREMENTS INTO UC OR
CSU SYSTEMS- SO THAT'S REALLY
IMPORTANT. AND THE PROGRAM FOR
BETTER GREW OUT OF A UNIQUE
CIRCUMSTANCE. OUR INDUSTRY WAS
INVITED TO A CAREER DAY AT A
HIGH SCHOOL. AND THEY WERE
GONNA GET SOME TALKS ABOUT THE
INDUSTRY INSTANCE COULD PICK
WHAT INDUSTRIES THEY WANTED TO
GO LISTEN TO. AT LOAN BEHOLD
THE CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY WAS
VERY SPARSELY ATTENDED. AND
THOUGH HE ASKED THE STUDENTS
YOU KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON AND-
THE PERCEPTION IS YAK
INSTRUCTIONS OF THE JOB. IT'S
AN IT'S RELIABLE IT'S MANUAL
BURKE AND IT'S NOT CAREER BASED
AND SO HE SAID YES WE REALLY
NEED TO CHANGE THE NARRATIVE SO
HE DEVELOPED THE CURRICULUM IN
TWO THOUSAND TWO WITH NORTH
ORANGE COUNTY ROP REGIONAL
OCCUPATIONAL PROGRAMS- AND
THAT. I A WHICH IS THE INDUSTRY
SAYS GEN. I'M THE EVEN
SPONSORED A NEW CONSTRUCTION AB
THEY PAY FOR THE DEVELOPMENT
THE CREEK LAMB SO THAT THAT
SPREAD VERY QUICKLY IN ANAHEIM
TO EIGHT SCHOOLS. AND THEN- BUT
IT WAS ADOPTED BY MY FOUNDATION
IN TWO THOUSAND TWELVE TO MAKE
IT A STATEWIDE. INITIATIVE AND
WERE NOW THIRTY TWO HIGH
SCHOOLS THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
FORCED BY EDUCATING AND
INSPIRING THESE STUDENTS TO
JOIN OUR INDUSTRY. SO HOW ARE
WE DOING THIS AND WHY HAS IT
BEEN SO SUCCESSFUL- I THINK THE
PROGRAM IS WIDELY POPULAR AMONG
OUR EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS
BECAUSE THE CURRICULUM MEETS
THE NEEDS OF OUR COLLEGE AND
CAREER BOUND STUDENTS. ANSWER
MEMBER I KIND OF TALKED ABOUT
THAT G. ELECTIVE AND WHEN YOU
HAVE A COLLEGE BOUND STUDENT
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO TAKE AN
ELECTIVE COURSEUNLESS IT'S
GOING TO BENEFIT THEIR ABILITY
TO GRADUATE FROM HIGH SCHOOL
ORGAN TO COLLEGE SO THAT G.
REQUIREMENT OR ANY REQUIREMENT
YOU YOU KNOW YOU CAN BE YOU CAN
BE CONSTRUCTION MATH AND THAT
WOULD BE. AT FOR SOMETHING LIKE
AND LOOKING TO YOU. YEAH YEAH
OKAY. SO YOU CAN AT. FOR
CURRICULA FOR INDUSTRY AB
CURRICULUMS I'M AND WE'RE
CAREER BASE BECAUSE YOU KNOW
YOU THINK ABOUT THOSE KIDS YOU
THINK ABOUT WHEN YOU WERE IN
HIGH SCHOOL AND YOU KNOW THOSE
KIDS THAT DON'T PERFORM WELL IN
TRADITIONAL CLASSES THEY DON'T
THINK COLLEGES THE RIGHT PATH
FOR THEM THEY DON'T HAVE
SUPPORT AT HOME TO OBTAIN A
COLLEGE DEGREE THEY NEED
PROGRAMS LIKE THAT. AGAIN
AGAINST THE CLASS I'M HAVE
HANDS ON APPLICATION THEY'RE
GONNA BY THE MASS THAT THEY'RE
LEARNING IN GEOMETRY AND APPLY
IT THE PRICE TAG. AND FRAMING
AND SLOPE OF A ROOF SO THEY
REALLY NEED. ARMS TO KIND OF
GET THEM ENGAGED WITH THEIR
LEARNING PROCESS. SO I THINK
IT'S BEEN SUCCESSFUL BECAUSE
WE'RE TAKING INTERESTING KIDS
AND WE'RE TELLING ABOUT
OBTAINABLE CAREERS IN
CONSTRUCTION AND WE'RE TEACHING
THEM THE SKILLS AND WERE ALSO
TELLING THEM. YOU KNOW THESE
EMPLOYABILITY SKILLS OR SOFT
SKILLS. SO YOU KNOW WE'RE NOT
ONLY SAYING HEY. ADD THIS IS
HOW YOU FRAME THIS I USE
HAMMERS HOW YOU MET MEASURE BUT
WE'RE ALSO SAYING LOOK SOMEBODY
IN THE EYE WHEN YOU'RE SHAKING
THEIR HANDS OR SHOW UP TO WORK
ON TIME. AND THIS IS HOW YOU
WRITE A RESUME SO THESE ARE
IMPORTANT ASPECTS OF HIGH
SCHOOL CURRICULUMS AS WE TALK
ABOUT CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION AND HIGH SCHOOLS. AND
AT THE PRACTICAL TRAINING AT
DOES LEAD TO EMPLOYMENT AND IT
DOES LEAD TO IMPLEMENT AT ABOUT
MINIMUM WAGE LEVELS- AND THE
ABILITY TO ESTABLISH AN
EMPLOYMENT RECORD- PROVIDES THE
ABILITY TO SUPPORT A FAMILY AND
HAVE SECURITY IN LIFE.
ULTIMATELY AB I'M GLAD ADDING
BROUGHT UP THAT DESIGN BILL
COMPETITION BECAUSE WE DO
PARTNER ALL OF OUR BETTER
PROGRAMS FOR HER AND PRINT. AND
SHE'S. GET INVOLVED WITH THE
DESIGN BILL COMPETITION-
THERE'S ONE UP IN SACRAMENTO
ADD HOSTED BY THE SRB XCF AND
THEN ONE DOWN IN SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA TO THE DESIGN BILL
COMPETITION IS REALLY IS
SPECIAL BECAUSE IT'S FREE TO
STUDENTS AND SCHOOLS TO
PARTICIPATE. THE INDUSTRY IS
FULLY ENGAGED THEY HAVE A TOTAL
CONTROL OVER THEIR PROJECT THEY
DESIGN AT THEY BUILD IT OVER
TWO DAYS INDUSTRIES WALKING
AROUND SAYING HEY YOU'RE DOING
A GREAT JOB DOING THIS OR DON'T
DO THAT THAT'S NOT SAFE. THOSE
KIND OF PROVIDING A REAL WORLD
EXPERIENCE FOR THEM AND ALSO A
LOT OF THESE KIDS THEY DON'T.
THEY ARE ATHLETES SO THEY DON'T
GET THAT TEAM- EXPERIENCED A
LOT OF ATHLETES STILL SO THE
DECEMBER COMPETITION PROVIDES
AN OPPORTUNITY THAT FOR THEM TO
WORKING GROUP'S THEY CAN TAKE
ON LEADERSHIP. ROLES A LEARN
HOW TO COMPLETE A PROJECT ON
TIME THAT'S A REALLY GREAT
COMPETITION- AND OUR PROGRAM IS
AGNOSTIC SO I AM SAYING WE'RE
NOT REALLY TELLING THE FOURTEEN
YEAR OLD FRESHMAN YOU HAVE TO
BE AN ELECTRICIAN ARE YOU HAVE
TO BE A FRAMER. YOU HAVE TO GO
INTO RESIDENTIAL CONSTRUCTION
YOU HAVE TO GO IN A COMMERCIAL
WE'RE KIND OF PROVIDING A
BROAD. OVERVIEW OF THE INDUSTRY
AND GIVING THEM THE SKILLS THEY
NEED TO GET INTO THE INDUSTRY.
I'M AND THEN WE TELL THEM THE
OPTIONS ABOUT- WHERE THEY CAN
GO AFTER GRADUATION SO THEY CAN
DO COMMUNITY COLLEGE THEY CAN
GO ON A CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT
AT STATE COLLEGE THEY CAN- AND
ROLAND APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAM
OR THEY CAN GO. RIGHT ON TO THE
JOB SITE AND HOMEBUILDING. AND
WE JUST KIND OF LEAVE IT OPEN
BECAUSE WHEN YOU'RE FOURTEEN
FIFTEEN YOU DON'T KNOW WHERE
YOU'RE GOING TO GO. YOU KNOW AB
BUT IT. THE REASON WHY IT HAS.
SO AT SUCCESSFUL IS THAT WE'RE
GETTING OUR INDUSTRY. ENGAGED
AND PARTICIPATING. WITH THESE
PROGRAMS. SO IN SHE CAN GET
ENGAGE WITH THE PROGRAMS BY
BASICALLY GETTING INTO THE
CLASSROOM GUEST SPEAKER PARENTS
SAYS INTERNSHIP OPPORTUNITIES.
INVITING THEM OUT TO THE
CONSTRUCTION WORK SITE
PROVIDING A PROJECT A MENTOR
GUIDED PROJECT- WHEN WE SHOW
INVESTMENT AND THE KIDS. IT
REALLY RESONATES WITH THEM AND
THEY'RE GONNA MEET. FOLKS THAT
THEY MIGHT NOT NORMALLY HAVE
ACCESS TO. SO YOU KNOW THE- THE
OWNER OF TRY POINT HOMES COULD
COME IN AND TALK ABOUT HIS
EXPERIENCE IN THE CONSTRUCTION
INDUSTRY THE NEXT DAY. YOU KNOW
ALLEN S. FRAMING COMES BY AND
THEY DO AN AFTER SCHOOL
CONSTRUCTION BOOT. CAMP AND-
SHOW THEM HOW TO FRAME UP BY
TEN BY TEN. YOU KNOW MONTEL
JUST REAL QUICK AND- THEY'RE
MAKING THOSE CONNECTIONS AND
SHARING BUSINESS CARDS. SO
THAT'S HOW THIS INDUSTRY IS
GOING TO CHANGE THE PERCEPTION.
OF ODD THE CAREERS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE. AND GET KIDS
EXCITED. ABOUT THIS INDUSTRY WE
HAVE TO BE ENGAGED. AND SO I'M
TRYING TO FOLLOW MY TALKING
POINTS HERE AND I GET SO
EXCITED AND SO L. M. NGUYEN
INDUSTRY GETS ENGAGED IT REALLY
CHANGES THEIR PERCEPTION TOO
BECAUSE I MEAN HOW MANY TIMES
HAVE YOU HEARD AND AS YOU SAY-
KIDS DON'T WANT TO WORK THERE
ON THEIR CELL PHONE THEY JUST
SHOW UP LATE. YEAH THEY JUST
WANNA GO HOME AND PLAY VIDEO
GAMES WILL THAT IS NOT TRUE IS
REALLY ISN'T AN INDUSTRY GETS
INTO THESE CLASSROOMS AND THEY
MEET THE KIDS AND THEY GET TO
TRAIN THEM THEIR WAY THAT'S
ANOTHER THING I HEAR A LOT I
JUST WANT TO TRAIN KIDS MY WAY-
SO THEY GET THE OPPORTUNITY TO
DO THAT AND BASICALLY OUR
HANSEL. TING THERE'S THEIR
EMPLOYEES ARE FUTURE EMPLOYEES
IF THEY IF THEY GET ENGAGED. SO
PROGRAMS LIKE BETTER IN OTHER
HELPING KIDS UNDERSTAND THE
OPPORTUNITIES AND CONSTRUCTION
THAT THEY MAY HAVE NOT KNOWN
BEFORE BECAUSE WE'RE GETTING IN
THE CLASSROOM OR TELLING HIM
ABOUT IT WE HAVE THIS
CURRICULUM THAT KIND OF GIVES A
BROAD OVERVIEW AND SKILLS THEY
NEED- AND SO THAT IS. NOT A TO
ADDRESS THIS LACK OF A SKILLED
WORKFORCE SO THE MODEL OF. YOUR
SANCTIONED CURRICULUM. THAT.
ENCOURAGES LEARNING THEIR
PRACTICAL APPLICATION ALONGSIDE
PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN EDUCATORS
AND INDUSTRY. IS THE WAY WE'RE
GOING TO RECRUIT. AND RETAIN.
ALLION PLACE IN THIS WORK
FORCE. AND HAVE TO END WITH NOT
ONLY ARE WE BUILDING
COMMUNITIES THAT WE ARE
BUILDING CAREERS. WE ARE
CELEBRATING THE SORRY ONE LEVY
WITH. AND IT'S BEEN SAID BEFORE
WE NEED TO PROVIDE MORE FUNDING
TO BUILD CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION PROGRAMS IN HIGH
SCHOOLS THAT'S ABSOLUTELY
NUMBER ONE BUT THOSE CITY
PROGRAM'S REALLY NEED TO MEET
THE DEMAND FOR LABOR. ARE
WITHIN THE REGION AND THEY HAVE
TO UPHOLD THE REQUIREMENT THAT
INDUSTRY IS ENGAGED IN
PROVIDING THOSE OPPORTUNITIES
BECAUSE AGAIN YOU HAVE TO KIND
OF DO THE HAND HOLDING THESE
ARE JUST KIDS. THEY DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON I MEAN WHEN I
GRADUATED FROM HIGH SCHOOL HE
DIDN'T KNOW WHO IS HIRING WHAT
YOU NEEDED TO GET BE HIRED OR
WHO TO CONTACT. AND SO THAT'S
REALLY IMPORTANT. WE COULD ALSO
USE FUNDING FOR THE FIVE OH ONE
C. THREE ORGANIZATIONS THAT ARE
PROVIDING THESE CURRICULUMS AND
BECAUSE WE ARE PROVIDING THE
CURRICULUM ARE WORKING TO BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS BETWEEN EDUCATION
AND INDUSTRY. AND PROGRAMS LIKE
BED AT NIGHT OF GREEN TECH WITH
HIM YOU'LL HEAR FROM LATER- WE
COULD REALLY USE SOME GRANT
FUNDING TO HELP MAKE. THAT
HAPPEN AND FINALLY AS WE COME
TO THE TABLE YOU'RE DOING A
GREAT JOB HERE TODAY WITH THIS
HEARING AND I APPRECIATE BEING
HERE- BUT WE NEED EVERYONE AT
THE TABLE. AT INDUSTRY
COMMUNITY EDUCATIONAL PARTNERS
BECAUSE INDUSTRY CAN COME INTO
THE CREDIT AL YEAH HIGHER FIVE
OF YOUR SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD
STUDENTS AND EDUCATION AS THEY
WILL KNOW YOU CAN'T HIRE
SEVENTEEN YEAR OLD SOON YOU
HAVE TO WALK THROUGH ALL THESE.
BARRIERS IN THESE HOOPS TO GET
THERE SO EVERYONE IS BE AT THE
TABLE SO KIND OF BREAK DOWN
SOME OF THESE BARRIERS
UNDERSTAND WITH THE GOAL OF OUR
OF OUR PROGRAMS AND OUR
ORGANIZATIONS. TO BE ABLE TO
PROVIDE THESE OPPORTUNITIES FOR
KIDS. SO THAT IS MY SPIEL.
ABOUT THAT. AT AND- THANK YOU
AGAIN **** YOUR INPUT. MADAM
CHAIR SINCE THE GLAZER THANKS
FOR THE OPPORTUNITY FOR BEING
HERE I BRING GREETINGS FROM- A
SUPERINTENDENT THURMOND. CAREER
TECHNICAL EDUCATION OUR IS
OFTEN AND I'M TO USE STRATEGY
IN SCHOOL DISTRICTS FOR CLOSING
THE ACHIEVEMENT GAP. GETTING
ALL HIGH SCHOOL STUDENTS
COLLEGE AND CAREER READY
REGARDLESS OF PERSON PLACE OR
POSITION. AND IT ALSO DOES UP
SKILLING AND RE SKILLING OF
ADULTS OF ALL AGES THE CITY
SPECIFICALLY THOSE FROM
TRADITIONALLY UNDER REPRESENTED
GROUPS TO AND TO THE CURRENT
AND FUTURE WORK FORCE. C. T.
INTEGRATES CORE ACADEMIC
KNOWLEDGE WITH THE TECHNICAL IN
OCCUPATIONAL KNOWLEDGE OF
PROVIDE. STUDENTS WITH THE
PARKWAY TO POST SICKENING
EDUCATION CAREERS. CITY
PROGRAMS THAT DRIVEN BY STUDENT
INTEREST AND I THINK IN AND AS
AS THE PREVIOUS BALANCE OF
SPOKEN- STUDENT INTEREST IS
SOMETHING THAT NEEDS TO BE
ENGENDERED AT A VERY EARLY AGE
FOR THESE TWO THIS PARTICULARLY
IN THE IT WHAT I WILL CALL AND
GENERALLY THE TRADES AREA AND
I'LL TALK A LITTLE MORE ABOUT
THAT. LATER IT ALSO TALKS ABOUT
WE HAVE TO LOOK AT CURRENT IN
REGIONAL STATEWIDE LABOR MARKET
DATA INDUSTRY ADVOCACY AND
INVOLVEMENT AND ADELINE WINDED
PROGRAMS OFFERED IN THE LOCAL
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS. K.
TWELVE CITY PROGRAMS ARE FOR
OFFERED A UNIQUE IN THAT THEY
EMPHASIZEDTHE INTEGRATION OF
CATHOLIC EDUCATION ACADEMICS
WITH CITY COURSES AND THE
COURSE IS A BASED ON SOMETHING
THAT WE HAVE DEVELOPED WITHIN
THE DA IN DEPARTMENT CALL THE
CT MODEL CURRICULUM STANDARDS.
FOR ALL FOR OUR FIFTEEN
INDUSTRY PATHWAYS. WE HAVE
CAREER AND TECHNICAL STUDENT
ORGANIZATIONS SKILLS USA IS A
IS AN EXAMPLE WHERE THE
BUILDING TRADES. GET STUDENTS
GET EXPERIENCE FOR I LIVE AS A
LEADERSHIP AND STUDENTS ARE
PROVIDED THE OPPORTUNITY TO
ENGAGE IN A CONTINUUM OF WORK
BASED LEARNING EXPERIENCES
THROUGHOUT THEIR CITY COURSE
SEQUENCE. AND THIS IS SOMETHING
I THINK I KNOW WHAT WE'RE WE
WILL BE DISCUSSING TO IS THE
POSSIBILITY OF ENROLLING IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE C. D. COURSES
AS WELL AS IT I HAD A STATE
UNIVERSITIES AND AT THAT AND
EVEN POTENTIALLY ATTAINING POST
SECONDARY CREDENTIALS WHILE THE
STUDENT IS STILL IN HIGH SCHOOL.
JUST TO GIVE YOU SOME NUMBERS
FIFTY CD'S SO SIX POINT THREE
MILLION STUDENTS AND EIGHT
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS.
OFF THE STAGE NEARLY TWO
MILLION ENROLLMENTS IN GRADES
NINE TO TWELVE JUST OVER HOFFA
AND ROLLED IN CT. MORE
IMPORTANTLY THIS PERCENTAGES
INCREASED FROM ABOUT 40% AT THE
BEGINNING OF THIS DECADE 250%
TODAY. SO THERE IS TO HEIGHTEN
INTEREST IN C. T. ACROSS THE
BOARD WITHIN TO HIGH SCHOOL.
WITH THE HIGH SCHOOLS AND THE
CAGE WITH TWELVE SYSTEM. OVER
THIS TIME PERIOD C. D. IS
INCREASINGLY COME TO BE SEEN AS
A STRATEGY TO IMPROVE EQUITY IN
ACCESS. WE DO THAT THROUGH US
TO OF THAT TO A VARIETY OF
STATE AND FEDERAL PROGRAMS. IT
MEANS THE NEEDS OF BUSINESS AND
INDUSTRY AND PROVIDE STUDENTS
THE RIGHT EXPERIENCE FOR
LEARNING. IN ORDER TO PREPARE
THEM FOR THE CURRENT AND FUTURE
WORTHLESS. THE OVER ARCHING
GOAL. IS TO SHOW THAT C. D. IS
CENTRAL TO STUDENT LEARNING AND
SUCCESS IS MEASURED BY COLLEGE
AND CAREER READINESS. OFF THE
FIFTEEN INDUSTRY PATHWAYS THAT
WE HAVE IT WITHIN THE
DEPARTMENT. ONE OF THEM IS THE
BUILDING AND CONSTRUCTION
TRADES. STATE WIDE THEIR FIVE
HUNDRED FOR SIXTY FIVE HIGH
SCHOOLS THAT OFFER AT LEAST ONE
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION TRADES
COURSE WITH OVER TWENTY FOUR
HUNDRED OF COURSE IS BEING
TAUGHT IN THEIR FORTY THOUSAND.
OVER. FOR FORTY THOUSAND SIX
HUNDRED STUDENTS ENROLLED A IN
BUILDING CONSTRUCTION STATE
DISTRICT THE STATE IS SEEING A
SHIFT FROM THE TRADITIONAL WOOD
SHOP. TO MORE SPECIALIZED
PROGRAMS LIKE BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADES CABINET
MAKING MATT MASONRY H. BACK
USING CURRENT INDUSTRY
TECHNOLOGIES. WE'VE BEEN
TALKING ABOUT DIVERSE WORKFORCE
A IT SHORTAGES BUT WE ALSO HAVE
WE HAVE A THREE HUNDRED
CREDENTIAL FOUR TIMES A DAY FOR
LET'S SEE INSTRUCTORS IN K.
TWELVE IN THIS AREA AND THAT'S
DODD NOT ENOUGH TO MEET THE
MEET THE DEADLINE SO. AS MORE
EXPERIENCED TEACHERS ARE
RETIRING THIS STATE IS SEEING A
CHEF FROM TEACHERS WITH THE
WITH AN INDUSTRIAL ARTS SINGLE
SUBJECT CREDENTIAL TO TEACHERS
WITH A DESIGNATED SUBJECT.
CREDENTIAL WHICH REQUIRES
INDUSTRY EXPERIENCE BUT THEY.
ALSO NEED HELP FOR THE PEDAGOGY
IN THE CLASSROOM. THE TYPE OF
CERTIFICATES- CREDENTIALS
STUDENTS CAN EARN ARE QUALIFIED
TO OUR AND TO INCLUDE. THINGS
LIKE SHOULD TEN WOULD BE BETTER
I HAD TO RAINY WAS TALKING
ABOUT SAFETY THAT I THINK
SHOULD START EARLY AND OFTEN
HIGH SCHOOL FOR THEM TO GET
THIS AND THEY SHOULD BE AWARDED
THAT THAT THE CREDENTIALS WE
HAVE ORGANIZATIONS SUCH AS THE
NATIONAL CENTER FOR
CONSTRUCTION IT EDUCATION
RESEARCH. THAT HAVE CORRECT
LEVEL WHO ALSO HAVE THE IS THAT
THE CURRICULUM THAT YOU DIDN'T
LIKE YOURS IN MANY OTHER
CONSTRUCTION. CURRICULUM OUT
THERE. COLLEGE GOING
OPPORTUNITIES INCREASE FOR
STUDENTS WHEN SECONDARY AND
POST SECONDARY INSTRUCTORS
WORKING A WORK TOGETHER TO
ALIGN CURRICULUM AND
INSTRUCTION. BUILDERS ARE
OFFERING A SIR AT BUILDERS ARE
OFFERING INTERNSHIP TO STUDENTS
DURING THE SUMMER AND SOME
DURING SCHOOL ARE OFF TO SCHOOL
US TWO EXAMPLES THE HABITAT FOR
HUMANITY AND IN OUR HOME.
EXEMPLARS OF HIGH SCHOOL
DISTRICT THAT PROVIDE HIGH
QUALITY OF BUILDING
CONSTRUCTION TRADE PROGRAMS ARE
AT THE SILLINESS HIGH SCHOOL.
SUSTAINABLE DESIGN AND GREEN
CONSTRUCTION. LUTHER BUT OF
BURBANK HIGH SCHOOL HERE IN
SACRAMENTO AND A CONSTRUCTION
DAYS ON AYE AYE AYE WHICH IS
THE CONSTRUCTION DESIGN I CAN
ACT ACADEMY AND THE NORTH
HOLLYWOOD HIGH SCHOOL A LOT IN
THE LOS ANGELES AREA WHICH THEY
CALL HOME ENGINEERING HAD IT.
SO GENERALLY SPEAKING ALL THE
STATE AND FEDERAL FUNDING FOR
C. T. PROGRAMS INCLUDE THOSE IN
THE BUILDING CONSTRUCTION
TRADES FOCUS AND IMPROVEMENTS
IN MODIFICATION IN THREE AREAS.
MAKING ALL SCHOOL DISTRICT CITY
PROGRAM'S HIGH QUALITY BY
CONTINUOUSLY REVISITING LAP
DATING C. T. PROGRAM CURRICULUM
AND DELIVERY METHODS. CONSULAR
TRAINING SPECIFIC TO SEE T. AN
EXPANDING AND REFINING CD
CREDENTIALS TO BUILD OUT THE
TEACHER PIPELINE. IT IS THE
SECOND AREA WE NEED TO INCREASE
IN HEIGHT AND THE CONNECTION TO
BUSINESS AND INDUSTRY TO WORK
BASED LEARNING. NOT INTERNSHIPS
APPRENTICESHIPS AS WE'VE TALKED
ABOUT TEACHER APRENDER
EXTENSION BUT I WOULD INCLUDE
IN THIS PARTICULAR THE HIGH
SCHOOL LEVEL FREE
APPRENTICESHIPS THAT IS
SOMETHING THAT DO WE HIT WE
HAVE THAT IN OUR AND NOT
CALIFORNIA POTS WAS ACADEMY
PROGRAM BUT WE NEED TO HAVE
MORE OF THAT. AS WE MOVE
FORWARD. AND THE THIRD AREA IS
TO EXPAND THAT AT THE SECOND
THE POST SECONDARY. IN ADDITION
THROUGH DUAL ENROLLMENT
SYSTEMATIC IN UNIFORM
ARTICULATION PROCESSES AND
PROCEDURES INCLUDING C. D. WITH
WITHIN THE A TO G. FRAMEWORK
AND COMPLETING POST SECOND
CREDENTIALS AS HIGH SCHOOL
STUDENTS. SO ARE MORE BROADLY
IF IMPLEMENTED THE
PREPONDERANCE OF HIGH QUALITY
C. T. WITHIN OUR SCHOOL
DISTRICT SHOULD SO GREATER
ALIGNMENT OF BUSINESS AND
INDUSTRY NEEDS AS WELL AS
SIGNIFICANT PROGRESS TO WOODS
ACCESS AND EQUITY. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH THAT WAS
VERY WELL DONE SHE TO. I HAVE
MY LIST OF THINGS WE NEED NOW.
RESERVE HI. OKAY SORRY ABOUT
THAT. SO MINUTE SHIFT GEARS A
LITTLE BIT KIND OF TALK ABOUT
YOU KNOW WHAT WE'RE DOING. OF
YAK OUT THE HAND OUT HERE IS SO
SHOULD YEARS OLDER TART TALK
ABOUT WHAT WE'RE DOING EXACTLY
THE STATE I STARTED THEIR
TEACHER LEFT THE INDUSTRY I'M
I'M A STRUCTURAL ENGINEER AND
ALSO CONTRACTOR AND- BUT THE
INDUSTRY TWO THOUSAND RATED TO
GIVE BACKING AND GIVE ALL THE
UNIVERSITY AND- AT THE TIME WE
HAD. VERY LOW ENROLLMENT- IN
THE CONSTRUCTION MANAGER
PROGRAM- LESS THAN A HUNDRED
FIFTY STUDENTS IN ABOUT NINE
GRADUATES YEAR. AND IT WAS AT
THAT TIME THAT THE INDUSTRY
SAID YOU KNOW WE ARE GOING TO
DECIDE TO SUPPORT. THIS PROGRAM
OR WE'RE GOING TO GO SOMEWHERE
ELSE AND RON BROWN. I'M STILL
HERE HE'S ONE OF TEN FOUNDER
SUBSIDED. NOW WE'RE GOING TO
SUPPORT THIS PROGRAM. AT MOVIE
FOUR TO TODAY WE HAVE OVER
FORMER STUDENTS IN THE PROGRAM
FOR GRADUATING ABOUT SEVENTY
STUDENTS THIS NEXT YEAR- WE
MAINTAIN ONE HUNDRED AND JOB
PLACEMENT- AND- AS I LOOK BACK
TO PREPARE FOR TODAY- THERE'S
BEEN A LOT OF THE THINGS THAT
HAVE HELPED US GET THEIR TERMS
FOR SUCCESSES SO IT'S FINE.
SHARES OF THOSE THINGS THIS
YEAR. SO IF THIS THING. DOES
WORK. SO IN TERMS OF BUILDING
TRADE PARTNERSHIPS- YOU KNOW WE-
SAW OUR STUDENTS WHEN THEY
GRADUATE THEY'RE GONNA BE THE
ONES THAT ARE A GUY CAN BE ON
THE MANAGEMENT TEAM FOR THE
PROJECTS ARE NOT TO BE IN THE
TRAITS. OF THEIR EARLY MANAGING
THE TRADES- SCHEDULES
ESTIMATES- YOUR WORK WITH THE
OWNERS AND SO FORTH. AND
MANAGING THE QUALITY THE
CONSTRUCTION THAT'S WHAT WE
TRAIN THEM TO DO. PROVIDE THAT-
ALL OF OUR FACULTY COME FROM
THE INDUSTRY- WE ALL HAD WORKED
IN THE INDUSTRY EITHER AS-
ARCHITECTS ENGINEERS
CONTRACTORS- BUSINESS-
ADMINISTRATION SO FORTH- BUT
IT'S IMPORTANT TO STAY INVOLVED
AND I'D LISTED SOME OF THE
ORGANIZATIONS UP HERE THAT.
THAT WE HAVE BEEN INVOLVED WITH
THE SOME OF THINGS WE DO. I'LL
TAKE STUDENTS TO THEIR TRAINING
CENTERS THE UNION TRADING
CENTERS A WALK THROUGH WHAT
THEY DO- WE HAVE ALL THE
CARPENTERS UNION- COUPLE YEARS
AGO WHERE THEY HAVE A PRETTY
SURE PROGRAM OR-STUDENTS WILL
GO IN AND BE AN APPRENTICE IN
THE FIELD FOR A SUMMER. AND
COME BACK TO THE YOU TO
SEPARATE STATE AND CONTINUE
WITH THE PROJECT MANAGEMENT
SIDE. WE HAVE A LOT OF CLUBS ON
CAMPUS THAT INVOLVE THESE
ORGANIZATIONS I JUST GOT BACK
FROM DC A FEW WEEKS AGO WITH
ONE OF THESE CLUBS- WE HAD A
FORM WITH OVER TO OUR STUDENTS
AROUND THE COUNTRY- GREAT
FUTURES- YOU CONNECTING THEM
ABOUT WORKING. AND EXPOSED. TO
THAT PART OF THE INDUSTRY. WE
HAVE HAD SOME REALLY GREAT
SUCCESSES SUMMARY PRODUCT HERE
PRACTICE PICTURES JUST TAKEN
LAST WEEKEND- AND WE'RE IN
CHICAGO WE- TOOK A GROUP SINCE
OUT CHICAGO COMPETE IN ACADEMIC
COMPETITION. AGAINST SCHOOLS
FROM THE MIDWEST EAST COAST.
AND HAPPY TO THAT TEAM ACTUALLY
THEY GOT BIG SMILES BECAUSE
THEY JUST WANT TO FIRST PLACE
NATIONAL WAR THERE- TO DATE.
SINCE I STARTED TWO THOUSAND
THREE STARTED TRACKING THIS-
WE'VE GOTTEN YOU KNOW OVER
SIXTY FIVE AWARDS- THROUGH THE-
THROUGH THESE COMPETITIONS. AND
THESE. WERE WE HAVE STARTED RON
IS ACTUALLY ONE OF THE COACHES
I WAS A COACH TO FOR THESE
TEAMS. AND YOU KNOW WE'RE GOING
UP THERE DOING OKAY BUT WE KIND
OF TURNED THINGS AROUND AND
REALLY MADE IT. A POWERHOUSE
TEAM AND WE ARE WE GO UP THESE
COMPETITIONS AND- AND SCHOOLS
ARE ALWAYS LOOKING AT US AND IN
TERMS OF WHAT WE'RE DOING TO
ACCOMPLISH THAT I MEAN IT'S
INCREDIBLE WE'VE- AND AWARDS
HAVE GOTTEN OVER THE YEARS
THERE. I JOB PLACEMENT DATA- WE
HAVE HAD ON TO DROP PLACES
SINCE TWO THOUSAND EIGHT WHEN I
STARTED TRACKING IT- WITH
CALIFORNIA LAWYERS. US THEIR
STATE IN THE STATE FOR THE MOST
PART I ONCE WANTED TO COULD GO
TO FLORIDA WANTS ANOTHER GO TO
WASHINGTON- BUT FOR THE MOST
PART THEY STAY STAY HERE
CALIFORNIA. AND THEY'RE WORKING
IN OUR INDUSTRY THEY'RE NOT
GETTING JOBS IN OTHER
INDUSTRIES. THE PAST THREE
YEARS SIR TO SEE- YOU KNOW THE
DEMAND IS REALLY HIGH FOR THE
STUDENTS STATEWIDE- FOR THESE
GRADUATES THAT- NOW EMPLOYERS
ARE TRYING TO GET AHEAD OF
OTHER EMPLOYERS WERE OFFERING
ON SIGNING BONUSES EFFECT TO
THE KIDS ARE WITH ME IN CHICAGO
ONE OF THEM GOT SIGNED ON
EIGHTEEN MONTHS IN ADVANCE AND
GOES TUITION PAID FOR THE LAST
YEAR. THAT'S HOW BAD THEY
WANTED ON- THE INTERNSHIPS ARE
ALL PAID INTERNSHIPS- ALL OF
OUR UPPER DIVISION STUDENTS ARE
INTERNING DURING THE SCHOOL
YEAR. AND DURING THE SUMMER IN
THEIR GRADUATING DEBT FREE
WHICH IS PRETTY INCREDIBLE. SO
ARM AND IT IT COMES IN AGAIN IT
WASN'T LIKE THAT TWO THOUSAND
THREE IT'S EVOLVED OVER TIME
AND IT MOSTLY I COULD TEST IT
TO THE INDUSTRY INVOLVEMENT WE
HAVE A TON OF INDUSTRY THAT
JUST VOLUNTEERS ARE TIME-
COLLEGE CAREER FOR WE GOT A
CULTURE FOR TOMORROW WE HAVE
ONE EVERY SEMESTER SIXTY FIVE
IN THIS IS FOR THE COLLEGE OF
ENGINEERING COMPUTER SCIENCE
NOT FOR THE WHOLE UNIVERSITIES
SO IT'S FOCUSED ON FIVE
THOUSAND STUDENTS AND YOU KNOW
CIVIL ENGINEERING MECHANICAL
ENGINEERING CONSTRUCTION
COMPUTER SCIENCE. 65% EMPLOYERS
WANT OUR STUDENTS AND WE'RE
ONLY REPRESENTING A PERCENT OF
THE COLLEGE SO IT'S OBVIOUSLY
VERY HIGH DEMAND AND IT'S A
GREAT TIME TO GRADUATE FOR SURE
AVERAGE STARTING SALARIES TO
PUT THE DATA OUT THERE- IT'S
GONE UP QUITE A BIT LAST FEW
YEARS BUT THE STOCK WINNER
WERE. WERE LOOKING AROUND CITY
FIVE THOUSAND AVERAGE SALARIES.
AND IN THE- YES. A LITTLE BIT
HIGHER FOR THE HIGHER COST
LIVING. SO YOU'RE GOING BACK TO
WHERE YOU GUYS CENTER ABOUT THE
TWENTY FIVE DOLLARS AN HOUR I
MEAN THAT EQUATES TO ABOUT
THIRTY TO THIRTY FIVE FORTY
DOLLARS NOW RIGHT THERE SO. AND
AGAIN THAT STARTED. I GRADUATES
ON ICONIC PROJECTS SO YOU KNOW
THE STUDENTS TO WORK ON
ANYTHING FROM RESIDENTIAL ALL
THE WAY TO YOU KNOW LARGEST
PROJECTS YOU CAN THINK OF- THE
GOLDEN ONE CENTER DOWNTOWN HERE
SACRAMENTO WE HAVE A TON OF
ALUMNI ON THE PROJECT WE'RE
WORKING WITH THAT OF THE ONE OF
THE MIDDLE THERE IS A GIFT
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY- ONE OF
THEIR PARTS OF MY JOB IS TO GO
VISIT STUDENTS AFTER THEY
GRADUATE AND ACTUALLY GOT
QUALITY TOP OF THAT BUILDING IT
IS THE TALLEST BUILDING. WEST
OF CHICAGO IS NOW COMPLETE. AND
UP AND THEN ANOTHER BRIT UP IN
SEATTLE HAD A STUDENT WORKING
FOR A MARINE CONSTRUCTION
THAT'S THE ONE WHO LEFT
CALIFORNIA TO SEATTLE. THE
LONGEST FLOATING BRIDGE IN THE
WORLD. IT'S OVER LAKE
WASHINGTON- RIGHT BY BILL DOES
HE WASN'T TOO HAPPY WITH THE OF
THE BRIDGE THERE. BUT IT IS
RIGHT NOT AREA. ARE BY FOR US
THIS IS REALLY WHERE IT ALL
STARTED I'LL BE HONEST IN THIS
IS A- WE HAD AN INJURY RISE
WERE MOST- MOST EDUCATIONAL
GROUPS DO WERE YOU JUST REPORT
FROM A COUPLE TIMES A YEAR OKAY
THIS IS WHAT WE'RE DOING AND
THEY WEREN'T REALLY ENGAGING-
THOSE TYPES OF BY SUPPORTS OUR
ADVICE WERE DECIDED TO THEIR IN
A SUPPORTER PROGRAM. I'M HERE
NINE TO TEN FOUNDERS IN THE
TENTH ONE IS BEHIND YOUR EAR
ROTH. IT MAKE THE PITCHER THAT
DATES BUT- RON IS NOT ONLY IT
JUST TO GIVE YOU A PERSPECTIVE
OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE INVOLVED
HE'S IN A LOT OF THE PROGRAM.
HE SUPPORTS IT FINANCIALLY AND
HE'S BEEN ON OUR ADVISER FORCES
OR SPOUSES THE FIVE OH ONE C.
THREE THAT WAS STARTED OFF
CAMPUS WITH THE SUPPORT OF OUR
PRESIDENT THE TIME. AND THEY
HAVE THE GOAL OF JUST. ON THE
PROGRAM AT IF YOU KNOW
ULTIMATELY THEY WANTED TO SEE.
MORE PEOPLE COLLEGE READY YET
TO GO WORK FOR THE COMPANY'S
MORE THAN NINE GRADUATES RIGHT.
AND WE'VE DONE SO MUCH OVER THE
YEARS LIKE IT'S BEEN AN HOUR
JUST TALKING ABOUT THE PROGRAMS
THEY SUPPORT THEIR- ARMS THE
REALLY VERY FORTUNATE TO HAVE
THAT AND THEY'VE BEEN THE
CATALYST TO DO AND ALL THE
OTHER THINGS WE'VE DONE IN
TERMS ACT COMPETITIONS
FUNDRAISING- EXPANDING OUR
PROGRAM HELPED US HIRE FACULTY-
DEVELOPMENT FOR FACULTY
PROFESSIONAL DEVELOPMENT.
SCHOLARSHIPS AND ANDRES IS JUST
IT'S ABSOLUTELY CREDIBLE AND I
JUST SAID HEY YOU KNOW WHAT WE
LISTEN TO THEM. I GET THEIR
ADVICE THEY HELP ME WITH
CURRICULA DEVELOPMENT AS WELL
AS RECHARGE INSTRUCT REVOLVE
MAKE SURE STILL CURRENT WHAT
WE'RE TEACHING- I REALLY RELY
PRETTY HEAVILY ON THEIR
EXPERTISE. HERE SCHOLARSHIP
SEARCHES OF ONE GROUP OF
SCHOLARSHIP THERE'S THE DEAN
THERE AND ONE PERSON FROM OUR
INVITES REPORTERS WELL. IRISH
LOCAL HIGH SCHOOL SO- THESE ARE
SOME PICTURES ACTUALLY JUST
TAKEN LAST COUPLE WEEKS SO- I
HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE WITH
HIGH SCHOOLS ARE SOME LISTED
pTRADE PROGRAMS GOING ON
CHILDREN HIGH SCHOOL IS THE ONE
YOU SEE UP FRONT YOU THERE THEY
HAVE AN INCREDIBLE AMOUNT OF
SPACE. AND JEFF PARKER RUNS
THAT PROGRAM IS JUST DONE A
FABULOUS JOB IN. I MAKE SURE
THAT I GET THE VISIBILITY TO
THE STUDENTS TO DECIDE IF THEY
DON'T WANT TO GO ON THE TRAYS
THEY WANT TO GO THE COLLEGE
ROUTE. I HELP THEM WITH THAT WE
HAVE SCHOLARSHIPS AVAILABLE FOR
THOSE STUDENTS WHO CHOOSE TO GO
THAT ROUTE AS WELL- BUT SHOT A
HIGH SCHOOL DEGREE PROGRAM HER
LOCALLY ROSEMONT HIGH SCHOOL
ALSO HAS A PRETTY PHENOMENAL
PROGRAM. A FULL SOME HIGH
SCHOOL START EXPAND THERE'S OUR
BUILDING ENGINEERING BUILDING
RIGHT NOW MY SON GOES ARSENAL
OF ABOUT THAT PROGRAM AS WELL A
LEAK IN HIGH SCHOOL DOWN THE
STOCKTON ALSO VERY LARGE TRADE
PROGRAM- FOR THEIR STUDENTS.
AND GRANITE BAY HIGH SCHOOL-
HAS A LITTLE BIT GOING ON TO
WITH US. THE COLLEGE GROUP
OUTSIDE. REAL QUICKLY ON THOSE
AUTOMATION THERE THE SECOND
HAND OUT I HAVE RUN YOU IS. IS
THERE'S A THERE'S AN
OPPORTUNITY HERE- SO
CONTRACTORS STATE LICENSE
BOARD- IN NINETEEN NINETY ONE
PASSED A THEY GOT THIS PAST YOU
LEGISLATURE K. CONSTRUCTION
MANAGEMENT EDUCATION
SPONSORSHIP BACK. AND
ESSENTIALLY. THEY RECOGNIZE
THAT THE CONSTRUCTION MANAGER
PROGRAMS AT THE UNIVERSITY HERE
IN CALIFORNIA AND THERE'S NINE
OF THEM THAT ARE CREDITED YOUR
CALIFORNIA- WERE UNDERFUNDED
AND SO THEY HAVE THIS- THIS
IDEA THAT- IT. IS S. AS
CONTRACTORS RENEW THEIR LICENSE
THEY CAN OPT TO GIVE AN
ADDITIONAL DONATION TOWARDS
THIS FUND AND WHEN THE FUN
REACHES A HUNDRED FIFTY
THOUSAND DOLLARS THEN IT'S A
THEN THERE ARE ELIGIBLE TO
START DISTRIBUTING GRANTS AND
THE GRANTS GO DIRECTLY BACK TO
THE PROGRAMS. THAT HAVE
CONSTRUCTION MANAGEMENT AND YOU
HAVE TO HAVE AT LEAST HALF YOUR
GRADUATES GO WORK FOR
CALIFORNIA PORTERS YOU CAN READ
OUR PERCENT SO IT'S NOT A BIG
DEAL- IT IS VOLUNTARY AND-
BECAUSE IT'S VOLUNTARY I THINK
IT GETS MISSED A LOT AND WE
NEED TO. NEED TO CONTINUE TO
ADVERTISE FOR ELEVEN FLEUR NOW
IT'S OUT THERE IT'S- I'M A
CONTRACTOR IS WELL IT'S A FORM
AT ALL RENEWAL FEE EVERY YEAR.
IF AND THERE'S- ALMOST THREE
HUNDRED THOUSAND ACTIVE
CONTRACTORS RIGHT NOW. SO IF
EVERY CONTRACTOR EVERY YEAR
JUST GAVE ONE DOLLAR EVERY
OTHER YEAR IT WOULD FUNDED
EVERY YEAR- SO IT'S NOT A LHASA
TELLS YOU I THINK THIS IS. WE
DON'T AND WE JUST NEED TO
EDUCATE THEM THAT IT'S
AVAILABLE THERE OR POSSIBLY
TURN INTO A FEE. WHICH WOULD BE
NICE OTHER STATES DO THAT- I DO
GET A CHANCE TO TRAVEL. QUITE A
BIT TO OTHER PROGRAMS ACROSS
UNITED STATES HERE THEY'RE
DOING BECAUSE I'M ON AN
ACCREDITATION WERE NATIONAL
ACCREDITATION WORK. AND THEIR
SCHOOLS ARE BRINGING IN. FIVE
EIGHT HUNDRED THOUSAND DOLLARS
A YEAR FROM THIS SORT OF
PROGRAM FOR THE PROGRAM TO HELP
FUND- EXPANDING. AND YOU KNOW
SUPPLIES AND HIRING FACULTY AND
SO FORTH SO. AND SOME I LIKE TO
DEFINITELY CONTINUE TO PUSH.
FOR THE PROGRAM- GOT SOME GREAT
ACCOLADES HERE IS ONE OF OUR
GRADUATES. I WAS FORTUNE OF TO
BE TEACHER. THIS IS ONE OF TO
GRADUATES A GRADUATE TWO
THOUSAND EIGHT. AND THEY SAW A
NEED IN THE INDUSTRY. AND IN
TWO THOUSAND TEN THEY LEFT
THEIR JOBS AND- MAX OUT THEIR
CREDIT CARDS IS DECIDED. TO
STARTED OUT AND- ACTUALLY- GOT
A START UP THE FUNDING FOR IT.
AND IN TWO THOUSAND EIGHTEEN
THEY SOLD IT FOR EIGHT HUNDRED
FIFTY MILLION DOLLARS. GOOD
AMAZING. THIS IS SOME HANDS ON
FACULTY LEADS YOU TO RESIST ONE
BIG PROJECT THAT WE DID OVER
THE LAST YOU KNOW TEN YEARS OR
SO- AND- THIS IS KIND OF ACROSS
MANY DISCIPLINES- YET THE
UNIVERSITY TO DEVELOP THIS WE
COMPETED IN A INTERNATIONAL
DEPARTMENT OF ENERGY US ALREADY
CATALOG WHERE YOU BASICALLY
HAVE TO CREATE A HOME THAT'S-
NETZERO SO YOU- YOU GENERATE
MORE ENERGY THAN YOU USE AND
THERE'S A SERIES OF TESTS YOU
DO TO DO THAT. IT WAS A BIG
THING TO TAKE ON MYSELF ONE
OTHER FACULTY- LET IT AND ON
THE LEFT IS THE RENDERING ON
THE RIGHT IS THE ACTUAL
STRUCTURE TURNED OUT VERY WELL-
AND WE DID WE DID QUITE WELL IN
THE COMPETITION IN FACT HERE IT
IS AT THE SITE IT HAPPEN TO BE
IRVINE SO TWENTY UNIVERSITIES
AROUND THE WORLD. FIRST WAY
SUITE IN ITS I MEAN IT WAS
GREAT TO SEE SOME IS COMPETENT.
I GOT THEIR STRUCTURES OVER TO
UNITED STATES WAS THAT IN
ITSELF WAS A FEET. UP ON THE
RIGHT THERE IS THE SECTOR THE
BERMAN VANITY OR IF THERE AND-
YOU KNOW WITH US IN OUR
STUDENTS ON OUR- DECK ON OUR
HOME. THOSE PRETTY EXCITING
PROJECT. THAT'S IT FOR ME SO
THANK YOU CHAIR FOR HAVING US
TODAY AND- I HOPE THE BILL HAVE
MORE CONVERSATIONS ABOUT THIS
IN THE FUTURE THANK YOU VERY
MUCH A GREAT RECITATION
APPRECIATED- I DON'T KNOW OR
YOU COULD GO IN AND RIGHT ON
THE SIDE. THIS IS GAVE OUT HERE.
FOR ENERGY THE I. THANK YOU
YEAH. OKAY AND THIS IS WORKING
AGES AT THE BUTTON HERE. ONCE
YOU YARDAGE OF RUN HERE. ALL
RIGHT THANKS YOU WANT THIS ONE.
I THINK I GOT THIS ONE. OF THE
JUST PUSHED WRONG YOU. ALL THIS
WHEN THEY'RE NOT ON. THAT RIGHT
GOT IT OKAY THANK YOU. LOVE SEX
DATE YEAH YEAH. I'M ALUMNI SO
RIGHT ON SEX DATE AS WONDERFUL
PROGRAM- AND SO MY NAME IS
SIMEON GANT AND THANK YOU FOR
HAVING US HERE- I'M THE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR AND FOUNDER
OF THE PROGRAM WE CALL GREEN.
TECHNICAL EDUCATION AND
EMPLOYMENT- WE TAKE A- YOU KNOW
AFTER EVERYTHING THAT'S BEEN
SAID- YOU KNOW GREEN TECH- HAS
KIND OF FOLLOWED SUIT ON THAT
AND WE DO TAKE A MORE
GRASSROOTS APPROACH SINCE. TWO
THOUSAND AND SIX WHEN THEY
PASSED ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY
TWO. THE GLOBAL WARMING-
SOLUTIONS ACT GREEN TECH- YOU
KNOW WE THOUGHT THAT THE- YOUNG
PEOPLE REALLY TO GET
OPPORTUNITY TO KIND OF FIGURE
OUT. OF WHICH DIRECTION THEY
CAN GO IN- IN THIS NEW-
ENVIRONMENTAL- WORLD RIGHT-
WE'RE GONNA PROTECT OUR
ENVIRONMENT HOWEVER WE'RE GONNA
DO IT THROUGH OUR
INFRASTRUCTURE DEVELOPMENT-
ESSENTIALLY WE LOOKED AT- HOW.
A LOT OF THESE YOUNG FOLKS
DON'T REALIZE THAT. YOU KNOW
FOLKS ARE AGING OUT THE
CONSTRUCTION INDUSTRY IT NEEDS
NEW BLOOD THEY NEED NEW PEOPLE
TO COME IN BUT THE- VOCABULARY
CHANGING- YOU KNOW BEFORE ALL
OF THIS WE DON'T KNOW WHAT
CARBON FOOTPRINT WAS WE CAN
TALK ABOUT THE CARBON
FOOTPRINT. WE TALK ABOUT AN
ANAEROBIC DIGESTION WE DIDN'T
REALIZE THAT THINGS LIKE- WE
CAN USE WASTE TO CREATE FUEL-
AND THERE'S JOBS AND
OPPORTUNITIES THERE- AND SO
WHAT WE DO NOW WITH GREEN TECH
IS WE BRING IN YOUNG FOLKS
AGES. SIXTEEN TO TWENTY ONE.
AND WE TEACH THEM A CAREER
OPPORTUNITIES IN CLEAN ENERGY.
ENERGY EFFICIENCY AND
SUSTAINABLE LIVING STRATEGIES
AND WE TALK TO OUR STUDENTS
ABOUT- WITH SUSTAINABLE LIVING
MEANS WE TALK TO THEM ABOUT
GROWING THEIR OWN FOOD. WE TALK
TO THEM ABOUT HEALTHY MAKING
HEALTHY DECISIONS WE TALK TO
THEM ABOUT CONSTRUCTION YOU
COULD ACTUALLY LITERALLY BUILD
YOUR OWN HOUSE. AND SO WE
TALKED TO THEM ABOUT THE
SUSTAINABLE ENERGY ARE
SUSTAINABLE LIVING STRATEGIES
BUT THEN THERE'S ALSO- HOW DO
WE REDUCE THE FOSSIL FUEL
ENERGY. RIGHT THAT WERE USING
AND SO WE TALK TO THEM ABOUT-
RENEWABLE ENERGY SOLAR. WIND
WATER TURNING WASTE INTO. I'M
FEEL. PACIFIC LEE IN AREAS OF
CONSTRUCTION. TRANSPORTATION
MANUFACTURING. UTILITIES AND
ENVIRONMENTAL MANAGEMENT NO WE
RECOGNIZE THAT A LOT OF OUR
YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE NEVER KNOWN
AS EVER TOLD HIM IN HIGH SCHOOL
THAT YOU COULD GET A GOOD JOB
AND- UTILITIES INDUSTRY. AND
WITH UTILITIES INDUSTRY GOING
MORE SOLAR. ON WHETHER THEY
WANT TO OR NOT. RIGHT THEY
THEY'RE DOING IT- CURRENTLY WE
HAVE A BIG PROJECT- WHERE WE
ARE INSTALLING ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING STATIONS. AND SO ONE
OF THE ISSUES THAT WE HAVE WITH
THE STUDENTS AROUND TOWN. IT'S
JUST GETTING THEM TO WORK
SITES. AND SO WE'RE WORKING
WITH THE AIR QUALITY MANAGEMENT
DISTRICT IN THE AIR RESOURCES
BOARD. TO DO A FROM A NONPROFIT
A COMMUNITY BASED PERSPECTIVE.
HAVE AN ACTUAL ELECTRIC VEHICLE
TRANSPORTATION CENTER. SO NOW
WE ALSO CREATING JOBS WE'RE
ALSO GETTING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE
AROUND TOWN TO WORK SITES- WITH
ZERO EMISSIONS. AND SO. WE GOT
TO MAKE A GREEN AND SEXY. IT'S
VERY DIFFICULT RIDE AS BEEN
MENTIONED ALL DAY LONG YOU KNOW
ALLOW YOUNG FOLKS DON'T WANT TO
GOING TO CONSTRUCTION. WHEN THE
WAY SOME OF THE WAYS THAT WE
TRY TO MAKE IT SEXY IS TRIED WE
HAVE TOURS WE'VE TAKEN I'M ON-
WE'VE TAKEN HIM TO THE GOLDEN
ONE CENTER WHEN IT WAS STILL
BEING BUILT. WE'VE TAKEN THEM
TO THE ANAEROBIC DIGESTION WE
TAKE ON THE GOOGLE WE'VE TAKEN
TO ALL THESE DIFFERENT PLACES
TO TRY TO ENCOURAGE THEM YOU
KNOW WE TALK ABOUT ELECTRIC
VEHICLES AND OF COURSE THEY
KIND OF FROWNED AT WHEN THEY
THINK ABOUT THE PRIUS. SO WE
BROUGHT THEM A TESLA. WE'VE
TAKEN THEM TO THE TEST LE PLANT
SO THAT THEY CAN SEE THE JOB
OPPORTUNITIES THAT ARE THERE.
WE GIVEN HANDS ON PROJECTS. WE
PROVIDE THEM WITH STIPENDS AND
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH HOPE. A
LOT OF OUR YOUNG PEOPLE HAVE-
SOCIAL EMOTIONAL ISSUES THAT WE
HAVE TO WORK WITH AS WELL- ONE
OF THE HANDS ON PROJECTS THAT
WE HAVE IS CALLED THE SOLAR
SUITCASE. SOLIS THROUGH CASE
GIVE THEM AN OPPORTUNITY TO BE
INTRODUCED TO ELECTRICAL
CIRCUITRY. AND SOLAR
TECHNOLOGY. THE BILL THIS
PORTABLE LIGHTING SYSTEM THAT'S
POWERED BY THE SUN. AND THEN WE
SEND IT TO PLACES LIKE HAITI IN
AFRICA WHERE THEY ACTUALLY NEED
THE LIGHT HAVE A POOR GRID
SYSTEMS AND SO WE'RE OUT GIVING
THE STUDENTS AN OPPORTUNITY TO
BE- PHILANTHROPIST AND SO IN
SOME FORM. AS WELL ON TO GIVE
HIM AND JUST TRY HER BEST TO
AGAIN MAKE THAT MAKE IT SEXY
ARMS WE ALSO PROVIDE THEM WITH
SOFT SKILLS- WE HAVE RESUME
WRITING- SESSIONS INTERVIEW
TECHNIQUES TIME MANAGEMENT. AND
BUDGETING. SO I MENTION THE
FIVE ELEMENTS OF GREENTECH A
CONSTRUCTION SUSTAINABILITY
MANAGEMENT- TRANSPORTATION
UTILITIES. MANUFACTURING
ENVIRONMENTAL MANAGEMENT. LOT
OF AGRICULTURE WE DO A LOT OF
AGRICULTURE IN SOMETHING CALLED
AQUACULTURE WE HAVE SOMETHING
CALLED AQUAPONICS A ONE
THOUSAND SQUARE FOOT GREENHOUSE
ARM ON PROPERTY HERE AT OAK
PARK IN SACRAMENTO AND WE'RE
TEACHING OUR YOUNG PEOPLE HOW
TO GROW. FOOD VEGETABLES
LETTUCE- IN IN THIS AQUA
AQUAPONICS SYSTEM- WE ALSO
PROVIDE THEM UNDERSTANDING OF
ECOLOGY LIFE SCIENCES-
LANDSCAPING AND WASTE
MANAGEMENT. AND SO ARM. OF IT
IS YOU KNOW JUST KIND OF
KEEPING THEM INTERESTED- WE DO
PROVIDE- WEATHERIZATION
TRAINING TEACHING THEM THE
INSIDE OF A BUILDING BUILDING
SCIENCES- AS WE GROW WE REALIZE
THAT MC THREE IS THE STANDARD
AND YOU KNOW WE NEED FUNDS AND
WE NEED OPPORTUNITIES TO BE
ABLE TO BRING IN INSTRUCTORS
WHO CAN TEACH OUR STUDENTS AND
KIND OF MOVING FROM A
GRASSROOTS LEVEL TOOL MORE
FORMALIZED- LEVEL. I'M WE DO
DISCUSS OUR- GETTING INTO
COLLEGE WITH OUR STUDENTS- WE
HAVE SOMEONE ON OUR TEAM WHO-
WORKS AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
WE ARE PARTNERED WITH THE
CONSUMERS RIVER COLLEGE AND SO
WE TRY TO DO THAT WARM HAND
OFF- AND BRING THEM STRAIGHT
FROM- WORKING IN HIGH SCHOOL
AND WORKING ON OUR FARM- AND
GETTING THEM RIGHT INTO COLLEGE.
SO WE ALSO CONSIDER
ENTREPRENEURSHIP SO THEY'RE
LEARNING- HAD A BILL PLANTER
BOXES IN THE LEARNING HOW TO
GROW FOOD AND SO WILL TAKE THEM
TO THE FARMERS MARKET AND SAY
LOOK. OF FROM BEGINNING TO END
THIS IS ARE YOU CAN ACTUALLY
MAKE MONEY- AND THIS IS JUST A-
A MODEL. YOU CAN LEARN HOW TO
DO THIS THIS WAY YOU CAN LEARN
HOW T BUILD YOUR OWN BUSINESS
DOING ANYTHING ONCE YOU'VE DONE
IT A FEW TIMES. ARE WE TAKING
THEM TO THESE TRIPS THIS ONE IN
PARTICULAR. IS AT THE REGIONAL
TRANSIT LIGHT RAIL MAINTENANCE
YARD. EVERY TIME WE TAKE OUR
STUDENTS TO THIS- AINTENANCE
ARE FOR THE LIGHT RAIL- THE
GENTLEMAN THERE KERRY TELLS IS
THERE'S TONS OF JOBS AVAILABLE
AND SO WE JUST WANT TO GET OUR
STUDENTS KIND OF PREPARED AND
READY FOR THOSE PARTICULAR
JOBS. AS I MENTIONED BEFORE
UTILITY COMPANIES PUBLIC
TRANSIT COMPANIES MANUFACTURING
PLANTS CONSTRUCTION COMPANIES
IN EVEN A GOVERNMENT JOBS BUT
WE ALSO- WE ALSO LET THEM KNOW
THAT THEY HAVE OPPORTUNITIES IN
THIS TRADE SCHOOLS AND THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES AS WELL THIS
IS ONE OF OUR- A SOLAR SUIT
CASE PROJECTS. ON THE LEFT WITH
OUR PARTNERSHIP WITH A
CONSUMERS RIVER COLLEGE AND ON
THE RIGHT THAT WAS- A SOLIS TO
CASE THAT WE SENT TO PORTER
RICO- ON THEIR ONE OF THEIR
LATEST- ON WHETHER.
CATASTROPHES. SO AGAIN ON THE
ON THE ENTREPRENEURSHIP
OPPORTUNITIES WE DO RECOGNIZE
THAT THEY THESE ARE
TRANSFERABLE SKILLS- THEY CAN
DO LANDSCAPE BUSINESSES THEY
CAN DO URBAN FORESTRY ENTRY
SERVICES- HOME IMPROVEMENT-
SOLAR ELECTRICAL AGE BACK AND
ENERGY EFFICIENCY CONSULTING-
AND OF COURSE WE'VE GOT A WE'VE
GOT A FARM STAND. AND SO- ONE
OF THE OTHER THINGS I DIDN'T
MENTION IS THAT WE ALSO TEACH
COMPUTER CODING- OUR GOAL IS TO
KIND OF MAILED AND MERGE SOME
OF THE- KIND OF CONSTRUCTION-
JOBS IN THE FARMING JOBS WITH
OUR COMPUTER CODING AND
BUILDING APPS AND THAT SORT OF
THING- THE BIG PROJECT OF
COURSE IS THE ELECTRIC VEHICLE
CHARGING STATION. AND OUR GOAL
IS TO BUILD AN APT TO- CREATE A
RIGHT HILL ON PROGRAM IN THE
COMMUNITY OF DEL PASO HEIGHTS.
SO WE HAVE BEEN BILLED PLANTER
BOXES- AS INTRODUCTION ON HOW
TO BUILD. YOU KNOW A LOT OF
THEM DON'T KNOW- YOU KNOW HOW
TO. USE A TAPE MEASURE BUT WHEN
THEY LEAVE GREEN TECH THEY KNOW
THE DIFFERENCE BETWEEN A HAMMER
AND INNOCENT- DRILL. AND A SAW.
WE DO HAVE TO IDENTIFICATION
TESTING WE ALSO DO- SHOULD TEN
TRAINING AND CPR TRAINING AS
WELL. AND THAT'S ALL THAT IS
OUR- PROPERTY IN OAK PARK ALL
THIS THE STUDENTS OF BILL BOTH
PLANTER BOXES- DAVE- PLANET
THE- THOSE VEGETABLES. AND
INSIDE THAT US- GREENHOUSE IS A
THREE OF OUR AQUAPONICS SYSTEMS.
THANK YOU. SO IS YOUR PROGRAM-
AN AFTER SCHOOL PROGRAMMERS IN
AN ALTERNATIVE EDUCATION
PROGRAM OR OR HOW IT HOW IT HOW
ARE YOU FUNDED IN WHAT WHAT HOW
DO YOU GET THE KIDS CERTAINLY
SO. WE DO BOTH AFTER SCHOOL ON
SATURDAY MORNINGS. NAM AFTER
SCHOOL THREE THIRTY OF THE
STUDENTS COMMON WE DO OUR
AGRICULTURE PROGRAM. AND THEN
SATURDAY MORNINGS WERE DOING A
LOT OF- URBAN FORESTRY AND-
LANDSCAPING AS WELL AS- WOOD
WORKING ON SATURDAY MORNINGS-
THE STUDENTS IS VERY
INTERESTING BECAUSE WE GIVE
STIPENDS. A LOT OF WORD OF
MOUTH- HOWEVER WE DO HAVE A
CONTRACT WITH THE SACRAMENTO
COUNTY OFFICE OF EDUCATION. AND
SO YOU KNOW A LOT OF WHAT'S
BEEN TALKED TODAY. IS THE FIRST
THING TWO WORDS THE TRADITIONAL
SCHOOLS AND THAT'SGREAT
HOWEVER A LOT OF OUR YOUNG
PEOPLE ARE NOT MAKING IT IN
THESE TRADITIONAL SCHOOLS
RIGHT. AND SO WE'RE DOING
OUTREACH TO STUDENTS WHO ARE
TRADITIONALLY- ON THE EDGES.
AND WE BRING THEM IN AND WE
MAKE IT SEXY. WE BRING THE MEN
WE TALK ABOUT WAYS THAT THEY
CAN MAKE IT. AND SO IT'S A
RECRUITING PROCESS- OUR FUNDING
COMES FROM SCULLY OUR FUNDING
COMES FROM GRANTS WE HAVE A
GRANT WITH THE ENVIRONMENT
PROTECTION AGENCY THE STATE AND
THE EPA. ON ENVIRONMENTAL
JUSTICE PROGRAM. COMMENTS WE
CODDLE THESE FUNDS TO OTHER TO
TRY PROVIDE FUNDING TO OUR
INTEREST OWNERS. YOUNG PEOPLE
MATERIALS BE. ABLE TO DO THE
PROJECTS AND THEY THEY GET AT.
CREDIT FOR SCHOOL THE STUDENTS
FROM SCHOOL WITH THE CATHOLIC.
THE OFFICE OF EDUCATION THEY DO
GET CREDIT YEAH IT'S LIKE THAT
ARE. INDEPENDENT STUDIES. SO
YES SOME OF OUR STUDENTS ARE
ABSOLUTELY ON INDEPENDENT
STUDIES AND HOME STUDIES. YEAH
I'M I'M JUST TRYING TO
UNDERSTAND BECAUSE THAT'S- PART
OF I THINK. THE OPPORTUNITY IS
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT. WHAT DO
WE NEED TO DO WITH IT THE- HEAD
COACH TO PROVIDE THE
FLEXIBILITY FOR SOME OF THESE
MODELS AND. I HAVE DONE IN A
NUMBER OF TOURS AND I AM JUST
REALLY IMPRESSED WITH THE
NUMBER OF HIGH SCHOOLS THAT ARE
DOING TOOL PROGRAMS WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. AND HAVE.
IGNITED YOUNG PEOPLE. TO COULD
GO THE EXTRA MILE TO BE ABLE TO
GRADUATE WITH AN EIGHTY AT THE
SAME TIME THAT THE GRADUATING
WITH A HIGH SCHOOL DIPLOMA AND
I- I'M I GUESS I STRUGGLE
TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHY ISN'T
EVERYBODY DOING THIS RIGHT- AND
LOOKING AT OPPORTUNITIES TO
BRING IN NONTRADITIONAL KIDS
GET A LOT OF KIDS DON'T LEARN
BY SITTING AT A DESK AND BEING
QUIET YEAH AND- FRANKLY MANY OF
THEM GET MOVED OFF TO SOME
OTHER PLACE BECAUSE THEY CAN'T
SIT QUIETLY AND YET IF YOU PUT
A MINUTE ENVIRONMENT WHERE
THEY'RE WORKING WITH THEIR
HANDS. OR THEY'RE WORKING AS A
TEAM THEN THEY CAN TALK ABOUT
WHAT THEY'RE DOING AND IT'S NOT
IT'S A DIFFERENT MODALITIES
HAVE SO- I'M I'M REALLY
INTERESTED IN LOOKING AT WAYS
THAT WE CAN INCENTIVIZE THAT
KIND OF CREATIVITY AND. TRY TO
BUILD AN OPPORTUNITY FOR KIDS
TO BE ABLE TO TRY EVERYTHING.
SO THAT THEY CAN FIGURE OUT
WHAT THE LIKE ABSOLUTE AND WE
CAN ENCOURAGE THEM TO START
THINKING ABOUT THAT A LOT
EARLIER THAN WE'RE DOING. WE'RE
DOING NOW. YES IN THE- SO WHY
AM I I'M NOT SURE I HAVE A
CLUE. WELL I GUESS MY QUESTION
IS- ARE THERE OBSTACLES TO THE
DUAL ENROLLMENT PROGRAM. THAT
WOULD BE THAT THAT WE COULD BE
HELPFUL FOR NUMBER ONE IS OUR
OBSTACLES AND NUMBER TWO IS ONE
OF THOSE OBSTACLES MONEY- AND
ARE THERE. CHANGES TO THE END
COULD THAT WE NEED TO CONSIDER
IN ORDER TO. TO TRY TO
INCENTIVIZE MORE MORE STUDENTS
GOING INTO- THE TRADE I A I
KNOW THAT FOR A WHILE. THERE
THERE WAS TRACKING GOING ON IN
THAT THAT WAS ONE OF THE
REASONS THAT THAT. THAT WE
CHANGE THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM
SO IT BECAME MUCH MORE
DIFFICULT TO TRACK BUT IT JUST
SEEMS TO ME THAT WE WENT WE
SWUNG SO FAR AWAY FROM- FROM
KERR AGING SOME OF SOME F THE-
VOCATIONAL EDUCATION PROGRAMS
THAT THAT STUDENTS HAVE LOST
THE ABILITY TO THINK THAT
THAT'S A GOOD PATHWAY. SO I'M
I'M I'M I GUESS I'M LOOKING AT
IS THERE IS THERE ARE THERE ARE
CHALLENGES TO THE DUAL
ENROLLMENT AND ARE THE THINGS
WE NEED TO DO. THERE ARE A
COUPLE OF CHALLENGES ONE IS IT
HAS TO DO WITH THE AND- AND I'M
SPEAKING FROM LIMITED KNOWLEDGE
GIVEN I'M ONLY BEING HUNDRED
DAYS AND CALIFORNIA IN MY
POSITION SO. IT BEAR WITH ME ON
THAT. I FOR ONE CHALLENGES OF
COURSE IS A CLASS SCHEDULE IN
THE HIGH SCHOOL THAT REALLY HAS
TO DO WITH. BECAUSE IT MAY
REQUIRE THEIR DISC TO THAN TO
GO ELSEWHERE TO GET THOSE TO A
LENORMAND COURSE SO THAT'S WHEN
SHELVE FUNDING YES IS A
PROBLEM. BUT I THINK. A LOT OF
THE- DUAL ENROLLMENT THAT IS
HAPPENING AND CALIFORNIA'S NON
UNIQUE IN THIS. IT IS HAPPENING
BETWEEN. A RELATIONSHIP WHICH
IS GOOD THAT IS BUILT BETWEEN
THE INSTRUCTOR AT THE HIGH-
THAT AND TEACHER AT THE HIGH
SCHOOL IN THE INSTRUCTED THE
COMMUNICATE LIKE IT DOESN'T GET
BECOME SYSTEMATIC AND THAT'S
WHAT I'VE- IS SO I MEAN I WOULD
RIDE THE STATE I CAME FROM WAS
THE IOWA. AND I WOULD RECOMMEND
THAT DAD DOES ACTUALLY IS. IT
WAS PUT INTO THE I WILL CALL TO
HOW THEY WOULD FIND
SYSTEMATICALLY DUAL ENROLLMENT
SO I AT THAT WOULD DOES IT DID
TO A DIVISION THAT THE THAT
WOULD THAT WOULD BE MY
SUGGESTION BUT I THINK PART OF
IT IS SIMPLY. SYSTEM MY SISTER
DIES IN THAT WE GET WE AT CITY
HALL AT COLLEGE GOING COURSES
THAT INCLUDES NOT ONLY BULLARD
ALMOND BUT IT CAN INCLUDE
ARTICULATE AND IT DOES INCLUDE
SOME OF THE A. P. AND IB
COURSES AT THAT ARE THERE. AND
YOUR OUT I TRADITION STUDENTS
ARE I. PLAYED TO LOOK AT IS
REALLY THE FUNDING MY DEBT FROM
ME AND I MIGHT BE. THIN
FLEXIBLE BEFORE FOR TOM FOR.
46% IS THERE ON THAT'S WHAT
I'VE BEEN TOLD I MAKE IT. YEAH
ABSOLUTELY. I'M I JUST ON THE
DUAL ENROLLMENT ISSUE AYE AYE
AND EVERY STATE'S DIFFERENT BUT
YOU KNOW THE LEGISLATURE IN
THEIR WISDOM IN THE GOVERNOR
NOW CREATED- TUITION FREE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO WE'RE
FINDING STUDENTS AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL IN THE
COURSE WORK THAT THEY TAKE IT
NO COST AND WE CERTAINLY ARE
DOING THAT IN THE HIGH SCHOOLS
AND SO IT SEEMS LIKE AT AGAIN I
HEAR ISSUES ABOUT FUNDING- WHO
FINDS THE TEXTBOOK- WHERE IT'S
LOCATED IT JUST SEEMS LIKE THAT
THAT'S A BIG BARRIER THAT'S
BEEN REMOVED NOW AND NOW WE
NEED TO GET SYSTEMS TOGETHER
SILENCE AND ACTUALLY JUST THINK
ABOUT THE KIDS WHAT'S- FOR THE
KIDS. WHERE IT HAPPENS YOUR
PLACE MY PLACE AND I JUST WANT
TO SAY TO THE CHAIR THAT ANY
KIND OF WORK IN THIS YEAR I'D
LOVE TO TRY TO PARTNER AND BE
SUPPORTIVE BECAUSE I THINK THAT
WE HAVE TO GET OUT OF THIS IDEA
OF THIS THERE ONE WAY THERE'S
ONE TRACK FOR A STUDENT AND- I
THINK THAT THAT THERE THERE ARE
STUDENTS THAT ARE ENTERING HIGH
SCHOOL THAT COULD BEGIN COLLEGE
AND A BA DO ON ALL THAT WE HAVE
TO GO. AT THEM AS THEY ARE AND
FIND THE BEST WAY FOR THEM TO
BE SUCCESSFUL AND HAPPY PROSPER
AND I THINK THAT THE SILOS CAN
GET IN THE WAY BUT SOMETIMES
THAT MEANS WE NEED SOME SMART
LEGISLATORS. WELL I WITH SOME
GREAT PARTNERS TO FIND A WAY
THROUGH. IT SAID THAT THE OUR
FOCUS ON WHAT MATTERS. MAY I
ADD ONE MORE THING TITLE. WHEN
DOLAN MOMENT HAPPENS TYPICALLY
IT'S AROUND THE WHAT I WOULD
CALL THE ACADEMIC COURSES
BECAUSE STUDENTS ARE LOOKING TO
THE A TO G. TRYING TO MEET
THOSE REQUIREMENTS I THINK
THERE HAS TO BE SORT OF MORE
EMPHASIS OF INVOLVING C. T. IN
THIS PROCESS OF DUAL ENROLLMENT
AS WELL. I APPRECIATE THAT AND
I DO AGREE AND I AGREE WITH. AS
SENATOR GLAZIER IT'S- THE IT'S
THE REASON I ASK THE QUESTION
IS THAT. THERE USED TO BE A
LIMIT ON HOW MANY COURSES A
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT. COULD TAKE
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE IN.
SATISFACTION OF THE HIGH SCHOOL
REQUIREMENTS AND THE REASON WHY
SAYS THEY WANTED KIDS TO STAY
IN THE HIGH SCHOOL AND NOT TO
BE TAKING UP THE STUFF THAT'S
IN THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AT
LEAST THAT'S HOW IT WAS
REPORTED TO ME. BUT NOW AND I
THINK WELL ACTUALLY I CAN'T SAY
FOR SURE BUT BUT NOW I THINK
YOU'RE RIGHT IT'S THAT THAT WE
HAVE WE HAVE- MADE IT A LOT
EASIER TO GO TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. FIRST STUDENTS THAT
WERE CLEAN- FINANCIALLY. AND
THE ABILITY TO ACTUALLY DO
BOTH. AT THE SAME TIME COULD BE.
VERY VERY IMPORTANT. AND IF I
MAY IN RESPONSE THE D. A. YES.
BUT THINK ABOUT IT THAT IF YOU
HAVE A STUDENT THAT'S WHAT IT'S
CAPABLE AND WILLING TO GO TAKE
A COMMUNITY COLLEGE LEVEL
COURSES- EARLY- THAT THAT WHAT
THEY GET OUT OF IT IS. THOUGHT
ABOUT A TO G. ANYMORE BECAUSE
THEY AT THE END OF THEIR FOUR
YEARS. THERE AND ABILITY TO
TRANSFER TO A FOUR YEAR BECAUSE
THEY'VE COMPLETED. THE SIXTY
UNITS OF GENERAL EDUCATION AT
THE OLLEGE LEVEL. SO THE WHOLE
A THROUGH G. ISSUE CAN GONNA
GET IN THE WAY OF WHAT THAT
REALLY CAN ACCOMPLISH THAT
MEANS THAT THAT. NOW GRADUATING
HIGH SCHOOL STUDENT IS ABLE TO
STAVE TWO YEARS OF COLLEGE TIME
AND MONEY. AND BE ABLE TO
TRANSFER IF THEY IF IT'S
APPROPRIATE OR IT COULD BE THAT
THROUGH A TRADE WHERE IT'S NOT
APPROPRIATE. THEY'VE COMPLETED
BUT THERE'S HUGH ENORMOUS
SAVINGS FOR THE STUDENT AND FOR
THE STATE TO STATE IF WE CAN DO
IT CORRECTLY SO IT'S A- I KNOW
THE AB IS A STICKLER. BUT KIDS
ORG. THAT IS A DIFFERENT TRACK
AT DIFFERENT PURPOSE BUT DIE I
THINK THESE THINGS CAN BE
WORKED. OUT IF WE STAY FOCUSED
ON WHAT MATTER. I DO AGREE. DID
YOU. ANY ANY OTHER COMMENTS TO
THE TO THE DUAL ENROLLMENT OUR
OR OUR OR THINGS THAT WE NEED
TO CHANGE I DO APPRECIATE YOU
COMING WITH SOME TASKS- WORK TO
DO- BECAUSE THAT'S REALLY WERE
WHERE WE WANT TO GO NEXT IS
WHAT WHAT OUR NEXT STEPS IN
TERMS OF LOOKING AT AT THIS
ISSUE AND WHAT ARE SOME OF THE
THINGS THAT. THAT THAT WE CAN
DO HERE IN THE LEGISLATURE-
BOTH IN TERMS OF IN A BUT IN A
BUDGET- AS WE LOOK AT THE
BUDGET BUT ALSO AS WE LOOK AT.
AT THE REQUIREMENTS MAKING SURE
THAT WE WANT TO THAT WE CAN
INCENTIVIZE DUTIES. I THINK IT
WAS MENTIONED EARLIER YOU KNOW
AT LEAST YOU KNOW FROM OUR
PERSPECTIVE TO PROVIDE MORE
ASSISTANCE TO THE COMMUNITY
BASED ORGANIZATIONS WHO CAN
WORK WITH THE SCHOOLS- YOU KNOW
I THINK THAT AGAIN AS YOU
MENTIONED YOU KNOW IN THE PAST
THERE WAS SOME TRACKING ISSUES
RIGHT BUT THINGS HAVE CHANGED-
IT WOULD. YOU KNOW MORE MORE
PEOPLE ARE DROPPING OUT OF
SCHOOL AND SO WE JUST GONNA
SHRUG OUR SHOULDERS- YOU KNOW
WE HAVE TO REALLY KIND OF FOCUS
AND- SAY LET'S BRING THEM BACK
AND- IF WE CAN GET MORE-
SUPPORT RESOURCES AND FUNDING
TO DO THAT AND SAY WE'RE IN THE
COMMUNITY. WE KNOW WHERE THEY
ARE AND WE KNOW HOW TO WORK
WITH THEM- WE CAN EITHER- WORK
WITH THEM TO GIVE THEM TRAINING
AND OR BRING THEM BACK INTO THE
SCHOOLS. YEAH I. AM A NOTATION
IN TERMS OF FUNDING FOR THAT
FIVE OH ONE C. THREE THAT'S
ALWAYS AT. A BIG ISSUE AND I
APPRECIATE. APPRECIATE THAT
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT THE SCHOOLS
IT'S ALSO ABOUT THE PARTNERS
THAT ARE ARE PART OF THAT. THE
TEAM AS WELL. YEAH MY BOSS
WOULD HAVE WANTED ME TO MAKE
THAT PLUG. YOU DID I HAVE
WRITTEN DOWN AND I. DO
APPRECIATE IT AND I THINK THAT.
THE BIGGER PICTURE AS WELL AND
I WAS LOOKING AT IT ONE OF THE
REPORTS WE HAD HERE. TALKED
ABOUT THE- THAT THE CHALLENGE
OF CALIFORNIA- AND FACES IN
REGARDS TO THE NUMBER OF ADULTS
THAT OVER SIXTEEN THAT ARE
WORKING OR LOOKING FOR WORK.
THAT NUMBER IS PARTICULARLY
HIGH IN THE STATE CAN ACTUALLY
I THINK IT'S THE HIGHEST IN THE
THIS IS THE STATE WHERE IT'S
THE HIGHEST AND- THAT THAT DATA
TELLS US THAT THERE ARE TOO
MANY PEOPLE THAT- FOR. FOR ONE
REASON OR ANOTHER AND I TO
CONTRIBUTING TO THE ECONOMY AND
THAT'S THAT'S WHAT YOU'RE
TALKING ABOUT THE DROP OUT
RATE- IT WE- WE HAVE TO FIGURE
OUT A WAY TO GET. THOSE PEOPLE
BACK INTO THE ECONOMY AND SO
IT'S NOT JUST ABOUT HIGH SCHOOL
IT'S ABOUT. GRAHAM SAID BRING
THE MEN. LOOK LIKE THAT LIKE
THAT. WHICH IS DOING IS
BRINGING THE MEN AND GIVING
THEM THAT THE TOOLS THEY NEED
TO BE ABLE TO BE SUCCESSFUL. SO
ON APPRECIATE YOUR TESTIMONY
HERE TODAY THERE ARE NO MORE
QUESTIONS THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR HELPING US TO SORT THROUGH
THIS AND FIGURE OUT. WHAT WE
NEED TO DO NEXT THANK YOU. VERY
MUCH. I YES ACTUALLY I DO I. AM
NOT LOOKING AT MY AGENDA SO
THAT THIS IS THE TIME FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT IF THERE'S
ANYONE THAT WOULD LIKE TO MAKE
PUBLIC COMMENT ONE INVITE YOU.
TO COME IN THE PANEL A YEAR
FREE TO GO. THANK YOU SO MUCH.
YES SIR. YES MY NAME'S MARK
I'VE SEEN I AM DIRECTOR THAT
CALIFORNIAN VIA MENTAL
TECHNOLOGY EDUCATION NETWORK
AND I WANT TO. TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO. FILL IN SOME
BLANKS AS THE QUESTIONS THAT
YOU HAD OF THIS PANEL- AND I
THINK A LOT OF NOT BEING
COMPLETE IS THAT. THIS GOES
BACK MANY YEARS THAT THEY
PROBABLY DON'T HAVE. AN
INSTITUTIONAL MEMORY- THE ISSUE
ON A THROUGH G. THE TUNNEL
VISION OF THE HIGH SCHOOLS TO
FOUR YEAR COLLEGE HAS BEEN A
PROBLEM FOR MANY YEARS- IT
REALLY WAS SEEN AS BEGINNING A
PROBLEM AFTER BEGINNING OF THE
CENTURY. AND BACK IT TO TRY TO
ANSWER THAT IN DEAL WITH THAT
BACK IN TWO THOUSAND AND FIVE.
THE LEGISLATURE PASSED SB
SEVENTY CARRIED BY SENATOR
JACK'S GOT I DON'T KNOW IF
YOU'RE AWARE ON THAT. BILL
WHICH WAS- LISTED. WITH THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGES TO CREATE A
SEAMLESS TRANSITION FROM HIGH
SCHOOL. TO THE COP COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. FOR CAREER TECHNICAL
EDUCATION. IN THE BOTTOM LINE
INTENT OF WHAT. WAS BEING
SOUGHT AFTER WAS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE SYSTEM FOR
VARIOUS. I'M INDUSTRY CAREER
PATHWAYS TO CREATE. A SEQUENCE
OF COLLEGE PREPARATORY COURSES
FOR THE HIGH SCHOOL. TO BE AN
ALTERNATIVE TO A THROUGH G. AND
TO COMPETE FOR THAT. NOW THAT
BILL HAD A FIVE YEAR LIFESPAN
IT WAS RENEWED IN TWENTY TEN.
BY SENATOR STEINBERG FOR
ANOTHER FIVE YEARS. AND DURING
THAT TEN YEARS. THE STATE
LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATED GOING
WITH THOSE BILLS AND SOME
OTHER- ONES THAT WERE ATTACHED
TO THAT WHOLE PROGRAM. CLOSE TO
BILLION DOLLARS AND WE NEVER
SAW. SEQUENCE WE NEVER HELD AN
ACCOUNTABILITY TO THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE SYSTEM. SO THAT WAS ONE
HEARING NOW IN TWENTY FIFTEEN
WHEN I WAS LOOKING TO COME FOR
A THIRD RENEWAL CENTER LEYVA
WAS GOING TO CARRY THAT OUT BUT
WHEN IT BECAME EVIDENT THAT THE
CAREER TECHNICAL EDUCATION HIGH
SCHOOL TEACHERS WERE GOING TO
OPPOSE THAT BILL WITHOUT
PERFORMANCE STANDARDS FOR THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CANCERS
OFFICE IT SENATOR. LEYVA IN THE
POWERS THAT BE DROPPED THAT
BILL BUT THE FUNDING THAT WENT
ALONG WITH THAT HAS CONTINUED
AS A BUDGET LINE ITEM. AND
ACTUALLY WITH THAT WHEN THAT
OCCURRED IN WITH THE- WE HAVE
WE HAVE WITH THE- HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHERS IN OPPOSITION WITH
THAT FINDING PIPELINE THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE CANCERS
OFFICE RETALIATED AGAINST THE
HIGH SCHOOLS BY. BY ELIMINATING
AS PART OF THAT APPROPRIATIONS
THE FUNDS THAT THEY WERE GIVEN
TO SUPPORT PARTNERSHIP
ACADEMIES WHICH WOUND UP WITH
THE LEGISLATURE CREATING
ANOTHER APPROPRIATION TO
CONTINUE THE FUNDING FOR THE
THOSE. ACADEMIES THAT WERE
FUNDED UNDER SB TEN SEVEN DAY.
SELL ANOTHER ISSUE THAT WAS ON
THAT AS FAR AS I'M HOLD DUAL
ENROLLMENT AS FAR AS ON THAT
AND ONE OF THINGS THAT AGAIN
THAT WASBEING ADVOCATED FROM
THE TRENCHES THE HIGH SCHOOL
TEACHERS WISE FOR ARTICULATION
AGREEMENT REFORM. THE REALITY
IS THAT DUAL ENROLLMENT IS NOT
GOING TO HAVE THE EFFECTIVENESS
THAT IS GOING TO BE NEEDED TO
FIT AND THE CULTURE OF THE HIGH
SCHOOL STUDENTS IN HIGH SCHOOLS
WHAT IS REALLY NEEDED IT IS
ARTICULATION AGREEMENT REFORM.
AS FAR AS ON ACT A. S. IS ON%
IT'S A VAT IS. A BIG THING
THAT- GOES ALONG WITH WITH THAT
AS AS FAR. AS I NEED- WHAT I
WOULD SAY IN GENERAL FROM THE
EXPERIENCE OF DEALING WITH
SCHOOLS AND BEING AND HIGH
SCHOOL CLASSROOMS. IS RIGHT NOW
WITH A LOT OF THINGS GOING THE
REPETITIVE TECHNOLOGICAL CHANGE
IS REALLY OUR K. TWELVE IS
DOING A MISERABLE JOB. OF
PREPARING OUR CURRENT CROP OF
STUDENTS FOR THE NEEDS OF Vì
ã KAHNEMAN. AND IT'S JUST
NOT THE TECHNOLOGY I MEAN WITH
A LOT OF THE ECONOMIC AND
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT PROGRAMS
THAT I GO TO THEY TALK ABOUT BY
THE MIDDLE OF THIS CENTURY THE
WORK FORCE IS GOING TO LOOK
VERY MUCH. LIKE A 50% OF SOME
SORT OF INDEPENDENT CONTRACTOR
TYPE SITUATION. AND EVERY TIME
I K. TWELVE HAS A DECISION TO
PROVIDE THAT TYPE OF CULTURE TO
FUNCTION AND THAT TYPE OF WORK
FORCE ENVIRONMENT AS I'VE BEEN
AROUND I WATCHED KATE TWELVE
INSTITUTIONALLY. MAKE THE WRONG
DECISIONS NOT PROVIDING SELF
MOTIVATION THAT THE
INDEPENDENCE THE RESILIENCY
THAT IS NEEDED. SOUTH FOR SHEET
THAT THAT HISTORY IT'S ALWAYS
MUCH MORE COMPLICATED THAN YOU
THINK IT IS RIGHT AS FAR AS ON
YOUR TASK LESS AS FAR AS YOU
KNOW HAVING AN AWARENESS OF
WHAT HAS BEEN DONE BEFORE AND
WHERE IT HAD FELT DEFICIENT. I
THINK NEEDS TO BE PAY ATTENTION
BEFORE WE SEND ANOTHER TEN
YEARS AND ANOTHER BILLION
DOLLARS I'M REPEATING WHAT HAS
NOT WORKED IN THE PAST RIGHT.
SHEET THAT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
THANK YOU. HYDRO KIRK I
REPRESENTING THE CALIFORNIA
MANUFACTURERS. IN TECHNOLOGY
ASSOCIATION. TRY TO BE BRIEF I
FIRST WANT TO COMMEND. V.
COMMITTEE TODAY FOR HALF
OPENING UP THIS CONVERSATION
IT'S CRITICALLY IMPORTANT
MANUFACTURING IS ONE OF THOSE
INDUSTRIES- THAT IS SUFFERING
FROM A SIGNIFICANT SKILLS GAP-
BUT WE'RE ALSO ONE OF THE
INDUSTRIES THAT IT'S BOTH
MAKING AND USING THE TECHNOLOGY
THAT IS TRANSFORMING OUR FUTURE
WORKFORCE WE OCCUPY AN
INTERESTING POSITION IN THIS
CONVERSATION WE WANTED TO AGAIN
COMMEND THE COMMITTEE FOR
STARTING THIS CONVERSATION WITH
HOUSING- FOR MANUFACTURING- IT
IT'S SOMETHING THAT- IS
CRITICALLY IMPORTANT ANY DRIVES
INVESTMENTS- IN WE PAY OUR
WORKERS ON AVERAGE JUST UNDER
NINETY K. YEAR OFTEN WELL INTO
THE SIX FIGURES. HOWEVER SOME
PARTS OF THE CITY THAT'S NOT
SOMETHING THAT ARE WAIT FOR THE
FAMILY- OVER A MODEST HOME A
CAR AND OTHER NECESSITIES- AND
THIS MEANS THAT MANUFACTURES
CAPABLE SORT OF WELL PAID JOBS
WITH BENEFITS- WITH LOW. IS OF
ENTRY. TO WORK IS THAT NEED
SKILLS IN ANY TRAINING- AND
THAT'S OF CRITICAL IMPORTANCE
AS WE'RE TALKING ABOUT I
TRADING OUR FUTURE WORKFORCE
BECAUSE- OF FOR MANY INDUSTRIES
LIKE MANUFACTURING A LOT OF OUR
TRAINING IS DONE IN HOUSE OF WE
CAN'T. ARE INVESTING
COMMUNITIES AND THE BILL THESE
FACILITIES TO TRAIN WORKERS I
WORK CRITICAL PIECE OF THE
PUZZLE THAT ISN'T PROVIDING THE
TRAINING THAT WE ALL MEET. AT
THE STATE MEET. AS PART OF THAT
CONVERSATION FLOWING FROM THE
CONVERSATION WE WOULD ENCOURAGE
AT FOLKS IS THERE CONSIDERING-
AFFORDABLE HOUSING TO CONSIDER
MANUFACTURING AS PART OF THE
CONVERSATION AROUND PLANNING
AND BUILDING- AS WAS ALLUDED TO
EARLIER IT IS AN UNSUSTAINABLE
MODEL FOR OUR WORK FORCED TO
SPEND TWO ORTHREE HOURS
DRIVING I FROM WHERE THEY CAN
AFFORD TO LIVE TO THE
COMMUNITIES ARE WE CAN AFFORD
TO BUILD WELL AS WERE BUILT
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. WE NEED TO
FIGURE OUT WAYS I HAVE AND
POLICIES THAT ENCOURAGE A
BUILDING- OF FACILITIES ARE
PEOPLE CAN WORK ALONG SIDE OF
WHERE THEY LIVE. OUT ONE FINAL
POINT AS THE KURDS INTENDING TO
DO- WE HOPE THAT YOU CONSIDER
THE MANY MODELS THAT THERE MAY
BE FOR THE FUTURE OF WORKFORCE
TRAINING. AYE MANUFACTURERS-
PARTICIPATE IN THE STATE'S
APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS WE HAVE
SEVERAL- WORKING- MODELS ONE IN
PARTICULAR DOWN- IN THE INLAND
EMPIRE THE INTAKE CENTER- THAT
EMERGE FROM MY PARTNERSHIP WITH
CALIFORNIA'S STEEL INDUSTRIES-
BUT WE FIND THAT MANY OF OUR
PARTNERSHIPS WITH COMMUNITY
COLLEGES WITH WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT BOARD. REMEMBER WE
HAVE BEEN ABLE TO PARTICIPATE
IN THE APPRENTICESHIP PROGRAMS
OFTEN ONE OFFICE- WE DON'T FIND
A LOT OF SUPPORT FOR- BUILDING
AND SCALING UP OF THE TESLA
MODEL THAT WE'VE EVELOPED SO.
I AM FOUND THAT CERTAIN STATE
PROGRAMS- WILL SUCCESSFUL FOR
SOME INDUSTRIES DON'T ONLINE
WITH THE NEEDS OF OUR INDUSTRY
SO AS THIS CONVERSATION
CONTINUES WE HOPE THAT YOU ARE.
CONSIDER THE MANY SUCCESSFUL
MODELS THAT ARE OUT THERE AND
USE THAT TO GUIDE SOME OF THE
<c.green>ONVERSATION POLICY. BUT THANK</c>
YOU GET FOR HAVING. THANK YOU I
APPRECIATE YOUR YOUR COMMENTS
HERE TODAY. AND ANY SUGGESTIONS
IN TERMS OF HOW WE- MAY I AM
SENSITIVE TO THE ONE OFF
FRANKLY I WAS GONNA SAY. JUST
BRING ALL OF THOSE JOBS. CENTER
CAP. OKAY DELIVERY. WITH IT
EARNING THE THOUSAND DOLLARS
BUT- BUT BUT BUT BUT AND I'M IN
ALL SERIOUSNESS THE OFF.
WORRIES ME BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
SUSTAINABLE AND SO THE QUESTION
BECOMES HOW DO WE
INSTITUTIONALIZE AND THAT'S
REALLY WHAT WE WERE GETTING TO.
WITH THE SECOND COMMITTEE IS.
WHAT WHAT ARE THE BARRIERS
THERE THAT WE HAVE IN STATE
LINE AND HOW CAN WE
INCENTIVIZE. THE BUSINESS
COMMUNITY TO COME FORWARD AND
HELP US TO CREATE THE MODEL
THAT ACTUALLY WORKS. THANK YOU
SO MUCH. FOR YOUR TESTIMONY IS
THERE ANYONE ELSE WOULD LIKE AN
OPPORTUNITY IS A FEW WORDS.
SAYING NO ONE ELSE THANK YOU
VERY MUCH FOR JOINING US HERE
TODAY THIS CONCLUDES OUR
HEARING